I
swear to God, I'm gonna fucking, oh my god, I'm, oh my god, I'm, oh, I swear to God, oh, it doesn't even work, doesn't even work, oh, whatever,
ah, I know, everyone, I'm so mad.
hello i'm jane silk song today i was supposed to dad was supposed to shoot his gun and i was gonna be like pop pop i'm gonna like it didn't work i couldn't get him he wouldn't shoot his gun why would you shoot your gun hello it is i jane silk i'm still trying to download this fucking game yet do i not pay with it's not accepting my money like i've been stuck on the paypal part like i've been stuck in payment method and i don't know what to do it's like they're like oh don't worry is this the pay i was like yes this is not payment and then and then it's just like sorry there's Eric.
I'll wait a couple of minutes.
And please accept my money.
I don't understand.
I'm so sad.
Oh, I'm too tall.
Give me a sec.
I want to be a little shorter.
But yes, you guys like a little surprise don't worry not only can he carry a gun he can also carry a knife to whenever we're in london he can be like welcome to london and then give you a good old london handshake uh
oh wait now i know why he's not he's not fucking waving his oh my god i forgot um i remember Okay, so for those who are wondering, this was made in a week because I saw, okay, I'll show you guys who the artist is.
This is the artist.
A huge shout out to the artist, Neo, for making this new skin suit, Jane Silk Song.
I am now hollowed Doki from the Dokiverse.
But she posted her own hollowed sona, I guess hollowed skin suit, a week ago.
And I like DM'd her and I was like, oh my god, can I have one too?
Do you, are your commissions open?
I would love to have one.
She's like, yeah, I can make it before silk song.
And I was like, oh, sweet.
And then, and so like, she basically was like, and then done.
And then here I am.
Here, here, shout out to all the fan artists, to all the fan artists that drew me and made their own Doki Night because like it was a great inspiration.
on what to look like so i just sent her like all the fan art and stuff and be like she's like you have a design i was like um i have a lot of fan art but oh my gosh so many guys drew dokey night so it helped a lot in like conceptualizing this so here i am but i remember she said something where i had to like open a a thing and then that would like link oh my god please let me pay please Let me,
oh my, okay, I was, okay, I'm gonna say it.
I think it's a fucking terrible idea that there was no pre-order.
I don't care if it, like, hikes for PR, whatever the fuck.
This is a terrible fucking, this is not good.
This is, I'm angry.
I told this to my friends, too.
They're like, oh my God, there's no pre-order.
Oh my, I was like, you do know.
With it not having a pre-order, they're like, oh, there's no pre-order.
everyone has a fair i was like you do know if there's no pre-order steam is gonna crash like i knew it was gonna crash i knew it because because everyone's talking about stuff it's been seven years it's been fucking seven years it's gonna crash there's no way the servers are going to be able to handle this and this is the one game that needed a pre-order and they didn't put to preach i can't even pay i accidentally added the game five fucking times because i was trying because they kept telling me oh shit my controller i need to close my door just in case my neighbors yell at me because it's seven in the morning i was so tired but this made me so awake and i actually added five the game five times because it was like oh um um there's an Aaron adding it,
but then it still added.
And then I was trying to remove the game, remove all four copies of the game, and then it took fucking forever to remove all the copies.
And then, and then after that, I actually removed all the games.
I accidentally removed all of them.
And so I had to re-add the game again
oh my god i have i'm trying to like fucking fight the system to even pay for this fucking game it won't it's like there shouldn't be an error um initially it's the high thing or updating your translation please wait a minute try again our content there's no there's no way to contact i know there's no way just fucking accept my fucking money
please let me let me play oh my god don't tell me they someone said they removed it from steam oh my someone gifted to me i'm joking no don't give it to me don't gift this game to me i just i'm so mad i'm angry eating
okay i need to read this how do i get it to work on control there I knew I forgot to I knew I forgot to something was missing I managed to open something um I have to open okay okay oh naru pad okay I was like what kind of pictures to work and I apparently have to download a goddamn plugin give me a sec um this tool is free okay cool all right how do I goddamn it okay there we go there you go um all right while i'm figuring out how to fucking pay for silk song i'm also downloading because there's more stuff i need to show you guys because i was gonna do like pop pop and then like um and then didn't pop because like i realized i did not download the plug-in for this to work all right download narupan this is the thing so it works don't worry it has like actual um it's sync to my controller there's something cool it's on god okay god tab yeah but then i have to fucking god then i have to create a fucking account of god i have to then i have to create an account on god and i have to worry
about that there's too many factors i'm just i'm doing this one by one first off let me figure out how to do naru pad or whatever all right let me hide myself real quick we gotta fix this whoa yeah that's the reason why i had to hide myself
there we go oh there you go so okay i wanted to start off the stream with this part okay i got it to work i was gonna start off the stream with this watch this i swear it still sucks on download now BOM!
Fucking jump, dude.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, pop, pop.
He's got a gun.
Oh my god.
Please just let me.
All right, let's see which is faster.
Steam accepting my PayPal or creating account on Gogg.
God, fucking it can't believe.
All right, authorize.
all right we're racing right now okay oh my god we're racing to see who's faster okay all right god god create okay creating account and then all right silk song add to cart check out now oh my god please don't tell me i should have just been i could have just been This entire time.
Yeah.
Damn it.
I could have been paying buying this on Gogg the entire time.
Oh my, okay.
Now, oh my God.
At least Gogg accepts my PayPal.
Oh my God.
There's people already 21 minutes deep into the Silk Song right now.
And I'm still here fighting the fucking processor.
All right.
Here we go.
Come on, You're winning the race.
Alright, use my Canadian money to pay for this.
Come on.
Install via Galaxy?
What the fuck is Galaxy?
Now I have to download Galaxy.
Oh, it's like Steam for God.
Okay.
I'm installing Galaxy now.
Alright, it looks like we might have to use Galaxy.
Alright.
Okay.
god goes faster you don't need yeah oh it's too late it's too late i i installed galaxy you don't it's too late it's already too late i went so far i'm desperate i'll let them install any malware they want as long as i can play silk song i will let them install anything on my account.
That's how desperate I am.
Alright.
Sign in via my Discord.
Authorize.
Get in here, Gog.
Get in here.
Alright.
There's my one own.
This is the one time.
Like Gog will receive like so many downloads on this one particular day.
and stuff give me give me give me give me i might buffer i might start buffering because i have because whenever i install stuff on steam i start buffering on stream so we'll see how this goes where the fuck is my game i said installed how do i know it's installed oh there it is oh 33 oh my god that one day Gogg receives like 80% plus traffic.
Just Steam.
Steam still refuses to accept my money.
Oh my god, they have to boot up fucking Gogg all the time.
You can't capture Galaxy installed.
Excuse me.
What?
What do you mean?
I...
Wait, what?
Why did I buy it on Gogg?
I can't install.
Oh, my, is that true?
Am I getting one, God?
Please tell me, for the 10 people that uses Gogg and streams, is that true?
The 10 people that use Gogg and stream, I need a no.
I...
There it is.
Please, please tell me Is that at chat?
Is that true?
It was not true.
You fucking liar.
I'm jumping not because I'm happy.
I'm jumping because I have to.
Yippee.
Okay, now I'm happy.
Yippee, yippee, yippee.
Yippee.
Oh my God.
Oh, here.
Sook song is finally real.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
It's an Espanola.
I jumped too much.
And now it's in Spanish.
Reduce.
Back.
We're in.
It took 25 minutes.
I'm God gaming now.
I'm trying to remember.
I think this was 8.
And this was 10.
I'm pretty sure.
All right.
Sound guy.
This is your time.
I need a gnome.
I think this was...
Oh, yeah.
Okay, we'll do it now.
Alright, I gotta make sure.
Video, borderless.
Ah, borderless is fine.
Blur quality.
Okay, low.
We don't need blur.
Okay, maybe we need to cap the frame rate.
Yeah.
Alright.
wins again why do i why am i hopping so much because i'm happy it finally installed i'm so it's time to give up on steam it's time it we have it's time to give up it's not gonna work it's it's time to give up today is a gog day yeah today is a gog is the only way to get this to work they see your beauty so frail and fine they see your peace woven in a faith and toil they forget your heart bound and slumber in servitude when you wake they shall see your truth a beast nature bare to all from oh okay from this guy i don't know who this guy is
all right here we go finally silk song on gog
it's me I'm so happy we did it we battled through Gog it only took 25 minutes it only took 20 minutes of struggling on steam and then Gog wins the race in 5 in like 3 minutes
it's Jane it's Jane Silken song i
told you not having pre-orders and just fucking dropping it exactly as it was i think that's bad pr everyone's like oh my god i can't believe they're just gonna drop it with the pre-orders that's so fucking sick of this so hardcore i like it and i'm just like they don't understand they don't understand it's gonna crash it's gonna be like 2000 when everything when Okay,
2K, Y2K.
They gave us Y2K on Steam.
They didn't listen to me.
Oh, Fire Loom.
Is this a prequel?
I think it is, because, like, seems like a prequel because there was Silk there.
For Silk Song.
Where were you when Silk Song killed?
What?
Hey, that's me.
I should be allowed to use a gun.
Just like dad.
Gun, gun!
Pop!
Alright.
I jump, she jump.
So immersive.
Okay.
Oh, she's like... Oh, she's on a shrimp.
Look at her.
She runs like a shrimp, too.
I first pick up a Glock.
Pop, pop.
What if I can?
Oh, I...
Okay, okay.
Wait, I have something special to show you guys out to.
Watch this.
Birds are singing.
You're gonna have a bad time.
Bum, bada, bada.
Okay.
There you go.
Sorry, I had to.
I had to.
Oh, shit.
She has like...
She can dangle off a cliff.
There you go.
I'm sorry.
Dan Stokey Bird is real.
Okay, I thought I could kill that one, too.
I was like, no bug left behind.
No way, he also, dad also has a normal knife.
A normal knife when we're in London.
Okay, there you go.
Where's this?
What's this?
Oh, it's just, uh...
It just feels a little weird.
The frames do feel a little weird.
I'm going to put it to...
I'll put it at 120.
And see if that's better.
The frames do feel a little weird, doesn't it?
Alright.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
It full healed.
No.
No bug left up at high.
It full heals when you charge it up.
It feels a little slow.
But I don't know.
because i'm taller now i can't tell i can't tell if it's because i'm taller and that's why it feels a little no v-sync is off um but it does it feels i'll do it does feel uh uh it does feel like i'll put free cap off maybe that's better okay i'll just do this for now
Oh no, I tripped.
Don't worry, I'm okay.
Oh no, never mind.
I'm too tall.
My bones are too fragile.
It feels too fragile.
Don't worry, I'm okay.
I'm okay now.
Wait, what's down here?
Oh, I knew it.
I knew there was something over there.
What is that?
Rosary string.
You can't double jump yet.
Sadly.
My bones are too frail for that.
What is that?
Worm string holding a...
Can be broken and the loose...
Oh, it's for trading.
Alright.
Catling bugs?
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
What the fuck does Scott combo me?
I like, okay, I like the quality of life changes.
I like the quality of life changes where when you charge it up, it heals everything.
So, every, you get, you don't have to charge it one by one.
That's nice.
I like that.
That's called being, that's like the, the tall buff.
Don't worry, I can be tall just like you watch this.
Wait, why am I not tall?
Wait.
there you see that you see that I can be tall just like her I can I can what's it called it extract no what's the word retract I can retract and extract my legs just like you Jane Stuck sign extendo oh my frail brittle bones
my leg extension surgery oh wait if if neil is watching right now i forgot to ask for like a toggle where i can just remove dad i'll be like oh there's a chair nice oh look at me i don't know you know if you're here right now i forgot to ask what can i want to remove him sometimes if he's a bad boy.
Seen payment.
You should have went to Gag.
You all saw.
And you could have been here too.
Why would you remove him?
He has a gun.
Oh, is that the boss?
Okay, first boss.
Oh.
Oh, that's weird.
So I have my, I have the dash, but I'm, I don't know how to control that yet.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Do I only have, can I not?
Okay, I can't, okay, so it's literally, it's only dash.
I'm, yeah.
Okay, you can't go straight down.
I have, I was trying to test it if I can go straight down you can't go straight down you can only it's just literally yeah it's just literally that it's just a dive kick you can't pogo there's no pogoing now which is I will say it is a little annoying that I can't pogo I like pogoing yeah no pogo for now it could be an ability later but for now she can only dive Yeah,
they nerfed...
They nerfed Pogo.
Yeah, see, like, I can...
I was like, wait a minute.
Why can't I...
Why can't I Pogo?
It literally is straight down.
You can't do any other way.
Yeah.
Pogo was too OP.
Also, are any of my sound guys alive?
Okay, that boss was fucking easy.
Uh...
Is the sound good?
Oh my god, I can't jump anymore.
My bones.
My bones so weak.
What?
We boys were supposed to be this tall.
Sound is good?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Grandma.
Granny.
Hello.
I'll wake you up.
I won't have any dying on my floor.
Awake, at last.
You should mind your shrink, traveler.
There's no use wasting energy on old nobody like me.
I see that now, madam.
My welcome to your land has not been kind.
I had a reason to be wary.
So you're another pilgrim then.
You just got out of the darkness to climb the great path and bow has...
skilled at peak.
Oh, I talk too?
Oh, it's because I'm not hollow.
I have a soul.
I have actual personality.
How dare she have a personality?
How would I impose my beliefs on you?
I am no pilgrim.
I am hornet.
And I arrive in your land by no choice of my own.
I was brought to your kingdom, my forest, captured by strange bugs, clad, and veils.
oh how curious the bugs of the citadel at the summit of our land they veiled themselves in service to their fate or perhaps as slaves to something greater then i shall seek their citadel and these veiled bugs would go to such lengths to bring me here i intend to find out why oh ferocious intimidating There is no pilgrim spirit.
You're the bearing of a hunter.
Welcome, then, fierce traveler, to Fireloom, our holy yet haunted land.
Before you depart, permit an old bug a brief warning.
Best keep that weapon down.
Our kingdom is gripped by a curse.
It's past go wild and dangerous.
some still attempt to climb to the citadel and its crest none return to speak of what they see i'm not gonna i'm not gonna put down my weapon i have a right to bear arms pop pop
back in hollowness i can carry my gun wherever i go pop pop
you very played well and you skill no doubt I don't mean any unkindness when I say you say you still seem a little frail I was a long time I was a long time spent captive bound by seal string to me my strength is diminished but recoverable by time I reach that citadel I'll be ready to face what waits all right let's go I like how she goes like trip mode when she runs there's like a little Naruto run oh okay i can up the audio just a little i can up it to here i don't know if that's too loud though it's very loud on my end when i do that i'll just do actually i'll do like nine and then i'll up overall volume on discord or not on the skirt sorry on obs uh there you go maybe that would be better there you go yeah that might be better Let me know that's better.
I'll go down now.
Oh, that's where I live.
Okay.
I'll just fall straight down, I guess.
I don't know.
I assumed that was the right way to go.
It seemed like it.
How was I supposed to know?
Okay, at least I know how to get there.
It's so weird not being able to...
I think it is a little weird not being able to...
Oh, what's the word?
To not be able to pogo.
Yeah.
I'm not used to it.
I've been pogoing for so long.
I can't believe they nerfed pogo.
Pogo too strong!
A patch notes hit hard!
Okay, I wanted to check if there was a secret there.
No, it's just a dash.
It's a dash jump, so you know what she's like?
Adidas!
There you go.
She just can't look- Oh wait, there's something- how do I get- Okay, I must be- I must have to do like...
Adidas!
Oh my god.
Oh, I can...
Oh!
Okay, I can mid-heal.
That's cool.
I like that.
Oh.
Actually, I didn't go this way.
Fuck!
Wait, do I need a dash for this?
Let's see.
Or can I just...
Okay.
It's so awkward when you can't pogo.
I'll see it.
It really is very awkward when you can't pogo.
Oh my god.
I feel like I have...
Oh, that was...
Wait, what?
Oh my god, it was nothing.
It was just extra money.
There was nothing, yeah?
It's diagonal, pogo, yeah.
It's so weird, though.
Okay.
Okay, so it's full heal, no matter...
Jesus Christ, Jane, you're OP as fuck.
Hold on, I have to do it one...
Back in my day, like last week.
Back in my day.
Last week, it's a full heal no matter how big the...
No matter how big the thing is.
Last night.
Alright.
Seven years.
Yeah, no.
Lucky for me, I just started playing Hollow Knight last week.
Yippee!
Back in my day.
One week.
exactly one week ago I can't get it I'm too I'm too short the one time I'm too short not one time I'm just too short all right off I'll go don't jump into the hole again what is that just don't jump into the hole and everything will be Hello?
Going bottom.
Yeah.
Hmm.
A fellow pilgrim.
Are you about to start your great journey to the holy city up top?
I am no pilgrim, sir.
Though it seems we'll be traveling a similar path.
I'm not a pilgrim.
Well, it makes no difference, I suppose.
We all must walk the roads up and up.
Though most of us will fall long before we see the grand gates.
If you're wise, you'll stop here and rest a while.
We're heading out into that dangerous world.
Alright, I sit.
I sit.
What else?
Rest here with me as long as you like.
I'm not ready to leave yet.
Top.
Yeah, I can talk.
Where are you?
Peb.
Oh, traveler.
Destined for the Citadel, yes?
Well, where are you in park?
Won't you stop and make a trade with an old pilgrim?
I'd see your wares, madam.
Though I fear I may have nothing worth for you to offer in return.
Oh, where are you not?
Do you like buying goods to trade?
we can barter still in this devout land we deal in the currency of faith oh we're are we are we killing religious bugs rosaries this finally card beats a prayer if you only share some with me i will trade you something fair okay what i have 300 this stone's a beauty isn't it they still help you gather up Who the bugs?
Praise the bug!
They say it'll help you gather up rosaries on the road ahead.
You'll come back and share some with me, won't you?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I... Wait, no, I have to...
Wait, okay, I gotta go back... Wait.
Okay, there you go.
That's like 30.
Okay, that was just 30.
I don't have more.
I'm sorry.
Wait, do I have anything?
Let's see.
There's a mask.
The shinier...
Okay.
Okay, so this is for upgrading now, I assume.
And then there's a key.
Hey, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Subscribe to Doki.
Most importantly, remember to like the stream and comment from time to time.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Hey, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
You won't go losing them.
It might seem, but it takes some time to keep him properly secure.
Oh, so you can...
I see.
So you can, like, find your rosaries.
You might lose them.
What's this your building, sir?
Oh, there's Flick, the Fixer.
A sign of some kind?
Aye, aye.
You're a sharp bug.
A wish wall.
It's past time.
This old camp had one.
As the resident fixer, I've taken it upon myself to sort it out.
Your popular thing about Farloom, wish walls, useful too.
So many prayers.
left unanswered.
Gives him a place to go.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's like wish shit here too.
There's nothing here.
Go this way.
Whoa.
He's like a dangerous place.
Okay, so we're either stopping a cult or we're going to kill someone else's guide.
It's one or the other.
It could be both.
It could be a it could be both a cult and we're going to kill a god we only have one god here and this uh the white prince or whatever his name is it's it's like her dad my dad's the god here how dare these bugs not follow my dad's law
oh shit okay all right
all right there you anything else here I'm still I I'm sad Adidas
Okay nice Oh this has to be a god fight Or like a boss fight Oh wait it's just one guy Stupid Oh never mind Oh oh it's a trap There we go I missed the Pogo.
Me too.
That's stupid.
Oh shit!
It's fine.
I don't want to heal just yet.
Because I can't Pogo, I need to be more, like, understand where I am at all times.
Which is a little...
Oh, whoops.
Okay, I guess I can't do that.
I guess I missed.
Oh, nice.
Yoink.
My rosaries now.
So now there's two types of currencies.
One is this, and the other one is the...
Oh, hey.
Who are you?
Hey, did you see it?
Red maiden?
The great gate heard my song, and in its infinite age, you kind of opened the way forward for us.
What luck for us to meet at this moment!
We can set off on a great road together!
Or perhaps, I'll tarry you just a little longer.
I want to sing a song of gratitude to this noble gate.
I'm Sherma, by the way.
Just another humble pilgrim like yourself.
If you ever need assistance on the road ahead, sing out my name, and I'll be sure to find you.
Me and my lucky charm are at your service.
Also, Recycle Bin, they got five gifted ships they can take you.
Sherma?
No, Sherma.
Yay, gate, gate, gate Nice to skate I've met Yay, gate, gate Greatest miracle yet Ha ha ha!
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
A little stupid, but she's got the spirit, you know?
She is the loo-loo.
They're dumb but cute.
I'll spare her.
I get, we'll spare her because she's just a cute little dumb bug.
Okay, we gotta grab the rosaries.
I'm gonna rob these religious bugs of their rosaries.
Okay, I'll sit down here.
Insert rosaries.
Oh.
Okay.
What the fuck?
I was gonna say, is that my chair?
Oh, it's just here.
Alright, wait.
Is she still back there singing to the gate?
Let's check.
I feel like we're killing a god.
I feel like we're going to kill the god of whatever this cult worships.
Oh, she's god.
My bullets over here, though.
shortcut I see I just didn't yeah it's called pay to sit oh I could talk to her before I was there I didn't realize she was there all right don't worry Doki Knight is here they should add a gun though they should you're blessed to walk the foundations of our loom humble yourself before the shells of those who gave their lives to hold our kingdom's weight.
Who gave dad a gun?
He has the right to bear arms tomorrow.
There you go.
Go this way.
Where's our map guy?
I can't open a map.
I swear to God, if I don't have a map, I'm gonna, oh, I'm gonna.
I have yet to, there's no ability to open a map yet.
Oh my god.
Not being able to Pogo is...
It's like fucking with me right now.
Not being able to Pogo.
This is like...
I had to do like a dash kick.
There you go.
This is like the closest I can to Pogo.
I don't miss hit... I don't miss Cornelius, okay?
I just wish he didn't have a fucking monopoly of maps.
Like...
That's different.
Alright.
These platforms are brittle as fuck, just like my bones.
Thankfully, you never once got lost ever.
Holy shit, he does double the damage.
Because look how tanky he is.
When I heal, I yell out.
okay yeah that means i'm gonna go this way because there's a platform higher so i knew it i was like there has to be an item here uh eating thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you yeah i never get lost oh nice okay i have a crest i have a crest now what's my crest warm but allows one to collect more shells shards from oh okay let's get shell shards
I still don't know what the shell strides are for.
Because, like, the currency here are, like, rosary beads.
I wonder what they're for in this game.
I can still go up, but I won't go this way first.
Okay.
Oh.
He has, like, blades on his shell now.
Okay.
The worst part of playing on launch is that no one knows where they go.
You see, if All I'm saying is If it wasn't on the Oh my, I can't dash yet She doesn't know how to dash Her legs are too long No one can help me What's that?
I don't know what that sign None of us know what the sign means I didn't
We don't know what that sign means.
Where am I?
I don't know.
Oh my god, I did a loop.
We're in the Metrovania part now.
I'll go this way.
I'm at the ground floor now.
Alright, I go this way then.
What does it mean?
Oh, we don't get one guy out of not upgrading your nail this time.
Yeah, Meti!
Okay, this way.
Oh, look, I can float.
Mm-mm.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, this way.
I guess I had to go back up.
Because there's, like, nothing here.
So I assume it's up.
I'm gonna skip these guys.
There's no point.
Fuck the skull in particular.
The glass, thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Ah!
I hate that.
I hate it.
I'm like reflex pogo-ing right now.
Alright, here.
I was looking at my other skin, got jump scared.
I've been framed again.
You've been framed by your fellow.
The only reason why I called you up was because I was looking at Twitter and everyone said it was Medi's fault.
So I just assumed you were the main culprit.
Because I said rat somebody.
And everyone on Twitter was like, I can't believe it was Medi that said that.
Like I said, I was like, you'll always blame.
Um, not me.
I pulled this from chat.
That was this.
I go back in here.
Now I'm getting...
Oh, shit.
Nice.
The bones of the dead monks that I can rob.
It's okay.
I don't believe in their god, so I can't go to their hell.
My god is literally my dad.
If you think of...
Oh!
Where am I?
Where did that?
Take me
My dad owns my heaven Yeah, my dad my god can beat up your guy What the fuck are these?
Oh, hello.
Oh Poshanka edge is sharp and sensitive keen.
In my land, that is the way warriors greet each other, for though you were a child barely hatched, you were also a warrior.
Your stance, your weapons, your movement all proclaim it so.
You have keen sight for my skill, bug, but my childhood has long since passed.
What has happened here?
I see signs of battle all around.
These strange, shuffling pilgrims in the camp below, They were docile enough, but up here, they seem to have lost their senses.
They cry out to the darkness and attack their fellow travelers.
Akanesh, keep your weapon drawn and your bearings true.
The way ahead is winding, and to lose one's way invites only death.
I am a navigator amongst my tribe.
Oh, she's a new...
Oh, my improvement.
I told you guys.
They made so much quality of life changes.
She is a quality life change.
I can't believe it.
They did everything.
She's our new map girl.
A new map lady.
No, couldn't you?
And supplies, if you wish.
Oh my god, big straw lady.
all right let's see where's the map moss lands map quill oh my god i don't have enough big strong lady is extorting me right now wait i don't even know what land i'm in am i in tomorrow map i'm in tomorrow right this is tomorrow okay guys right i don't know mike thank you for the gift and Thank you,
thank you.
Goodbye, Cornelius.
You got...
I got an upgrade now.
Alright, nice.
I don't have enough for a quill.
Alright, press...
Oh my god.
Big strong lady is extorting me for money.
And these lands name are given freely, are they not?
I am Sharka.
Wealding wings.
If our hunt intertwines again, I will have new maps to trade.
Until then, farewell, child-wielding needle.
Wait, how am I going to find you again?
Who are you calling for, Sharka?
Your voice echoes through the caverns.
I came deeper into Farlum in search of my mentor, the greatest of my tribe.
I could not keep Peso and her trail grew grown.
So she will have traveled much farther by now, but if I keep moving and stay vigilant, with her okay I am broke shell markers bench pins compass okay I am broke why do you take the currency of whoa oh my god this is definitely a quality of life change okay almost a quality of life change oh what did she draw this with a fucking crayon?
Is it?
This was drunk with a goddamn crayon.
Like, what am I looking at?
at least she sings for you.
She drew, I swear, this looks like she drew it with a goddamn rock or a crayon or something.
Okay, there's a bench here.
Well, there is a bench by a cat.
Paper is hard to come by.
I'm not talking about paper.
Look at this map.
Look at what she drew.
Okay, this is the moss lands now.
Hello.
What the fuck?
Did you guys see that?
Oh, wait.
They have rosaries.
Oh my god.
It's time.
Oh.
Oh, this is a prequel.
This is a prequel.
Look, look the silk thread.
I don't know.
I still can't tell.
This feels like a prequel.
I'm still like not 100% sure.
Oh my god, they're actually crazy bugs.
They can be saved.
I don't think so.
Okay.
Oh, I can't tell.
It feels like a prequel with how everything is.
It could be a prequel sequel.
Yeah, a chair.
Okay, now I can equip this.
How does this equip work?
You can tell it was a prequel because they haven't learned how to draw yet.
Papa Smurf, thank you, the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Okay, I can...
Alright, I can farm these guys.
Oh, I have enough.
I have enough for a quill now.
Happens around this.
There's no way I travel.
I can travel all the way to this new land while John Hollow Knight is doing all that shit.
I'll soon leave the crumbling roads, but if you stop by the southern bull, we may meet again.
I pass there often to trade with the pilgrims.
Yeah, I need a quill.
Nice.
All right, you stay here.
I'm gonna beat up more monks.
all right okay now oh okay so when i don't so she sold me a blink she sold me like okay all right sure that's fine i got my i got my quill my quill vlc i need a compass yeah i got beat i got beat up more monks give me a sec It takes time.
Jesus, it sounds so pathetic.
When?
Okay, I need, like, a rosary collector thing.
Okay, how much do I need?
It was 70, right?
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, I'm here to hustle.
Yeah, I need the other map, too.
But, like, I can collect that later.
This is... Alright.
is more important okay so the thing is i notice is that is that it goes up to two wait oh did i kill them uh oh i gotta reset it with the bench all right i'll go back to the bench
all right give me a sec i gotta reset the monks real quick give me a sec i gotta rob them just rob them a little more i gotta buy a compass i don't care i'm farming i need the compass i don't know where i am okay it's not that hard to farm this at least
okay it's 70 right i'm just gonna do two at the time i'll keep i'll just beat up this one guy i don't want to walk too far i
farmed and bought the whole shop and you just beat up these poor monks you're like oh my god she's back please stop you're like i just this is where i live now
um zelzi thank you for the super shout thank you thank you hello donkey bird is this all yes i am why does he sound like that it is a it is honestly a gift to god that i'm beating them up that's why he sounds like that um uh who created the design of my new skin suit of jokey night uh neopal um i uh i can show like the thing later at the end of the stream um but i showed
all right oh okay for us in the bench don't worry i'm coming back i'm gonna put it's groundhog day for the these two it's no i need you you don't i need that other map too he's he should be honored it's a gift from god that i'm here to beat him up every day not even every day every 10 seconds i'm like come back to life it's time for your regular beatings
there you go this is actually like um money glitch what is it called unlimited money glitch
that's right you should have believed in my god my dad should have believed in my dad instead of this false god Then the beatings will stop.
The beatings will continue until my wallets, my wallets fall.
Here we go.
There we go.
I don't know how much I can buy now.
I don't know if there's an actual efficient way.
infinite money.
I don't know if there's an actual if... No, we'll do one more.
One more for the road.
Efficient way to do this.
But like, for now I'm doing it like this.
This is...
Alright, now I'll buy.
I'll buy my compass and my map.
A lot, lot, lot.
See, Cornelius didn't sing for us.
This is a quality of life change.
Cartography, pah, bakalo, is a craft skill common amongst my tribe.
Most important to keep one's mind sharp when on a journey.
The charting of caverns, the memory of travel, the knowing of one place within the kingdom, an engaging task for a warrior's mind.
And a fortunate thing that my great mentor never liked the skill.
The talent at getting lost, I should almost be impressed.
She's me!
yeah okay 70 only that and then we'll also need this the bench bins and then it's time 40 more don't worry don't worry i'm back don't worry my fellow monks i'm back i need my money did you pay your protection money yet that's right the protection money is gonna protect you from me
need for you.
She's back.
I ain't done with you.
That's right.
Come back alive.
It's collection time.
There we go.
I wonder if it's faster if I do this.
It's almost done.
Don't worry, we need like 40 more.
Because I need my Moss Lab maps, too.
This doesn't end until the big strong lady is satisfied.
Alright, every little bead counts.
Yeah, that's right.
They have debts to pay.
I'm a debt collector.
I hear you.
We need like, I think it's like two more.
One more time.
I'm literally like...
I'm literally like three beads off.
I lie, lie.
Oh!
At least we know exactly where the map woman is.
Alright, that's enough.
I'll just kill this one for fun.
That's right.
I might... I had enough beads.
But this time, this is for pleasure.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, mama.
Alright, here we go.
I soon leave.
Oh, there we go.
Alright, now we're fine.
Oh, I didn't even need...
Oh, it was $40.
Whoops.
They were both for pleasure.
It was actually $40.
Oopsie.
All right, we'll go this way.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, this is a boss fight.
Unless...
Don't worry, I'll free you.
Okay, never mind.
Just stay stuck, I guess.
I'm not strong enough.
Never mind.
I'm not strong enough!
What am I supposed to do?
wait where's my compass oh my god i gotta sit down jesse welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome i forgot to i forgot to put on my compass
uh where is it oh i have only one unlock i still don't okay this is an interesting okay this is interesting I'm here now.
I need to learn the song.
I need to learn the silk song.
Oh my god.
I need to learn actual silk song for that.
Wait, is she also crazy?
Oh my god.
Okay.
So these are also crazy, guys.
When...
Oh!
Shit!
I was not expecting her to fucking projectile vomit me there.
That's fucked up.
How do I- That's it.
Really?
Oh, it does three healing.
Okay.
Now I know.
I'll put in that.
Fuck this whore.
I'm not dealing with that shit.
Oh, oh, there's a trap there.
I'm not.
I need to remember I can't dash jump.
Or I can't pogo.
I need to remember that.
Weaver of our loom.
By grace you're warded.
By thread you heal.
For your favor, internal.
We offer our song.
Oh.
This is where I learned these silkside.
Okay.
I wonder what the...
I still don't know what the...
Oh shit.
I thought I was being...
Clever.
Okay.
I assume this is where I have to learn the Silk Song.
I'll learn it for here.
Oh my god.
At least I got money though.
Nice.
That's right!
It's time to rob you!
Nobody- oh shit!
Nobody is safe from me.
friend I like how I say friend after I killed him it's like I don't understand why can't I make friends is this silk song daughter of a distant land we have remained we who remain have waited long find our strength to yours reclaim the future of our haunted kingdom I'm gonna learn Adi us yeah this is a prequel is
steam actually still crashing found the silk skill attack by throwing a needle forward yeah no this is i think it's a prequel now for sure because i this is a needle throw
it's still down should have gouged it all right rb
Still no Pogo.
There you see.
Oh my god, it's this!
Hi!
Did they regrow?
No.
Might use this.
Oh!
It uses my thread.
Okay, nice.
Okay, so it uses my...
that.
Wait, is there still people?
Okay, I need more, I need, um, I don't have, wait, can I farm it off of these?
Oh, I can.
Oh, nice!
I can farm my thread off of the silk.
Okay.
What's my other charm?
They're gonna need a four-way force, amplify.
Oh, wait, no.
I already have that.
Who's over here?
Oh, it's a witch.
Burner.
Oh, it's a druid.
Her name's Moss, the druid.
What is it?
An intruder.
Terrible to interrupt.
A humble druid as they work.
I meant no intrusion, druid.
The sound of your laughter drew me to investigate.
This settlement is built around an old structure of the weavers.
Do you know of them?
Do they inhabit this land still?
Hmm?
My gentlemen!
What weavers?
You speak nonsense.
You're here and here.
So why did they send you?
Did you hear my wish?
Grant your wishes.
You?
Grant your wishes?
Wishes, yes!
My wish!
I need fruits of the world.
Do he little darling?
I need them so I wish does the kingdom not send you that I want you to grant my desire promise wish sure oh I have a gathering mission now berry picking wish promise I'm promised and the binding is stronger than sin bring me three precious fruit grant my wish and then the work begins she's manifesting i manifest destiny i am destiny um all right rady thank you for the super chat thing thank you a big old you said you upgraded pc to 128 gigs of ram i have some bad news having four sticks a ddr can actually it's okay no don't say that it's working don't say that I refuse to believe
It's working fine My speed has not been It has not been Not fine yet so far It's fine It's been working so far
It's one guy exactly It's like that one guy that was like Oh, you can't stream God game There you go I saved you Okay Give me a sec Bum
You should be burning in hell Oh shit Oh shit I was fucking around Oh shit Oh, he does two hits!
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
I think this is my first death.
Oh, I fucked up.
That's not what I was trying to do.
Oh, my God.
First death.
It's sun sun.
My rosaries!
My god, I dropped all my rosaries on the floor!
Oh, it's a cocoon.
Oh, that's...
Oh, that's interesting.
It's a cocoon.
He doesn't fight me back.
Okay.
Oh my, I think the hard part is I can't dash yet.
That's the hard part.
Wait, what?
I wasn't even holding.
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah.
I can't pogo.
So I gotta be like really careful.
Bum, bum, bum.
Alright, I can dash for that.
I'm 1 HP and I dream right now.
I...
Okay.
I can do a hit there.
And then when he's...
slap.
Okay, nice.
Oh, new move.
New move.
What's that?
Oh, it's gong time.
Bum, bum, bum.
Alright.
New move.
Ah!
Shit!
Jump too late.
Jump too early.
Okay.
I was trying to heal, but But then I got distracted by the gongs.
It was like, gong, gong.
I can't believe.
I saved his life and he fights back.
I don't like the two hits.
I think you guys might notice that when I get hit by two damage, it throws me off a lot in general.
When it's like one hit characters, I'm fine.
I don't know why.
The two hits messes me up so much.
Just don't get hit.
Yeah Just don't get hit Doki.
It's just that easy.
Just don't get hit
I wonder that's how much damage that does I wonder if that does that more damage than More damage than regular hit
Because I think I think if he doesn't do two hits I could have I think I could have killed him easily when it's two.
Yeah, see that?
The fact that I can't Pogo really fucking sucks.
Alright.
Oh, one extra.
Okay, he does an extra now.
Oh, fuck.
Hit this one.
Okay.
just don't panic just don't panic just don't panic gun gun gun gun okay oh i got gunned
okay i can't i need my thread has to be full thank you oh my god no
oh the extra guy the extra guy
Oh My my threat has to be full for me to heal never mind.
I don't like I don't like that I don't like that it has to be full for me to heal It's actually like really annoying Yeah, it's very scary Yeah, I can't heal at all Oh no That's so close.
Oh, I could have died I actually could have died there.
I...
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, it's all or nothing.
That was close.
I risked it all.
There you go.
I'm done.
I'm done having...
I'm done giving him a bad time.
I want a super saiyan there.
Oh, I'm having a vision.
Arrived at last.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm going a little crazy.
The gods are speaking to me right now.
I am the new guy.
Come, child.
Witness are waking.
Alright.
Now you can start shanking, Dad.
Breaking the power to regenerate silk within one shell.
What's that?
Consume the silk heart.
What did I do?
Witness me!
Hello?
Wake up.
Jane?
What does that do?
Oh, now you're okay with me?
Oh!
Oh, she's my new tramp!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Bad dog!
I saved your life!
Bad!
Now take me to the...
Now take me to the bone bottom.
Yeah!
Whoa.
Hello.
Beast.
Bees.
Horrible beast.
Oh.
Alright, now who's a good boy?
Who's a good boy?
That's right.
You are.
You're a good boy.
Yes, you are.
Yes, you are!
Yeah!
Alright, now never fucking hit me again.
Yippee!
That's right.
Alright, we go this way.
Okay, now we open our own trans system.
Can't believe he, like, fought back after I freed him.
Okay.
What's that?
I just pressed that button without thinking.
What do I do?
Oh, gone!
Gone!
Oh, my chair.
Oh, nice.
Pretty fucking elaborate for a chair, but alright, I'm complaining.
I like that when I die, it's a cocoon.
Because it's a lot easier to handle.
Versus, uh...
Oh my god, I keep forgetting.
I keep forgetting I can't pogo.
Oh shit, it's like reflex, you know?
At that point, it just feels like reflex.
Krish, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just so used to doing it.
That was forget.
Jesus Christ, these guys do.
Alright.
Friend!
Wait, I actually don't know.
know what I got.
What was the move that I got?
Wait.
Control it.
What?
What did it give me when I went like crazy?
What does the silk heart do?
Did it tell me what it did?
Oh, regen silk.
Okay.
Well, it's not doing it.
Okay, this i need it so eventually i can wall jump in the air and the water everywhere inside a shell twists inside guts tightest around heart heart pulsing rhythms sick alive dead something worse deeper must look deeper
just one single wow one single silk oh my god you shouldn't have oh my what an honor my one silk okay my one silk regen you shouldn't have yeah I'll be very careful here like I said oh shit at least I can regen in midair that's nice I like that I like that I can regen in mid-air.
The one thing I don't like is that it has to be a full bar of silk if I want to be able to...
Oh my god.
That agno move.
God damn it!
Okay.
Fuen!
I'm going down.
Why did it take me up here?
Hmm.
It took me up here, but there's nothing here.
That's weird.
I'll go back and see.
When?
Oh!
Okay, I see it.
I see it.
There's something on the top right.
Like, a bit to the middle.
I was like, where the fuck do I go?
I still don't know what to do with the shards.
And you guys were like, pick it up.
But I'm like, what do I do with it?
I missed it again.
I had to land on that particular platform.
Oh my god, I can't wait for my double jump or dash.
I can't wait for my otter of those things.
I hope I get double jump or dash.
Okay.
Maybe it's a nail upgrade.
Okay, I'm just gonna look down.
Alright, there you go.
There he is.
Oh, it's the new grub!
What are they?
Oh, they're like dogs!
Oh!
That's cute.
They're the new grub.
They're like dogflies.
Wait, was there anything up here?
No.
God damn!
I keep forgetting.
No Pogo.
There you stuff when?
No Pogo allowed.
I'll get used to it.
It's not now.
Alright, right side.
Alright, gotta kill.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, can't even rob him.
Sad.
Can't even rob the religious zilots.
Zilots?
Is that how they pronounce it?
What's the point?
Can't even rob them.
Oh, okay, that was a sick move I just did.
Zilots?
Yeah, he took his valuables to a goddamn grave.
It's like, you ain't robbing me!
The money dies with me!
It's like when you die, you just like throw all your money into the lava or something.
You just burn it all or some shit.
Oh!
The money's up top too.
There's like shells.
The money is...
are the bodies of the dead bugs.
Cool.
Alright, this way.
Nice.
What's this?
Is that one of the missions?
The wish things?
What is this?
I can't open it.
It must be something in the future.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna pull a heal.
When?
No.
Not Pogo.
See?
It's something I can do later on, I think.
Yeah, because I can't activate it yet.
It won't let me activate.
So I assume that it's something in the future.
Alright, right side.
Right side, right side.
Hello?
Oh!
I got two damage?
Oh my god!
Why is it all...
Oh my god they know they know everyone all of them are too they fucking know it's my one weakness it's literally my one weakness when they do two damage they fucking know what's the point if they all do two damage and Might as well be one HP!
Oh my god.
My one weakness.
I literally don't know how to play the game when they start doing two damage on me.
I don't know why.
It's like a mental block.
It's actually a mental block for me.
Oh, oh my god, that was an accident.
All he did was just walk forward.
When?
Yeah.
I'm so sad.
I gotta learn, but I'm so sad.
I don't want to learn!
What if I don't want to learn?
That's too damn bad.
Is
he here?
Yeah.
He lives here.
Oh my god!
I think I need to have a dash for this.
What?
He anti, yeah.
I'm like, how do I fight that?
Like, I can't, I don't have dash yet.
So I'm just like thinking.
Do I need Dash for that fight?
I'm like thinking, should I have Dash for it?
I don't know if I'm like brute forcing it or anything.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, secret.
Oh, that's cool.
I unintentionally found the secret.
Ow?
Fine, I actually needed that.
When?
Okay, I need a...
I'm gonna go...
I need to go find...
I gotta get my money back before I go back.
I don't know if I'm brute-forcing him.
If I need, like, other upgrades to do this.
Okay.
I love the cocoon thing.
Yeah, how come I can't do...
Shaw!
Okay, let's go back.
I need to go to that little secret I found.
Okay, this one.
Okay, these...
Oh my...
Oh my god, he comboed me!
You fucking whore!
When?
There we go.
Okay.
Spikes my fucking mortal enemy.
I'm so scared.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, it's more money.
What's this?
Oh no, it's a charm.
Craft metal.
Oh, it's now upgrade.
We haven't found a weapon upgrade yet, though.
Can I activate this?
I feel like I can.
I need a.
Is it need a?
Oh, there's a...
Oh, there's a bench down there?
Okay, I'll go there.
Pogo stick?
I have to do this?
No way.
Oh, there is a bench.
Never mind.
Is that bench?
What is that?
Oh, it is.
Wait, what is this?
Hello?
What is here?
Alright, we'll try.
Oh.
Oh, they live up top.
Hello?
Oh, hi.
Get out of here.
This one's a little light theory worth a lifelong sentence.
Oh, try to steal.
Oh, this area is locked, though.
It's like a jail.
It's like a little jail.
I wonder how I can unlock it later.
Where am I?
This way.
Yeah, it's a little dungeon.
Yeah, that's on him for getting caught.
Should have gotten caught then.
Alright, this is gonna...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, when he jumps...
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm like...
Oh my god.
I have to be like...
I...
Yeah, Dash would be really nice for this area.
Okay, I gotta stay cool.
The thing is, I don't know if I'm pre-forcing him or not.
Because if I had a dash, this would be so much easier.
100%.
No.
Okay.
Alright.
I think I got the pattern up.
Oh.
Okay.
When he does his swing.
His jump.
Yeah.
His jump is like what's fucking with me.
trying to figure out the pattern of when he's gonna jump
oh it is doable it's very hard i i have no idea if i'm brute forcing that's the thing
okay oh
ah i keep thinking i need to know what he does what he does uh when he's like uh when what what is the telltale sign when he's gonna jump i'm like i figure out his swing his swing i just pogo him but like when does he jump like that when does he do that oh my god he's just okay
Okay.
Oh.
See?
I can't tell.
I can't tell when he does the jumpy move.
He crouches.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh.
This boss.
This boss is very annoying.
When?
Squat equals jump or what?
Okay, he poses what completely is not going to jump, but you do the double dash slash.
When he poses it back completely.
Holy fuck.
This one's hard.
I think it would...
Definitely with dash, he would be like the easiest boss ever.
Because I'm like, I really want to dash, you know?
Okay.
fucking parries me a fucking course okay oh no no no oh I knew he was gonna do that too what fuck you fuck
you I'm not good at parrying so there's more so just timing it right this
is like this is definitely the filter boss
okay oh
my god you're such a bitch when there we go i figure this pattern out holy oh my god i figured the pattern out he will oh my god i figured it out holy shit okay this is a pogo oh it is okay oh he has he has really low hp but he's so oh my god i don't think i was supposed to be here i okay now i feel like i'm not supposed to be here
them for no reason oh okay yeah no i no i'm not supposed to be here look how fucking strong they are look it's fine i'll save them i'll save him oh my god oh my god oh this is bad This is worse than Pogo, because I don't know the distance.
I don't know the distance for this.
I don't know the distance.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna grab our stuff.
I can't believe...
I spent so long.
I actually brute-forced that boss.
I wasn't supposed to be here.
There's no way I was supposed to get to the...
Go to the other map by now.
I don't think I... I don't know.
I feel like...
I feel like I brute-forced it because all the little minions are so strong.
They're all so fucking tanky.
So I feel like...
I feel like...
I was not meant to be here yet.
There you go.
It's easier to go up than it is to go down.
That's for sure.
I'm going.
I'm leaving.
Don't worry.
Back to Sun by Fire will make you stronger.
I'm leaving.
One.
Yeah, they're too tanky.
I don't like it.
Corrin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I want to grab all the Upgrades first.
I mean, now that I kill him.
Like.
Okay.
So many spikes everywhere.
Like this entire town is literally just goddamn spikes.
I swear to God.
I!
What?
When?
This entire...
area is literally just spikes it's nothing else it's just it's a spiky spike world
i mean it's very cool that they have fire ants now they added fire ants oh my god i burned to death i'm too scared to
i'm too scared to pogo or cross pogo because it's like because I don't know where I'm gonna go
I don't know where I'm gonna go so I don't want to pogo
yeah the dive kick is so dangerous Kaz thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh wait this is a new area deep docks Jesus Christ where the fuck there's another new area Where's the bench?
I hope you're enjoying Hollow Knight so much as small as adorable.
Wishing you love loads of fun with Silksong.
I'll now attempt to fight the first boss.
The same story page myself.
Is it still down?
How is it still down?
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is it actually still down?
It is!
Oh my god.
Thank god I gogged it.
That's crazy.
I can't buy so song yet, too.
You guys gotta live vicariously through me right now.
Yeah.
Wait, there is a little secret in there.
Okay.
Oh, okay, it was nothing.
The secret was nothing.
Guys, now that you know the secret is nothing you don't have to go here oh she's here
child wielding needle what do you make of this huge groaning structure the skill of all impresses me if this is merely an outpost of the citadel above then a cat hole must be grand beyond measure yokada perhaps so you must have pried is indeed the work done here to build something so vast and such a dangerous place.
Alright, gotta buy another map.
Bellways.
Oh, that's the fast travel.
Okay, let's buy this first.
And then... Ah, let's...
Okay, let's buy this.
Fuck yeah, we have enough money anyway.
The checkout is the problem.
Yeah, the checkout is the problem.
I can literally call it checkout.
Oh my god, where am I?
Do I go here first or do I explore everything?
Do I explore this area?
Explore everything.
Official, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm like debating if I should keep going here or explore.
I'll explore back.
I'll go back to the last area and explore it a little bit more.
I need to use the bathroom now.
Listen to her sing.
Oh, wait.
I'll go further back.
Wait, I'll reset her.
Listen to her sing.
I gotta use the bathroom.
Oh
oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
I'm back.
I got myself some cough drops too
Like oh and hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Shalom Bring your eye.
Oh,
I go back.
I'm done singing with her.
I'm harmonizing with her.
Oh, there's the tram.
Oh, I'm broke.
She took all my money.
She actually took all my money.
Ooh, cello.
She took it up.
Okay, I gotta kill these guys for money, I think.
Where are they?
I won't get the tram system so I can go home.
I won't upgrade my net.
There must be a way to upgrade my nail, I feel like.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, yeah.
Ornita.
Mynita.
That's what I mean.
Oh my god.
Fly down!
Yeah.
Oh my god.
And then it falls into lava.
Oh, now I'm falling.
Oh, it does two damage.
That's two damage!
I swear to God!
I swear they all do two damage.
Lava is hot.
Why do they all do two damage?
Oh, chalon!
Ah, la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la- The song is actually stuck here.
Where?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
And now I'm back, yeah.
Let's just explore as much as we can for one area where we move on.
I wanna upgrade my nail!
Ooh, let's see this guy, la-la-la-la-la-la-y-la-y.
Ooh, cello.
When?
Oh, I have maximum amount of charts.
That's a thing?
Wait, who are you?
Aha, aha, a native of these far-e-low-land approaches.
Have no fear, my friend.
We fleas are but humble travelers.
Oh, the fleas are nomads.
Oh, that's funny.
just like traveling around on other animals.
Yeah, well, Metzer.
So, like you, I'm not of these lands.
I'm merely journeying through.
A kindred spirit?
It's good luck for wanderers to meet on an unfamiliar path.
And now that we have met, know that I am flea master, Mushka, leader of this cavern.
Wait, they're Russian too?
Mushka?
The fleas are Russian?
Our own journey has barely begun, but you're most welcome to tear here a while, stranger.
Where waves are dark and winding, good bugs must stay close together.
Oh, there they are!
There's the doggos!
Do the Shinn, do Shinnah, do Shinnah, I am saying welcome to your caravan, stranger.
You're very, very funny, very strange flea, isn't it?
No fur at all?
And your wings fell off.
are ours just jest of course us please famous forgiving jokes
oh i got chair here don't you know stranger you're looking a little tired is it unhealthy you can rest with us here if you wish this nice dark and warmth from below brings good health so you should make care not to stay much luck you're not a fleet after all wait what about the fucking dogs i found for you guys
oh but i found you your dogs where's my reward stranger will you hear my worry the time has come for us fleas to find each other and travel together as has happened through generations before the many fleas of this kingdom should be flocking to our caravan but times have become dangerous you feel it too yes our poor cousins out there and hiding.
Wait, they're children?
Not even dogs.
Could you help us find these poor lost fleas?
We didn't continue our journey until some of these poor deers have found a way here to us.
Oh my god!
They're not even...
I thought they were your pets!
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize they were your children.
Paragost?
I don't understand you rightly, stranger.
You will help gather the lonely fleas to the caravan.
Truly, I am traveling these lands for my own reasons, flea master.
However, if I happen upon any fleas on my travel, I will aid them the best I can.
Oh, I could ask for nothing more.
They must all be hiding or stuck in dangerous places.
But if you rouse them, they're sure to find their way here to us.
may the kingdom bless your travels and keep you safe stranger you're welcome the rest of us whenever the roads bring you back oh look the poor fleas are starting to make their way to us what a precious thing we have much to thank you for already and I hope we will have even more than thankful for very soon please keep seeking out our lost fellows oh I can't I didn't realize they were their children.
They act so dog-like.
They barked too.
Oh shit.
Like how was I supposed to know they were kids?
They barked.
I don't even get paid.
They are wandering nomads.
I can't believe they were kids all along.
Yeah they look like puppies.
I go I go.
up all right where's the tram okay we're going to tram and see if there's like upgrades or anything it's like i've maxed shards now so i'm like i feel like i'm i can upgrade or like there's something i can do with them so i don't have to like you know so i don't have to like waste my time can't like not having to carry more toddlers and dogs are so if you say that to a parent they'll fucking punch you the dog okay dog owners would be like yeah they're like my children it helps but then it like an actual parent would be like did you compare my child to a fucking dog all right oh my god he sounds like chubaka do you guys hear that watch
He like Chewbacca'd me.
Did you guys hear that?
Yeah!
He's like...
That's Chewbacca.
That's rude to the dog.
Alright, let's see.
My butt really hurts.
Good night, Toki.
Yeah, I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why does your butt hurt?
Oh, traveler.
trade with an old pilgrim, surely something here will aid you in your great journey.
I'm sorry, the big buggy mommy extorted me of all my rosaries.
Oh, back again?
The wish well is up, ready for all the poor souls who've been left behind down here.
In Vardu, wishes are granted to those truly devout, or so they say.
And there ain't no harm in us dregs having wishes too.
Why?
I even went and added a little wish of my own to the wish wall.
Fair's fair.
I did build a thing.
Seems like the kingdom should be granting my wish before anyone else.
Alright, what is the wish wall?
Oh!
I mean, I fucking already have a lot.
I donated.
Bone bottom repairs.
Wish granted.
Those men who hunt...
We could make use of the shawls and falling.
How do I do this?
Garb of the Pilgrims.
How do I do this wish?
Oh!
It's those guys.
Okay, I see.
Oh, hey!
There she is!
We're in Aramis.
The watchfuls never ever seen such a part.
They're religious, Shaka.
They're like, they're a cult.
They believe in peace and love.
Oh, they're hippies.
It's such a poorly defended encampment.
It's like those hippie camps.
Peace and, yeah, they don't believe in violence.
The pilgrims here seem to have no mind for war, Shaka.
I suspect most depart for this little story.
soon after they arrive them.
And they persist in their carelessness.
They will only find death in these harsh lands.
Oh my god.
They're fucking hippies.
Oh, this is a tram station.
I knew it.
Good bow.
The lands around turning deadly.
I worry for its safety.
We surely aren't seen its finest moment.
But this place has been serving us passing bugs for as long as I can remember.
It's faith, you see.
All those pilgrims, now and past, our devotion holds it together.
The camp remain and provide no matter the troubles.
Alright, remember when...
Okay, so we have to kill the pilgrims.
And you know where they are in my favorite spot.
Don't worry, Sharka.
Sharka will defend them.
Wake up!
Oh, jeez, cool.
Those civilians are unharmed.
It's Pilgrim Farming Time.
Let's gotta remember where they are.
This way.
I remember where you all live, pilgrims.
I remember.
Yeah, it's two of the left.
They thought the nightmare was over.
Oh, it was over.
Oh, shit.
For that.
Oh, my God.
He learned.
Joink.
My cloth now.
Okay, I need 12.
That's like six times a refresh.
He was like, I'm not.
safe I can finally get down from the platform she'll never come little do they know I'm back oh this is faster little do they know you're never safe yeah I purchase page should have gogged it oh should have gogged it all right nice we're almost done almost oh my god she's taken we're almost done stripping them of their clothes i'm back who is this i'm back baby boom Boom!
Alright.
Yoink.
She's a menace.
And I'm like farming money too.
Why are we...
It's because they're crazy.
I mean, it's a little...
Okay, it's a bad that I'm stealing from the mentally ill.
But like, it's part of the mission!
The other pilgrims told me to do it.
I'm doing as I'm doing as I told.
A good soldier follows orders.
I'm just doing as I'm told.
It was a wish, okay?
I am granting a wish right now.
It's a make a wish.
They asked me to...
They asked me to strip them of their grave.
in the make-a-wish.
They're doing my part.
Look, look, see?
I promised someone.
I'm fulfilling a make-a-wish.
They requested this in the make-a-wish well.
But it's a ride.
Well, maybe they shouldn't have wished it.
Is it truly my fault when I'm only fulfilling a make-a-wish?
See, from the mentally, if gotcha game, those can do it so can you.
Oh, Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If anything, I wonder, like, what are the limitations of make-a-wishes?
What's the limitations?
See, wish granted.
it i'm a good person the person that requested this might have had cancer okay i fulfilled their make a wish look at that all right you can hold a gun now it's gun i wish what about kid who's dream is to rob the elderly gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i got i got a
Yeah, it's never a war crime in the first time.
Sorry, crappy.
Sad crap that you was super chat thinking, thank you.
That's a fucked up kid.
The kid is dying.
I'm fulfilling their wish.
How dare you?
That child was dying.
I'm just fulfilling it.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, man.
I can't wait to get Dash.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Obey first.
Complain later.
Let me go up.
Exactly.
How can you say no to a sick child?
What's wrong with you?
I'm just gonna... I'm killing him just because I can't.
Yeah.
Alright, where else should I go?
Okay, we go up.
Okay, let's practice this.
Okay.
It's so weird.
I need to, like, have it more ingrained in my head for these Pogo's.
For the dash Pogo's?
Such a weird Pogo.
I had to, like, unlearn the other Pogo for this.
Okay.
Money!
Oh, shortcut!
Nice.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Mmm.
Okay, I wonder if I can...
No.
I was gonna say if I can...
That's the hard part.
I don't...
The ring.
of this is the hard part.
Because when you lose your groove, it fucks you up.
Because it's a...
I think that's the hard part.
When you lose your first dash, it gets a lot harder.
It's easier when you're closer, I think.
When you're closer to the...
Like, you just have to be...
Ah, see like that!
It's...
Yeah.
It's harder to recover.
It's very hard to recover when you miss the first one.
I think I'm gonna die for this.
Yeah, like...
It's so...
It's such a weird Pogo.
Okay, I gotta grab my cocoon.
It's definitely a skill check.
It's easier when you're like up like super close to it, which I've noticed.
I'm still trying to develop the muscle memory for how close I have to be.
Shaw!
Akitas!
Yeah.
Okay.
Gotta get that temple going.
I like the little flip she does, though.
It's really cute.
Oh my god, my cocoon is so far.
Yeah.
Ah, going back is difficult.
Oh my god, are you serious?
I don't like going back.
Going back is hard to do.
Holy shit.
Friend!
Alright, this way.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, shit.
Wait, what the fuck?
I didn't realize there was something there.
Oh.
Oh?
There's no maps here.
Oh, that's all my money.
Is that it?
There's a fucking map for this one room?
Okay, don't you hate it when you're money just rolls away?
My money literally just rolled away.
Would you fucking hate it when that happens?
There's someone, there's a, oh.
Super goddamn rosary currency.
It literally rolled away from me.
I don't know which way to go.
Okay, I can't do that.
All right, guys.
Do I go to the or the deep rocks I don't know which way to oh god damn I thought I had pogo not a diagonal whoops that was an accident okay uh deep rocks okay oh shit I'm just gonna go to the bench real quick yeah the bench is over here i'll be in the or deep dock sorry deep docks not deep rocks i'll explore here next uh get to my oh there's a mask what does that match say
all right let's get to the deep docks
ROW!
Reving up the docks.
Down out goal.
Okay, this way.
We go up here.
Alright, nice.
What's this?
Can I hit this?
No.
me dash that's all i want that's all i want please if i have dash this game would be so much easier
i can i can live without double jump i just want my dash dash was so good i am i am so handicapped without a dash Oh, shit.
My dash was my crutch.
I'm a dash crutcher.
Oh, my god.
When?
Yeah, fuck you.
Burn!
It has!
What is he doing?
Mining the clothes?
Does he yearn for the mines?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, my god.
Oh my god, they're the new jumpies.
Oh, I don't like the sound.
The sound they make.
That's so unselling.
They remind me...
Yeah, they remind me of clickers.
That's why I was like, what does this remind me of?
Like, their sound effect.
They sound like clickers.
A pony!
They look more like...
Like dinos.
Yeah, they...
bye they look they know they sound like clickers from last of us what oh my god you can what the fuck wait do i pogo you out oh it doesn't hurt me oh oh okay i can stand the fuck oh i have mom feet like you know mom hands where like they could touch like hot stuff without having to worry
i was like what the fuck is he doing okay insert rosaries
so like when they when because like moms they they cook so much that like when they're their hands they can't feel they can't feel the heat anymore because you're always touching when they're cooking so instead of mom hands I have mom feet nice yeah the nerve damage yeah nerve damage I mean you put it like that that's less cool I love this game this game came out like two hours I mean maybe oh you could have got I was gonna say,
were you able to get past the seamstores?
Jesus, they're so tanky.
Yeah.
We will go this way.
Whoops.
I hate these ants.
They're so fucking tanky.
I feel like... I just feel like I'm not supposed to kill them yet.
I'm not supposed to be in that area yet.
Friend!
steam store is that first boss oh I can't even go there yet okay maybe in the bottom thank God I still have map map time map time oh I don't have a map of this area either I was like thinking I was like did I not fucking look at this area yet?
Alright.
Oh, shit.
We go left side.
The floor is lava, but I can just jump it, apparently.
I have nerve.
Apparently my feet has nerve damage, so it doesn't matter.
Which is fine.
Don't you love it when your feet has nerve damage, guys?
When?
It's fine.
I don't care that much.
Alright, we go down.
Down and Tudor, right?
Okay, what I will say, I like that Shakira.
Sorry, what was her name?
She's like Shakira to me.
It tells you where all the... where everything is like you can explore I don't remember her name I call her Shakira or is it Sharka okay she's Shakira now to me I don't know if you guys notice this but like you know how Cornelius he like just draws like three things and was like go do the rest Shakira even though she drew this with a goddamn rock she like gave me everything like every almost all the things I could explore and be like,
this is all the stuff around you.
I like that.
I like that she's babying me.
That makes me happy that she's babying me.
Okay, we'll go to the right.
She knows I need help.
I did?
No, I didn't.
I went to that area.
I can't go up top because it's locked.
Yes, it's better.
Not only is she a big buggy mommy, she actually is helping me.
She actually is useful.
Unlike a goddamn nerd.
Wait, what?
7 12 bell toe send 30 measures 4 beats smoker rock 8 beats sweet smell mark of the felty all workers at a 9 bell toe send 20 measures 2 beats smoke rock 7 beats sweet smell mark of felty all workers okay what's that mean okay that's lore
oh boss fight Oh, shit.
There's the bell tollo.
Okay, I want to know how strong this is.
Alright, it's that strong.
Whoa!
That guy's new.
I did not expect him.
Whoops.
I feel like I have a lot of range in general.
when oh
shit you can jump all right okay now i know all right there we go easy okay needle is strong needle strong where is this area up top okay where am i oh there's a bench nice
And then a shortcut here.
Um...
Do I have...
Anything that I can?
Okay, no.
I guess I'll go right side.
See what I'm missing.
Oh!
Upgrade!
Oh my god, he's so... Look at his tiny hands.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, Forge Daughter.
Ah, Twinkie Bug.
Why do you bother us that I awake?
The sound of your craft called me to investigate.
What is your duty here?
Are you a smith of some kind?
A smith?
Hardly so cruel.
We are forged daughter.
How can a boining bug not tell?
Ours is the ancient line and honor rule.
These dogs and lambs around are fortunate to have our skill.
If you are talented as you say, suggest would you leave me your aid i've lacked for my usual tools and i suspect you could craft five replacements look it's like the gap mowing big big strong uh uh forger with her tiny tools that is her voice now blades and traps imagine that's your forge master you're like i'm gonna make you a big old sword
This sword can kill thou, she's a buggs!
The babush...
The babushbushmiss.
No doubt, we know you are, Ty.
Has been?
Of sorts, but may be strange to this land.
Some would likely prove fine challenge for your crab.
then we'll construct them but you'll provide the materials and compensation for our time okay okay let's know what can we clap big bug baby voice yeah you know he's what is that sing shard a vicious stabbing trap the words and he's the workers She's down there,
lost it.
Oh, it means I can swim, right?
What the fuck do I buy?
What?
It's so hard to figure out.
Because, like, no one knows.
It's the worst part of Pavilion launch day.
No one knows.
I assume the crafting kit because it's expensive.
A fair exchange.
Affair, change me, pointy bug.
Now I'll work cause.
Return again if you find need of our trade and talent.
What the fuck did I buy?
What?
It's just a pouch?
Oh my god.
I just bought a bag.
If you need something, talk to the boss.
I'm busy.
I literally, I just bought a fucking bag.
Nice.
This bag better be like from Gucci or something.
I bought an upgrade for something I don't have.
I swear to God.
This bag better be from fucking Gucci Baguchi.
It's a nice bag.
I can't even do anything with it.
Oh buggy.
Yeah, it better be like buggy bag.
I swear to God.
What's this?
Oh, I don't think they carry...
Oh, I don't think they carry rosaries.
They don't look religious.
This land doesn't look religious, guys.
I can't tell.
Oh, you can throw to the side?
I thought it was... Oh, I can... Oh, I can hit it.
That's good.
Wait, I'm killing her workers.
Shh, don't tell her.
Don't tell her.
I'm literally... Ow!
What the fuck?
She does... Why do they all do two damage?
I swear they all do plus two now.
Okay.
I mean, sure.
Wait, there's like... It says there's something... Oh, it's over here.
It's over here.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I can't see that.
No, he realized I was low HP.
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize.
Everything does too damage now.
It's so crazy.
I didn't look at my HP.
I was too busy, like, stabbing people with my fucking needle.
Okay.
I got two guys.
I'll just drop straight down.
Oh, shit.
I didn't see this guy.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I- I- No!
Oh, wait.
I didn't have a lot.
Never mind.
I already spent it all.
It's fine.
I didn't have a lot of money anyway.
I remember it.
I already spent all my money.
I gave it all.
I already spent all my money to the child.
To the forager lady.
Oh my god, it's the same.
Wait, no.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's where I died.
Okay, there you go.
That's fine.
Thank god I already spent my money.
That's the best part.
Can't lose no money!
Whoa.
There we go.
Can't lose my money if it's all gone.
What's over here?
This has to be lore related.
Ha!
Oh, nice.
I knew there was money here.
God, I hate that it...
Because sometimes these beads, they roll out to the door and then they disappear.
My free money.
It's good.
Good thing you have the bang.
Okay, I'm glad that...
There we go.
My money!
What?
I need a magnet.
I need a fucking rosary magnet or some shit.
It's just fucking crazy that I lose it all.
Okay, that's fine with me.
Okay.
I'm fine with that.
See, look!
Oh my god, I think I didn't roll off.
Is this...
Okay, it does that.
Uh... Oh, I didn't go this way.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Okay.
Ow!
Woo!
Okay.
When?
Oh wait, there's shards here.
Ouch!
Ooh!
Hot!
That's so stupid.
Just gotta make sure, as long as I keep jumping, I'm fine.
Ouchy, ouch.
Hot, hot, hot!
Ooh!
Hot, hot!
Oh!
There you go.
Oh my god, he like blocked me there.
Oh, I mean, it's good that he came down and he is the money.
Nice.
I think like, yeah.
I don't know when exactly I have to like stop moving.
So I gotta like make sure I don't actually burn.
Because I feel like they do two damage.
Everything does two damage, apparently.
Wait, what can I do?
What the fuck was that?
Oh, I can hold more silk.
Okay, nice.
It does.
I knew it.
Everything does two damage now.
It sucks.
I think that's my only gripe.
A lot of stuff does two damage now.
That's my only gripe.
Ow!
Like this guy.
Like he's just a fucking slug!
Did I go red?
Was there anything to the red?
I don't remember.
How much money do I have?
Oh, 120.
Oh.
I should have enough.
Yes, I can buy stuff.
Nice.
Where am I?
Where are you getting?
twaps.
Hey, y'all.
Um, okay.
Let's not fuck it up this time.
Do we get Magma Ball?
Oh, sorry.
Magma Bell or Sting Shard?
I don't know what to do.
Magma Bell?
This one I can hang around these dogs.
So I'm like, the Bell is, like, wards off the lava.
of stuff so i don't know if it's good or not i don't purchase all right there it is the process are around here these long burning rocks they're useful to the citadel and whatever the shadowy bushness but useless if you require tools of us we need final material wear metal
evil explorer punish them and will build your violent age okay okay I got equipped this tool
all right we go down I think I can't go this way right I don't remember oh yeah I can we go this way I am the doki night don't get me jump wee wee wee we we i'm jump okay bench is here wait no bench is not here i i can't use it yet i'm gonna find a bench whoops that's my elevator
all right i'll use a bench i think that's my bench where my bench is at
I can swim that lava now
But shop, think of a super chat, thank you, thank you Apparently there was a 10 year old kid who blew up a car With an RPG for a make-wish So I know what I'm making my future kid do What your future Oh!
Oh, reduces the damage Oh!
I was gonna say what the fuck do you mean I know what you want your future kid to have cats what the fuck all right now you only take one damage yay all right all I thought it was immunity the lava.
I was so excited.
I was like, yay, I'm ready to swim.
Don't think I can make that jump.
I definitely, that's why I know I will get dash.
I did not mean that.
What do you mean that?
What the fuck do you mean?
I know what I'm thinking about.
Sorry, I wasn't looking.
Okay, there you go.
How else was I supposed to take that implication?
I don't think I could...
Yeah, I can't go up because...
I know I can't go up because it's locked, right?
Guys, does anyone remember if the bench is up top, it's locked?
You remember?
When?
The bench up top, the pathway to the right, it's locked, right?
Yeah?
Okay, we'll just, I guess it's time to go to the ant world.
Alright, we'll go to ant world now.
Guys, we're going to ant world!
It's like Disneyland, but it's all ants.
I don't want to go to ant world.
It's too late!
We're going to ant world!
We're fucking going to Ant World.
Alright.
That and stash might be Ant World.
Yeah, I think so too.
I assume so as well.
Ow.
Jesus.
We're gonna get ants!
Ants!
Ants in my pants!
Wait, I remember that this was a chair.
It was locked, but there was a chair there.
Okay, nice.
Ant world time!
Oh my god.
Stupid fucking ants!
We deserve ant world.
Where's my map of ant world?
When?
Hello?
Oh shit.
Oh, they're like...
They're like rogues.
At rogues.
Jesus Christ!
It was one needle!
And you're still alive?
Okay.
Nice.
That's right.
I killed your friend.
Whoa.
My turn.
Get out of here.
I rule Antworld.
I'm your new queen of Antworld.
Call me.
Call me Walt Doki.
Oh, now it teaches me to look down.
Wow.
Thank you.
What would I do without look down?
When?
Thank God.
What an honor.
I was finally taught to look down.
What did I do to deserve such an honor?
Where's my chair?
Yay, chair.
Oh, fuck.
That was an accident.
Gamers don't look down.
True.
So true.
Oh, did I just literally...
Oh, my God.
I literally went...
Oh, I unlocked the area.
Oh!
I'm going to unlock the shortcut now.
Okay.
This feels very Bosch-like.
Oh, it's no power-up.
Oh, this is where I get power-ups.
Daughter of a distant land.
We who remain have long waited long.
Bind our strength to yours.
Reclaim the future of our haunted kingdom.
Fine.
Give me the power of Dash.
Is Dash?
Oh.
my god thank fucking fuck who'd i t i think i brute force that boss it's amazing i did i think i was supposed to get the dash and then go to ant world beyond once nature's limits chase down prey and leap i think i was definitely supposed to get dash here and then fight the big ass fucking boss now i realize i indeed brute-forced it.
Yeah, I killed it before I got dashed.
Oops.
There we go.
It definitely feels like it.
Okay, there's something above me.
This dash isn't even the... This dash is weird because you go... you go down.
I don't know how I feel about this dash.
Okay.
You actually, you fall a bit down when you're dashing.
So it's not even a full dash, yeah.
Hello, here's an, I saved another child.
They look like dogs.
They're like dog kids.
Maybe they're like one of those adults that think their dogs are their kids.
You know?
You're like the ones that buy those strollers for them.
Like you look, be like, oh is that a baby?
And then you look in it and it's an actual dog.
Okay, where do I go now?
Wait, what's the...
I'm trying to figure where to go.
I guess I go to Atworld.
I go to Atworld?
Why do I go to...
I don't know where to go.
Wait, it's a sprint?
What do you mean?
Yeah, I can run fast.
Alright.
No, I already...
Did I not unlock that?
Oh, yeah, I was broke.
I didn't unlock it.
How much money do I have?
I have enough.
I forgot to unlock this...
The tram.
Alright, ring ring.
What is the dog gonna do with money?
Like...
What the fuck are you gonna do with money?
You're a dog!
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm getting my zoomies.
I just have my zoomies right now.
I actually have zoomies.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Look at this girl.
Look at James.
Look at Sanco.
Okay.
I'm drifting.
I'm actually drifting right now.
Chasing my tail, yeah.
Ah, steal from this guy.
Alright.
I love that look like...
I love it, I love this!
I'm like chasing my tail.
I have like an actual zoomies.
Oh my god, you finally bought silk song?
Oh my god, it took three hours.
Where do I go?
I think I have to go to Antworld.
I feel like... I think I did everything down here.
I required dash, right?
I don't remember.
I think... Oh, maybe downstairs.
Now that I have my dash...
Wait, here.
Oh, here.
There you go.
This is what I need to do.
I don't remember now.
Hello!
How sad a little spider has fallen from its cage.
So lost, so weak.
Poor little morsel.
I can save you.
Little spider.
All the trouble you faced above.
All the suffering.
It's so simple.
I'll just skewer you here and now Fluck that flickering light Right out of you Wait what, this is a boss fight Your threats are worthless Wait, that's a child?
She is like As tall as me Look at her fucking waist That is a child If you are my foe Say your voice and raise your blade Delicious I like you already Okay, I was not ready.
Guys, I am not ready for a fight right now.
I...
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
That's right.
That's why you're a child.
And I am cheating silk sign.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that was not...
Oh.
that was not what okay I I'm sorry I did not mean all that what the fuck I was doing so well okay okay when she did that it threw me off I'm sorry that it threw me off I was doing so well too I died to the lava.
I died to the environment lost to a child.
I'm cyclone.
I got, I, I'm, oh my god, I'm all over the place right now.
I can't believe it ever since I died to the child.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I was doing so well, but our new booze threw, it threw me off my groove.
I was doing so fucking...
I was dodging and everything.
I just did not expect her to do that.
Alright, here we go.
Give me my cocoon back.
Okay.
Like, she's so predictable.
Like that.
But then she does that crazy-ass move that's like, what the...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, a fucking...
What?
Like that!
Like, what the fuck is that?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm gonna save this.
Actually, no.
Okay, nice.
I do dash for that then.
It's so risky to use the needle as a tax.
There we go.
Second try.
Second, that's right.
Get cooked, child.
I did it, guys.
I beat up a child.
We did it.
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee.
Woo.
Zoopy.
Yippee, yippee, yippee.
I beat up a child.
Yay.
I gotta do Gotta do a little zoomie After Wait Stop
The child Enniolated That's right I showed it There's always someone trying to copy Virgil Mr. Broken Boss Thank you for the super chat Thank you The child's destroyed.
You gotta teach your harsh life lesson there.
Gotta show what reality truly is.
Oh, I don't have a map for this area.
Now where I'm at.
Okay, maybe I can...
Okay, I had to do a dash there for that.
Bar fields.
Every... I don't know if I'm supposed to be in some areas sometimes welcome to the world real world kid exactly yeah okay I I don't know I need a wall ride for that you're gonna learn today exactly oh what the fuck like this what the fuck get out of here oh
shit oh my god this guy is a lot scarier he is definitely a lot scarier oh did he run wait where did they go oh okay i was not expecting that i need a friend no no my friend oh no how would i friend now
Okay.
No, I still can't.
I still can't friend.
I need...
I need a friend.
Yeah, no.
He canceled my friend.
That's fucked up.
What's this?
Okay, stuff that I don't have.
Wait.
Okay.
Yes!
There we go.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be here.
This entire game is like me.
Am I supposed to be here?
That's me the entire game.
Because I can't wall dash.
Or wall, yeah.
I want to try and kill him.
Oh my god, does this reset them?
Friend!
Oh yes!
Okay, I got it.
It's fine.
Okay, I have maximum shards.
I still don't know what to do with my shards, though.
I am...
I am a little confused.
Because I don't have map.
Okay, I'll full heal.
Friend!
There we go.
Maybe go down?
I forgot.
I keep thinking that I can live through lava.
I keep thinking.
Okay, I go to Atworld.
Maybe Atworld has, uh...
Has Wall Dash.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Just like...
Maybe.
Is there anything else I need a Dash for?
Maybe here?
Wait.
Down here.
I remember there was like...
Yeah, here.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I don't have the key.
Okay, it's time to go to Ant World.
Alright guys, now we're actually going to Ant World.
Come on, kids!
Instead of going to Disney World, we're going to Ant World.
It's our favorite place.
I don't care if you don't want to go to Ant World.
I spent good money for Ant World.
okay how much money do i have like how much rosaries do i have 122 i can't buy but i want to go well too damn bad your mom can't afford lego land
can't afford lego land this is our this is all we can afford not at world Oh, I gotta see that movie.
Alright, this way.
I wish, oh wait, here.
No.
Is there anything that requires, like, dash?
And world is just like Legoland.
It's, just imagine the ants are like, various Legos.
It's almost a...
Oh my god.
It's almost the same thing.
I keep thinking it's a full dash.
I think, like, it's just me trying to unlearn all the Hollow Knight stuff.
Okay, this way.
Yeah.
This game is just me unlearning Hollow Knight mechanics.
If you build the answer together, they could technically become they could technically become Lego.
It's like when you try, you know, like fire ants, if you try to drown them in water, they'll just build a raft.
Just Pogo, shake my head.
Run.
What's over here?
Oh, nothing.
Alright.
No, I don't have the key for the guy for the jail.
Okay.
It's Pogo time.
Gotta hide in this area.
Oh, wait.
This is where I found the child.
The dog child.
Jesus Christ!
Gwen.
They're just everywhere.
Get out of here.
Gwen.
Step on an ant does not hurt as nearly as much as stepping on a leg.
That's exactly, that's an improvement!
That's basically an improvement!
If you think about it, it's better than Lego!
They don't hurt unless they're fire ants.
Okay, they can jump too.
That's good to know.
Oh, what the fuck?
Jesus, they're so fast.
Oh my!
I thought that I was really thought they would jump further.
These guys are tanky as hell Oh my god.
There's oh, and then he's gone
That's fine.
I'll take that Wait, all right Excuse me.
I was like, how do I take it?
They're so tanky.
I know I was like, what the fuck?
Oh my god these stupid Fucking ass!
Oh my god, I hate them.
I hate them so much.
I-
Oh my god, oh my god, I had a feeling.
Oh my god.
I had a feeling.
Okay, thank God.
What?
That's fine.
I got my heel up.
That's all I care about.
Jesus!
They're so...
Thank you!
Here we go.
What?
Oh, thank God she's helping!
Oh, thank God!
Oh, Shakira!
Shakira!
Okay, that Shakira did not help as much as I thought she would I got her little orb things disoriented me so much Like like you know how like her little bracelet stuff It was bouncing around so I like didn't know what's like a projectile Those hips don't lie
Shakira please save me I just I couldn't tell where to go
She did, like, her bracelet, like, disoriented me so much.
It was actually, like, yes, thank you, Shakira, for helping me.
But I don't know what to do.
I'm sorry, I was distracted by the ad stick.
I...
Oh, my God.
These stars guys are so fucking tanky I hate this pogo Yeah Her hips don't lie Oh fuck Okay
Are you serious
There you go.
I'm just gonna get to Shakira.
I'm just gonna get to her.
There you go.
Alright.
I just gotta kill him.
I'm not gonna use my needle yet.
Yeah, because, like, I am scared.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What?
I knew I had range.
there oh my god and they know how to block it's crazy oh yeah oh yeah
there you go jacquira you got this you got this jacquira do your thing holy i can't tell where anything is.
I...
Because...
I legitimately... I can't tell.
It's so fucking.
Oh no.
It's okay.
Please tell me I feel.
Okay, nice.
I did it.
Tokyo Albert.
We did it.
Punch, think of a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Shalom.
Oh, hello.
Oh, Lari, Lari.
Oh, Shalom.
That was battle well fought, child.
Mielding needle, your master would be proud of you.
The one who trained me long ago.
I never called her master.
What if she would be proud of what has become of me?
I cannot say.
Nuhakatata.
Oh, Nuhakata.
Whether she is dead or alive.
Have faith.
Nothing a pupil does escaped her master.
master's sight.
Oh, she's alive.
Sadly, not in my stomach, though.
Oh, nice.
Now I can afford this.
You guys wouldn't let me eat her.
God, so sad.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to show you guys this one.
When the axe comes over.
Wait, girl.
Big buggy mommy.
Pickpucky mommy
Oh my god Okay I need to see if I can
I realize...
Maybe I should...
I'm gonna ask Neopal if she can fix the thing so you see that...
Yeah, I don't like that.
Where the head sort of disappears a little.
So I'm gonna ask her to fix that.
My bottom part of my head disappears a little bit.
Okay, now I can heal.
Wait, what?
Ah!
I was so confused.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
What?
I was, like, looking at this.
I was so confused what that is.
What does that do?
Was that thread?
Ah.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Not these guys.
I...
Let's get me out of here.
Ah!
I mean, that works.
I didn't realize they were, like, just...
there.
I don't want to deal with them.
What's over here?
Oh, shit.
Got that stupid fucking traps.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That's another trap, isn't it?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Not trapped?
Oh, my God.
It wasn't a trap.
Ow.
Stop.
baby and when there you go I lived I don't know what happened what what the fuck just happened I don't know oh my god are you see are you I hate this
Like, how am I supposed to...
What?
I can't go anywhere there.
I think I need to unlock something for that.
Oh!
No!
It's not fair!
Why did you not build traps?
How?
He's so smart!
Oh my god, the infection!
should have taken them I wish the infection took them all right
nice my memory lock it expands a crest in the crest pane of the menu what the fuck what does that mean I wish I can fly I want I don't know how to get there I'm gonna go
lap your wings I'm not meant to fly look just a little guy oh I didn't I didn't realize there was a shortcut here.
Okay, now I'm back here.
Where the fuck do I go?
Okay, so there is like...
This Pogo will be the death of me.
Because I can't reach up top there.
I hate this Pogo.
Oh my god.
Because I can't reach up that.
I...
Oh,
go then dash.
How do I...
Oh my...
Oh my god.
I had to do that.
I don't know if I cheesed it or if that's...
I'm so sad.
I am so sad.
I don't know...
Okay.
I'm so sad.
Oh, my.
This is the test.
This is the ultimate Pogo test.
Oh, my God.
This is my purgatory.
This particular Pogo...
God damn it.
Literally, this Pogo is my purgatory.
If I can do this, I've mastered this Pogo.
If I can do this, I have mastered this Pogo.
Like, I can't hit that.
What the fuck?
Like, what the fuck?
How do I hit?
Oh my god.
Dash then Pogo?
I feel like...
Do we need double jump for that?
Okay.
Because I can only do this.
Yeah, see?
I don't have enough height.
Oh my god.
That was an accident.
Do I need double jump?
I don't know if I have enough height for this.
Like look.
I go up here.
If I dash, like, see?
Look at that.
I'll try again.
If I can just...
See?
Oh my god.
Because I need like a certain height to do these.
Jesus.
Jesus!
I'm gonna go.
better though.
I'm building muscle memory off of these.
Yeah, I can't.
We'll go the opposite way?
What do you mean?
Like this?
Sick.
No, the wind doesn't do shit.
Oh my God!
Ah!
I don't know how I did it!
I don't know how I did that.
I don't know how I did it.
That's the worst part.
The wind doesn't do shit, by the way.
I don't know how I did.
It's actually...
I don't know if I'm, like, cheesing it right now, too.
God, I fucking made it.
I fucking made it.
Holy shit.
Is this the queen at?
Hello?
Goodness.
This is just too embarrassing.
Detected even through my perfect cover.
What tell?
Whatever.
Surely something gave me away.
It was one thing, young bug.
Your disguise is near...
Oh, wait.
It was one... No one thing, young bug.
Your disguise is nearly faultless.
I've merely spent a long life being watchful.
Then I'll just have to hope to feast about don't share such keen sights.
It'll be so much harder to accomplish my work if I'm detected or eaten.
Where are you?
These are dangerous feasts.
young one not for a casual wondering what task you sees you brave them a treacherous quest but a crucial one upon the last wish my father i'm taking up the study of these wild caves sometimes i keep forgetting that i can talk to so i read up lines that i'm supposed to be one seeing these fields still display life and growth even as the lines around a road to dust there's a lot of harmony here that loots the great waste above and the dry I marrow beside what time and study I shall uncover why.
See here?
This old statue.
I've just been thinking long on it.
What clue am I supposed to hold?
The clawwork seems beyond the other structures throughout those caves.
Oh, what she, I wonder, deserves such a refined remembrance.
Hers is a form of a dancer, and the craft is indeed requisite.
There must once have been more to these ants.
the hauntings smitten are their shells and mines okay it's all the lore conversing is a pleasure but must return to my observate observance try not to leave too much a trail when you leave please okay that that was just lore i did all of that for lore yeah i know i can see it from the hornet but like sometimes it's like really like you know gamers don't look up you know
My chair!
Oh my god!
I never learned.
I was like, surely it'll be different this time.
How do I break it?
I just want to sit on a chair.
It's not...
Ah!
fit I
Cannot sit on chair
My feet hurt Feet hurt Be hurt one chair
Oh now I can't do shit Oh my god now.
I just need wall dash.
I can't do anything up there Oh my god, I went up there For no reason.
I'm lost as fuck right now.
I feel like I went...
Oh my god, I had to go to the other area.
Okay, try sitting on that chair now.
All that Pogo.
All that Pogo for nothing?
I'm so sad.
Just for lore.
Oh, that Pogo for lore.
I'm so sad.
I worked so hard for that area too.
I don't know where to go then.
I feel like I did everything over there.
Yeah.
Where do I go?
Huh.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Why is my cocoon all the way up there?
Do I have a...
Oh, I do.
I should... Wait, how much is that?
20.
Okay, let's grab a tool.
Maybe a tool would help.
Cool.
Glad that didn't hit me.
Sit.
Alright.
Alright, we go.
Let's go back to the forge daughter.
It's fine.
My feats...
My featsy can take it.
Ow.
That's fine.
Because I have Fwen!
I'm purposely tanking everything, because I have Fwen.
Where's the Forge daughter?
Where does she live?
Down here, right?
Yeah, no.
She lives down...
Yeah.
Where did she live?
Just give me a second try.
I don't remember where she... Oh, there.
There.
I don't have the thing where, like, you know how they're like, oh.
Uh...
Or is it here?
Oh, there she is.
That's fine.
You met the workers?
wound up.
They still work at their cash in a simple way, but they're useless for conversation.
It's only ourselves.
A young fellow with my sense left.
Oh.
The behavior of your fellow workers has seen similar agitations upon the roads.
These dogs are not alone in the strangeness of their occupants.
There's odd behavior to be sure that not for Bilo and us to know, Ice is our busy work and we keep to ourselves.
Whatever the goings of the world outside, no bother to us as long as our craft can continue.
Keep well, Forge daughter.
I shall return if I require your aid.
Yes or no?
Either is fine by me as long as the craft continues.
Please!
I want to- Oh, shop!
Okay, I was like, why am I talking to you?
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Wait, I don't even have the rocks to upgrade!
I forgot!
Oh my god, I don't even have the rocks to upgrade this.
God fucking, damn it!
I'm a little lost.
Okay, I'm going to look at my big map now.
I'm trying to remember which one were gates that were locked and which one we can parkour.
Okay, let's retrace our steps.
It's Metrovania time.
Well, I already have max shards right now, so I can't...
Which area?
We can't... No, we can't go to the right because um it's locked i remember we got backtracked there's some area in the morrow there's stuff it's it's like basically locked up but i know we did everything in hunters march
yeah because they don't they don't show like they don't show like what's locked up on the map
like that's like why i'm like hello it's time hey who's a good boy okay bone marrow
okay maybe there's like something i could buy with the hippies maybe oh my god thank god this is what we needed i'm so sick and tired Oh, and I can buy a shard.
Wait, I can buy a shard right now.
Are you serious?
It takes up the compass slot?
There's no fucking way.
Oh, wait, I have memory locket.
Oh, that's what the memory locket... Okay, I can.
Thank God.
Okay, okay, that's what the memory lockets are for.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
I was gonna freak out.
I was gonna say, there's no way.
I cannot get rid of the fucking compass.
I...
There's no fucking way.
They cannot do this to me.
Oh, wait, she's gone.
I was gonna freak out if I had to take away the compass.
Okay, we go...
The tram, and then down.
Or up.
I don't know if we could go up, but we'll try.
This angry Doki, exactly.
Damn!
Adidas!
The most lost Doki yet.
I like that I can run.
Okay.
Wait, where is it?
Okay, it's above.
Okay, we're gonna check out above if we can access that area now.
Because I don't know.
I'm always lost.
Okay, it's here.
No, that's...
Yeah, I need a wall ride for that.
Okay, I can't access this.
Now I know...
Ow.
Okay, and then there's one below me, too.
Is that a...
No.
It's this way.
Ah!
Stupid whore!
Okay, I can add eat us, or when.
Your goddamn swords aren't gonna protect you from my sword.
My sword's bigger.
Oh hey, I didn't see this.
Oh, nice.
That's right, my sword's bigger, bitch.
Okay, this way.
Yep, it's locked.
God damn it.
Everything is locked.
I assume that one is also like...
Everything is just locked!
Okay, there's... I think that is also a wall, right?
Is it?
Yep.
God!
Okay, there's stuff to the right of deep docks.
I assume like... No, there's one more area.
Oops.
I'll farm this for HP.
Alright, oh.
Collect it.
Nice.
Okay.
Can we go to far fields?
I know this one is locked, too.
Yeah, it's locked.
They're all locked!
Alright.
I mean...
I remember that door was also locked.
I'll look at it again.
Oh, shit.
Speed ride.
I'll check again.
I'm pretty sure that one's locked
Wait, okay, I have enough I found it, I bought a stone I didn't buy the stone God, I thought I bought it I thought I bought it, never mind I don't need it I legitimately thought I bought it
Yeah, this one I needed the key I don't have the key Okay, so this one, I need a key All right.
The only way I could go is the place I killed the child.
I need to go to the place where I killed her.
Or, like, hurt her a little bit.
That's the only place I could think to go.
It's here.
Wait, there was a key at the shop?
Wait, was there?
But does that open that key?
Does it open that specific?
Oh, my God.
Back to...
It's backtracking time.
It was five, but I'm not made of money.
It's 500.
I feel like that doesn't progress.
If it's like...
Usually...
I feel like usually if it's like something you have to buy, it doesn't really progress the story, I feel like.
Yeah.
Yeah, if it costs that much, it seems like an option.
optional thing.
Okay, we're back here.
The far fields.
Maybe we'll figure out how...
Maybe it's here.
Yeah.
I...
I gave up here because, like...
I felt like I needed, like, wall dash to do a lot of these.
Yeah, but for the waterways, I had a lot of money.
I don't have fucking shit.
here and I don't have the map okay I'm gonna ignore these little bugs oh shit
okay when I think I have to fight these guys that hits me
Okay, he'll come back up, right?
No.
Hello.
Oh, my god.
Okay, now you come back up.
Okay, you're such a bitch.
I just want to summon him.
Fuen!
Okay, I hope...
I don't know if this resets this.
Okay, it does not.
Thank God.
That's right.
No light for you.
There you go.
Okay, let's see.
And so I can figure this out.
Oh my god.
I assume I have to jump from that.
Okay, I have...
Maybe I have to do like a running thing.
And then...
Yeah, I knew it.
Cheeky.
That's so cheeky.
Oh my god.
I have to do like a wiggle jump.
There we go.
Oh, man.
The parkour here is a lot more complicated than before.
I think, like, because we had so much, like, assist.
Oh, my God.
I didn't think you would.
Oh, nice.
My money now.
They, like, they, like, babyed us.
so hard with like all the stuff they did.
I think they they definitely babyed us more.
Silk saw is like, Hollow Knight was like elementary school and then Silk saw is like going to college.
Like we just go straight to college.
No, Hollow Knight is like going to kindergarten and then like
and then now we're like paying our college tuition
are there something below me but i don't want to risk it oh my god it's these win things what are these win things
what is this okay i have enough thank god oh my god thank god there's a bench gong gong gong gong gong going.
Why didn't you going?
Oh, there's a tram.
Expensive ass bench.
My doggy is here.
Get over here, boy.
Eita!
Yay!
Alright, I called you here for no reason.
Thanks for coming over.
There was no reason for you to be here.
I just wanted to say hello.
I ding-dong ditched.
Sharika, you look well at home in these wilds.
Poshanka, the scoundrel field office, offers many paths and much combat To leap from vantage upon the red shells or to meet them face front with rings ready.
These are decisions to live for.
I am much surprised those soft pilgrims ever safely climbed the scorched and savage place.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, wait, I have...
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I have this.
I gotta get these out.
I might as well.
all the beads out so I can also afford the vendors I think yeah I need the vendors I'm so lost without it nice all right now
get here
what the fuck is how do I get out of here that's the question
Oh, this...
Oh, this looks like a boss fight area.
Oh, no.
What do these do?
Because I don't jump higher with them.
Like, sorry, I was testing something else.
I feel like...
Hmm.
I wish I knew what this does.
Maybe it'll tell me later.
It'll definitely tell me later.
But it's still like, you know, what does it do?
What's this?
What the fuck?
Yeah, it has to be for later.
It's like, I don't know what else it could be right now.
God, I hope I grab him upgrade quick.
Oh, there is a creep.
Crazy Cultist!
Oh, my rosary beads are flying up!
Wait, what's this?
Wait, what are you?
Oh.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck was that?
They're like, yeah, they're like roly-poly.
Into the lava.
Alright, let me... when?
Okay.
he's like a little all right okay there's gonna be ability where i can use the loops not yet ow okay i i don't know i thought i don't know i i don't know what i thought was gonna happen i i don't know
I thought something different will happen, okay?
I thought it opened like a secret passageway.
It looked like it opened a secret passageway, okay?
Okay, there's a mysterious door here.
That looks like a boss fight door.
Secret pathway to respawn.
A pathway is a pathway.
When you roll out, wait?
Oh.
Goodbye.
If it works, it works.
Sometimes you gotta commit a little murder.
Holy shit, I don't even know where I am.
What?
This is a shortcut.
Yeah, I see it.
I was like, that destroys a hole down there.
And another shortcut.
Oh, never mind.
I already have $400.
Yay!
I'm robbing the...
I should say that out loud.
In game!
Just a...
you know it's in game oh wow black fire thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh thank you five gift of ships thank you thank you is that everything
was that everything i'm trying to think
there's definitely gonna be a lot of backtracking i can tell where does this go okay it goes back.
Yeah, that's the hole that he fell through.
I'm gonna backtrack here just to be sure.
Ow.
Get in that spike.
The joys of Metrovania.
That's the only downside for me because no one has this game just released today so no one knows where to go.
Nobody knows where to go.
I think I went everywhere.
Nobody can backseat me now.
Now I'm experiencing the real Metrovania.
Oh, where's this?
Hello?
Oh, I get a chair.
Yay, chair.
Hello, babe.
Well, aren't you a sight?
No, don't tell me.
Where's all this to come?
Boys, your form, are you hunted, pursued?
The citadel will see a fine prize in you.
It's as you say, madam.
Veiled bugs brought me to your land.
I seek them now for answers.
Ha!
Fierce too.
There are bleak times.
But powerful stray like you could certainly cause some change.
Well then, I have no love for that holy cast.
scaling state.
If you're seeking to settle a score, perhaps I can lend some aid.
If you're planning to send from these little fields, you'll be needing some lift, and I'm just the bug to help.
Head for the caves beyond my home.
The bugs within produce a marvelous spine.
Flexible, yet strong.
Collect those spines.
Return to me, and I'll soon... Oh, this is where I can fly!
I'm gonna learn how to fly!
She can fly!
It's like when elephants can fly I'll soon have your old cloak transformed into something more buoyant Okay Lexile Lexile spine Ooh, you have to kill A smart choice, get out here and gather those spines and best you be quick about it As nice it is at the company,
you hang around too long, those little bugs will turn your gaze on me as well What the fuck Hunt hokers in the far fields.
What the fuck is a hoker?
Far fields.
Where is that?
What is that?
Those flying things?
These guys?
Are you hokers?
No.
What do they look like?
These guys?
What is it those guys?
Or is it these guys?
Oh, it's these!
Right?
Oh!
I can just break it!
Okay.
That's actually convenient.
Oh my god, I'm actually...
No, that's fine.
Right.
How much do I have to...
Okay, I can just farm the spikes.
okay yeah it's scavenging I'll just fire him in man come on come on there we go come on throw them again that's right there we go how many did they need in five out of 25 yeah they only take three hits okay all right I got up I'm I'm gonna reset the world.
Now I know.
Ow.
I should bring in these guys, this too.
Yeah, because I know they...
Nice.
I poop a little.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Ow!
Nice.
When?
Alright.
And then there's one here.
Okay.
Alright.
And then one more.
Ow.
I keep forgetting he does that.
The last one too.
Oh my gosh.
If only let...
Alright.
Got another one.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
I got a little dash attack too.
Alright.
Reset time.
rewind time I'm back wait how much I need okay okay farming this is easy
and I'll farm these guys too oh
alright nice alright that was quite a bit alright this guy
nice that's actually a really good farm Look
at that!
I'm teaching you guys the most efficient way to farm, too!
Oh, I got it.
That's pretty fast.
Alright, now I can fly!
Thank god.
I thought I was gonna be, like, stuck in this area.
I can fly!
Hello, ma'am.
Well then, I can tell by the rattling from within your cloak.
Your hunt was a success!
It'll kindly pass over the spines.
I can get to work.
I believe I can fly.
I believe I can touch the sky.
Perfect, these should be more than enough.
Wait there, just a moment, and we'll soon have you soaring up and away from these lowlands.
Oh.
I got the drafter cloak.
Flare the cloak to ride a strong glide.
Oh my god, my leg.
Oh my god, put your clothes on.
That is fine work.
See, you're on a vacation.
Well, yeah, whoa.
Put your damn clothes back on.
She's just naked under there.
You're quite welcome, dear.
A rare opportunity.
practice um such intricate sewing in a war so that you would be able to properly appreciate my addiction additions blown away now stray one and do try not to die i rather not have my hard work going away so just a moment dear before you scurry up i'd love to spoil the surprise but curiosity beg me to ask do you know why they pursue you those citadel bugs no certainly no certainly certainty,
but I have a strong suspicion.
They help me for my nature, for the silk produced within my seashell.
Aha!
Truth, no doubt.
In Farlum, yours is a rare skill.
Prize beyond measure.
The channel won the soul within a thread.
Soul and silk is separately linked.
Um, it's silk and soul for like silk song.
It's a skill almost lost from Farlum.
Those old weavers shared it, but they're long dead now.
There's another live in this kingdom that shares my nature, or some part of it.
I've seen silk similar to my own.
It snares the shells of those upon the road.
I've seen it wrapped and possessed them whole.
There is will within that thread.
One that seems to come from somewhere above us, a citadel.
A little bit.
Hmm.
Good sharp sense you've got.
That citadel, all roads to words and all answers waiting.
And a long climb up there, my dear.
Now, it's time you get going.
Your style and your silk sure are fine.
But stay too long, and you'll only be trouble for me.
All right, rushed.
Let's go.
So there's another half-breed out there.
Ooh.
Whoops.
That's like, just like me apparently.
Wee.
And then I float.
Okay, that's funny.
I'm dead.
Because she said that there's like someone like her.
Wee.
I messed up.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I go there.
this way oh my it's so silly i'm sorry but when i do it a little float like this it's so silly yeah thank you the super chat thank you thank you make you glad are the spines of your enemies that's pretty metal not gonna lie we i'm like a little balloon a little balloon boy oh okay how How?
Oh!
I realized I don't have Pogo anymore.
So I was like, wait a minute.
How do I do this?
I can't...
I can't do an upward shot though.
What?
I don't know how to do this.
Oh.
Maybe here?
Oh!
Okay.
There we go.
Wee!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, it was just...
Oh, it's for a mask shard.
Oh, it's different, too.
The mask is different now.
Is there any secrets?
Okay, so that was a pointless area.
Ah!
Sorry, sorry, I thought that was empty.
Look,
new mechanic!
New mechanic, guys!
New mechanic!
Wee!
Alright, let me grab my stuff real quick.
new mechanic my brain hasn't registered yet oh thank god thank god girl got deflated
i i said i can't get over this it's it's so dumb
all right it's just such it looks so dumb but i'm barely i'm not very easily amused
hello friendly not friendly fourth chorus guys i don't think he's friendly i don't know how i'm still like
I don't know how I still want to pogo.
Like...
What?
What do I do?
He took away all my platforms.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
When?
I was gonna say, you took away all my platforms.
Okay.
Don't take away my platforms!
Not my platform Oh shit Whoops When
No my platform
Okay Stop being angry Get therapy Oh fuck Get therapy Don't be angry
It's nice that I can just glide though You know There we go.
Oh, shit.
Now I have less platform.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Oh!
Way!
Oh, unlucky.
Oh, I don't know what to do.
Oh, that.
There we go.
Wee One
Okay, I will say the glide is so OP it we
Wee It's so dumb.
It's so yay It's so Don't be.
I can just do this forever.
There we go.
He should be the best game mechanic.
I just fly.
I'm like, yippee.
Mary Poppins.
I'm like, Mary Poppins.
And I realized, I was like, wait a minute.
I can just do this.
I can just...
Yeah.
I just flowed.
Or a farming myth.
Like, the weirdest straw with this one.
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
I'm literally just flying.
I'm Mary Poppins, y'all.
Wee.
All right.
Oh, yes, I have to walk that.
Oh, no, she's not here!
I was like, okay, guys, we're gonna listen.
Okay, I want her to sing for us!
Okay, we're gonna go to the bone marrow place.
Let's go to the tram real quick.
We all float down.
I gotta walk, dad.
It says walkie time.
Alright, let's go next to our big buggy mommy.
Alright, here we go.
cookies okay all right we're gonna she should be here right it's our buggy dummy mom no she's not here no oh oh oh my god she's here you see i'm sorry maybe she'll she sing will she sing for me
this okay we're gonna stand next to her all right we're gonna stand next to her oh whoa whoa whoa
okay i'll be right back dad okay i'll be right back guys let me put just walking dad be hurt okay where is it i gotta put it on in case people are like where does she
walking my dog walking my dog BRB there we go
how was I gone hello I'm back I was literally so I would have been back sooner but I was literally someone's side quest in their life someone like they like went up to me and like asked me 20 questions about dad Because like, they were like obsessed with like weiner dogs.
And they like stopped.
I literally was like two minutes to my door, to my lobby door.
And they stopped me and was like, whoa, how old's your dog?
And then they asked like 20 questions.
And I was just like, uh, and then he like was like, he wanted, and then he like spent their petting my...
I didn't want to be rude or like, you know, I didn't want to be like, no pets, $20.
And then you want to pet him.
yeah it was an unskippable cutscene um so then and then he really wanted to like and then dad actually let him pet like let him pet him um and i was like whoa you're letting a man touch you right now that's crazy he ain't no pretty lady um so i was very surprised so i was literally in an unskippable cutscene because he kept petting my dog yeah whoa i paid a pet uh so yeah that's why Like,
I could have came back, like, five minutes earlier.
Because he, like, he pees and poops very fast.
I was nearly...
If I wasn't in an unskippable cutscene, I'd be back faster.
Eita!
I wonder if I'm, like, making good progress compared to everybody.
Compared to, like, the 800 million other streamers playing this game right now.
I'm just wondering...
Am I... I don't even know if I'm making good progress compared to everybody else.
No clue.
I mean, I did complete some of the bosses pretty fast.
I know, like, a lot of streamers.
Like, literally everybody is playing this game right now.
Everyone did, like, a hard grind.
Um, everyone was doing a hard grind to, like, a hard grind of Hollow's Net.
Wait, is it?
Oh, I had to go to the ant place.
I keep forgetting to the ant place.
platforming is that i i feel like i'm mastering it a bit regarding the um um um the parkour i think this is the filter this fucking park this is the filter when they do the parkour shit for this oh no of course the speedrunners are ahead of me it's because like when you have the po going so ingrained in your head it's it's really weird to like not pogo yeah but I was gone for a little I did did a little intermission yeah I think dive kick is the filter just jump over everything okay
um we're gonna go to the hunt oh we gotta go down it's like oh shit I know fuck you I'm a full heal Uh, okay, it's this way.
Wee.
I'm sorry.
It's just so stupid when I...
Wee.
It makes me so happy.
I think when you get this, you can skip majority of the parkour.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, I should have went from the top part.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah, the glide saves a lot of time.
Um, we go straight.
Wee!
Ow!
Oh, whoops.
Oops, I messed up there.
Wee!
Okay.
There you go.
I unlocked the glide, yeah.
I'll just fucking glide.
Fuck this.
Wee!
I don't care enough about this stupid parkour area.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, wait.
I just want...
I want to grab this for the thread, the silk.
Yeah, I love the glide.
It's just so fucking dumb.
The glide makes me happy.
Ah!
happy.
Yay.
Oh my god.
I could do.
I'm so happy.
I.
What do I... Oh.
Imagine.
Oh.
Imagine if I could cheese that.
Where the fuck do I go then?
No, wait a hornet looks up.
I'm like, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Happiness.
God.
No, I can't cheese it.
Wait, maybe if I go all the way down.
Reset the mob.
Should I do it?
Should I cheese it?
I feel like I feel like that's a skip.
I don't think I'm supposed do that guys okay hello follow me follow me follow me
oh that's oh whoops
oh okay wait friend okay wait um no i can't i can't do the skip unless i do this No, I can't.
I think that would be a really cool skip if I pull it up.
It's 100% doable, but I can't do it now.
That would have been a really cool skip, though.
Oh my god, it's the same trap.
It's the same trap that I got caught in.
Wee.
Okay, here we go.
This is what I needed to do.
Maybe this is where I...
Oh.
Dead body?
Hello?
Oh, this is a boss fight?
Question mark?
Oh.
This looks ominous.
This looks scary.
Chapel of the Beast.
What is this?
Okay, there's a shortcut here.
What?!
Okay, we gotta farm.
Okay, we gotta go back.
I gotta get some thread.
I used to glide too much, guys.
I glided too much, and now I don't know how to do anything else.
Wee!
Stupid.
okay
the ceiling oh my god it's so far it's so far okay there's a faster way for this all right we go back to the tram i died to an ant i did yeah we go to the trap where's the tram station wait where is my tram seat oh wait where's my tram station It's like...
Oh, here it is.
Wait.
Where is he?
Oh, here, here.
Ada!
Okay.
We'll go deep talks and go up.
I think that's faster.
I think that's a lot faster.
Okay.
Oh shit, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, how do I get there faster?
Okay, we go up top, then right.
Is that it?
Yeah.
It's this way.
Alright.
Wee!
Hot shit!
I can't help it, guys.
Okay.
Alright, yeah, go up here.
Uh...
Do you remember how to get there fast?
This way?
No, that's the...
wall dash.
I do that when I have wall dash.
Okay, buddy!
Okay!
Oh my god, I hate you.
my foot you can't cancel I don't know if you can but so far I can't cancel the friend thing can you actually cancel it
I'm on I feel like I can yeah cuz I tried to cancel it and it wouldn't let me I can holy shit this guy every time he's got me every time he's read my mind
i can't help it chapel of the beast oh you me zoom me zoom me yeah i love that the little zoom he does it's just so cute i just float this no
Oh my god.
Okay, it's harder to do this when...
Okay, I'll say it's very hard to do the float.
And this at the same time.
It's very difficult.
I forgot to sit in a chair.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're going to try and get to the chair.
Okay, let's try to get to the chair.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Imagine if I stepped on that trap again.
Wait, isn't that chair the trap?
Oh my god, that's not even a real chair!
It wasn't even a real...
Oh my god.
I just remember.
That chair wasn't even real.
That's the worst part.
Oh my god.
Please let me...
I'm your little...
That's the worst part.
It wasn't even a real chair.
Oh!
Oh, no touch.
I gotta be so careful.
It can be.
No, it can't.
It's a trap.
I can disarm it?
Hell.
Wait, I can.
Look, it came back.
It went...
Oh!
Secret E!
I got to sit in my chair!
Oh!
Nice.
Okay, that's good to know.
Ow.
I'm happy now.
Thank God.
Ow, it's gonna be so...
You can actually disarm.
Okay, we're not gonna fall for this guy again.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, you're actually such a nerd.
That's good to know.
That's actually good to know.
Okay, I'm gonna have to figure out how to do this fucking thing properly.
I don't know why, like sometimes it just...
There we go.
Like, this is easy.
This is easy.
We float down.
Yippee.
There, see?
Oh, wait.
He evil?
Why evil?
I flee you.
There you go.
I...
Get fucking Merry Poppins!
Oh my god.
Big strong bug.
That tab done.
Wee.
Okay.
A shortcut.
Okay, now we...
Boss, but...
I don't know if I can first try him.
If he does...
Oh, I knew it.
See, like, they all do two damage now.
What?
They all do plus two.
It's so annoying.
Okay.
Get two plus two.
Oh, wait.
I messed up that.
Didn't get me this time.
2.
Stupid plus 2 shit.
It pisses me ah.
Ha!
Is this stronger here?
But the only thing annoying about that here is that um
shit.
Oh.
Alright.
Like oh.
Okay.
I need to lock in for this.
This guy is difficult.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm gonna use my needle.
Whoa!
Oh, what?
He has friends!
How do you have friends?
Doki got rude.
You don't deserve no friends.
Can't believe he has friends.
Oh my god!
Crush them!
This is... this is bullshit.
Oh!
And they fly!
Okay, I was doing really well though.
I was doing really well.
I figured out his pattern.
Oops.
I need to go back to chair.
Oh my god, of course this ad fucking blocks me.
He's not that difficult when you figure out the pattern.
But it's just, it's when it's not a, it's not a, it just stops becoming a 1v1.
That's annoying.
Oh my god.
I needed that too.
Okay, I got full souls.
And then he dropped his friends.
No, he doesn't deserve nice things to be said about him.
He's pretty easy.
It's literally just the fact that he has his friends helping him.
Which should be illegal.
If I don't have my fucking friends helping me, he doesn't deserve that friends helping him.
No.
Ah!
Psychic reading the super chat.
No friends like my solo cute apex, night ring, and marvel rivals cry.
Psychic, thank you for the super chat.
That was...
Are you serious?
Quinn.
Oh my god.
I literally just have to stay on the ground for this.
There you go.
Are you serious?
Holy fuck.
Okay.
I messed that up.
There you go.
That's fine.
I got some of my HP back, though.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Not the friends.
No!
His friend!
My friends blocked me!
I was about to fly a different way!
His friends cheated.
Oh!
His friends are not strong!
They just have numbers!
I need to make sure I don't step on the trap.
Stupid friend.
I got friend blocked.
Goddamn friend blocked.
Wait a sec.
Let's realize.
Alright, there you go.
Basically, whatever happens is that whenever I mute myself, the GoXLR slider always goes, like, sometimes it'll go down by one.
So, like, I always have to, like, raise the volume back up every time I mute myself to make sure that it's back at this what it's supposed to be.
The fight didn't even start yet.
That should have been illegal.
There we go.
Alright.
I need to make sure I don't fucking...
I don't jump too much.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh my god, friend time.
You stupid friend.
Mad.
He's not even that hard.
It's literally the plus two and friend.
The plus two and the friend buff is what's fucking me right now.
i swear to god he's i like i know his patterns it's literally plus two plus two stupid friends why does he have so many i'm gonna kill all his friends and i hope he dies alone
i hate it i hate multiple enemies rng i hate it so much It's literally one of my biggest pet peeves.
It's one of my biggest pet peeves in terms of hero design.
Or like boss fight designs.
Oh my god.
Okay, that was foolish.
I was impatient there.
He's successfully rage-aiding me.
He's rage baiting me so well.
I hate it
Alright Yeah Maybe He gets this friend now Thank god thank god thank god he killed his own friend
That's actually so fucked
Okay I have to be so careful
Oh my god.
Oh, that's not fair.
Oh, thank god.
It's caught up, boss.
Exactly!
I did not bring your own friend party!
Oh!
Oh, my god.
Oh, my god!
He takes up half the fucking screen.
He took up so many parts of the screen.
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm in fight club right now.
This feels like fight club.
He's literally putting me in fight club.
Oh.
difficult i know i keep saying but it's literally not difficult it's just it's just the randomness the rng like him himself it's not as like hard to figure out it's just the random elements oops okay i look how i set that and then i said okay okay you know i deserve that
I rushed it There I rushed it Oh my god I threw off my groove Lost kin Yeah it feels like Lost kin But like Lost kin is Not as frustrating Only because I'm playing with anger now I'm not playing with I'm playing with anger I'm not thinking things through Because I'm so angry At least like Lost kin These guys are like tiny and they're one shot his friends are so tanky too
okay i got i'm coming down i'm zen i'm zen i'm zen i swear to god i'm zen now
yeah lost king is not as frustrating because he's dead Yeah, fuck you.
I wonder if that, like, gives me...
I wonder.
I'm curious.
Why is he, like, up in the air?
What the fuck?
He's, like, more in the air now.
It's so weird.
He's supposed to be more on the ground.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
Gwen.
He's like, well, you keep calling friends, so I assume like...
I thought you wanted to bring my friends along, too.
I'm like, that's not what I mean.
And you know it.
I just have to get rid of...
I have to get rid of him.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
friend oh
please stop
thank god
friend that's fine no no
god if he did one damage if he did one damage This shit would be even easier.
But he doesn't do one damage.
It was such bad timing.
The fact that two of them spawned in.
You know what?
I know what I need.
It's time.
For him to have a bad time.
All right, here we go.
It's on silk song time.
Okay.
Ah, shit.
I already messed it up.
Are you sure?
I didn't even figure out when is the right time to use this.
Oh, what?
Okay, I always...
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Oh, I'm locking in.
I'm actually locking in.
This guy has been tilting me.
No.
Oh my god, I hate this guy.
Thank god, okay.
Thank god he killed his friend.
Because I think this one is the worst one to get RNG-wise.
And then he gives it to me again!
At RNG!
He's so hard to kill, like, the big guy.
He's so tanky.
he too he's so fucking tanky so like he's so tanky the rng like i need the little guy all right that's a run killer i feel like if you're speed running this like you gotta hope it's the little guys because the big one seemed like a run killer the
thing is i it's hard to let me have him try and take him out myself like have him the big guy because he could I have such limited space I have such limited space in general for it I wonder if that like counts as damage I don't know me doing that needle thing counts as like damage in general oh shit that was an accident That's good,
I have.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, friend coming down.
Friend coming down.
Oh my god, that was a...
Oh my god!
He ricocheted me and threw me...
This is my ceiling.
This is the filter.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Stupid.
I'm fucking- I'm farming you for thread.
And I'm going back.
Angry jumps.
I'm angry!
I need to focus up.
I know I keep saying I need to focus up.
Eh.
Fuck it.
I don't really need to charge it up.
Oh!
I would say if you can beat I will say if you beat this guy like pretty fast you get good you get good RNG plus like you're pretty good
I think this is the filter boss for the new players only because like there's too so much RNG if you get really good RNG with like with like um like his the spawners I think like It's doable But I'm not
They're locking I might not talk as much right now because this guy makes me so fucking angry Yeah
Okay, let's hope that does a lot of damage because I don't know Thank God
Yeah Okay, friend time.
Nice.
Fucking course.
Okay.
Oh, no, not another one.
No!
Blocked so much!
They blocked the...
Oh.
arena so much.
A stupid arena block.
I hate him.
He doesn't deserve friends.
I will kill all his friends.
And so he'll die alone.
Everyone he's ever encountered or met will be gone from this living earth.
I will make sure he dies alone.
Because anyone he's ever met is the reason for their deaths.
He is the reason why they're all dead.
Said calmly.
Everyone.
Not even just his friends.
Everyone he's ever met, interacted, or like had a presence in their minds.
Where I'm Tokyo's best Tokyo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
There has to be an easier way to deal with, like, the...
Friend time?
Oh, my god.
Holy shit.
Another one!
It's so bullshit!
Okay.
He caught...
okay that's just I'm sorry I'm just playing with anger now like that was so bullshit oh my god
okay just my friend charge up didn't work I'm
crashing up
all right and then yeah I got rage baited I'm getting rage baited so hard he's like those I swear he's like Lex Luther and his fucking rage baiting monkeys that's him that's him and his friends no I don't need a jump but I thought where when I was just trying to position myself in a good area that's him he's like the rage bait baiting monkeys with Lex Luther he's Lex Luther and those his friends are all the monkeys and they're all typing like fuck you You suck!
I can't believe that's a real movie scene.
I didn't watch it, but I saw the clips.
And then it's literally just like a bunch of monkeys like trolling Superman.
The damn Luther monkeys.
It's so silly.
It's actually so silly.
It's one of my... It's my...
I never watched the movie yet.
But it's honestly one of my favorite scenes.
It's such a fucking goofy scene.
The amount of hate he has for him is so justified.
Oh my god, it's the first one, too.
The fact
that he goes all the way,
I wish it was just the ground one.
Oh, ding guy.
Oh my god, no!
I should have just got hit by the small one.
Ren.
Oh my god!
I need to just be hit by...
Ah!
It's him!
The big ones throw me off so much!
Yeah, I need to be hit by the small one, not by the big one.
Because at least the small one is 1 HP.
Actually, I don't know if the other guy is also...
Oh...
No, it does.
The ram lets you take out his minions, but it's so hard to time it correctly.
I know that you're like, why are you gonna hit by the little guys?
I don't care.
Like, I have a bench next to me.
I just need a farm thread.
Yeah, maybe I'll... Yeah, I'm gonna try and use my needles more.
You're right.
I'm going to be more aggressive with my needle.
I think that's the strat.
I'm just worried because he does so much damage that I just want to heal.
I'm trying to save it for heal.
Oh, does the cocoon give me a throw no matter what?
I don't know.
The first phase is easy.
was just a 1v1.
He's fucking done.
He knows.
He fucking knows.
He knows if it's just a 1v1 it's over for him.
I missed.
There we go.
Ah!
Yeah!
He knows he... No, the big guys isn't... I don't know if the big guys are one shot.
Okay, that third gives me full...
He knows.
He knows that I win in a 1v1 no matter what.
Are you serious?
Okay, fuck it.
He actually backed up.
He's never backed up before.
Yeah, I got comboed.
That's fine.
I am 2 HP instead of 3.
But his first attack is so...
His first phase is, like, not that difficult.
Okay, so I don't have to farm.
That's good.
That's good to know.
That is a weird hit.
I thought, like...
Okay, the hitbox is not...
I don't know the hitbox.
Alright.
I get, like, I...
Do you guys see that?
I get iframes if I hit him.
Which I've noticed.
There you go.
No, no, no!
I...
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay, that's fine.
I did not mean to heal.
I was trying to use the threat attack.
That's fine.
Ah, fuck.
I should have healed that.
I can't even heal.
Oh!
That's good.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
I want HP now.
Nice.
Not okay.
Okay.
Full HP.
But I...
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God.
No!
Oh, I got locked in.
Okay, now that I know what Grant's flow is through it, the sandwich.
Yeah, he sandwiched me.
He sandwiched me hard.
I looked at chat.
I didn't realize my ladder was off.
I was looking at chat.
Chapel of the Beast.
Someone said, like, I remember people were like, oh, Mantis is the hard is a hard filter like the first filter matches was not as hard as this
like oh shit whoops i need to focus i'm not focusing what
what why did i what what happened it like pushed i like pushed me up i don't know what happened
Oh, fuck.
I looked at chat.
Let's go back to the bench.
We reset.
Hee-hee.
Oh, was it a dash attack?
I didn't even realize.
Oopsie.
I shouldn't look at chat when I have to parkour.
It's my weakness.
Yes, I'm still at this part.
I envy all the streamers that passed this part really, really fast.
I envy them.
I hit...
I think I'm getting hit by, like, the worst RNG possible, too.
Are you serious?
When...
I think everybody can catch up to me now because of this area.
Oh.
Okay, nice
Oh, oh my god
Nice, okay
Again, oh my god, he missed
He actually missed it Okay, there you go
I can't kill him Wait, what?
was that guy bugged out wait his helmet bugged out
yeah that
one was invincible he gave him an invincibility glitch what more does he need they all kind of bugged what yeah i was thinking like what more do you need have everything you need to fucking kill me.
You really need more.
Oh shit.
Okay, I'm raging.
I'm raging.
Motherfucker fucking cheated.
He had plot armor.
He actually had plot armor.
At least I'm really good at this parkour now.
In this specific spot.
Oh my god I swear Please make this be part of the story Please Oh I have a feeling this is an This is an optional boss I have a feeling I'm just doing an optional boss right now I think that's the worst part I feel like this is an optional boss I Shoot
Don't tell her.
Oh, that makes it worse.
There we go.
We don't know.
I...
Okay.
I can't do anything about it.
I don't even know how many staggers do...
What do you mean?
Oh, my...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I couldn't kill him in time.
I know.
I have a feeling this is an optional boss.
The more I fight him, the more I fight him and seeing the difficulty spike, I'm so sad.
I'm going in.
I'm still going in.
The more I fight him compared to the other boss.
There's no way there's no way you're not optional.
He's no longer optional in my book.
I have to kill him I don't care.
I don't care if everybody now is now ahead of me.
I don't care.
I have to kill him
What?
Oh, I don't know the hitbox.
I thought I I thought I thought, bro, okay, sometimes her helmet isn't the exact hitbox.
So I thought, uh, I thought I was, like, about, like, I was, like, under it.
Oh, wait, what am I missing?
I'm stubborn.
I don't care.
I will kill him.
It's personal now.
Maybe I need to upgrade it now for it.
Okay.
tilted no 100% don't worry I am indeed tilted no I am 100% like I'm dying to stupid shit like that when I shouldn't be when what what it made me dash to the left instead of the right it doesn't even tell me where to upgrade my nail this is worse than lost kin i would say i would say lost kin is harder than it's easier than this uh because you can't control the rng of what bugs he spawns if he spawns all the ground ones then it's good if he spawns a giant fucking tanky uh invincible spiky lords guys that also fly then it's bad that take up like one fourth of the screen oh my god sorry I'm like when I'm ranting I lose focus okay okay I need to focus up there you go I'm focusing up for real all right there's friend number one there's
friend number two
Oh my god, there's friend number three!
Because also, whenever he spawns his friends, it's also RNG.
Because sometimes he doesn't spawn anything!
It was over when Big One appeared.
No.
If I quit now, they win.
They win!
Okay.
Just need to get into a good rhythm.
There we go.
Okay.
Fucking course.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
How many face does he have?
Oh my god.
I swear to God.
Yes!
That's right.
That's why you don't need friends.
I didn't need friends and I killed you.
This will be time.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
tier foes was that buying to enter a wild fury and steal life from prey
what did i have life steal
what did i get we have vampirism that's fucking op as shit i do not believe that this boss was supposed to to be easy.
And it was not...
Wait, what?
Wait, it changed.
Wait.
The area changed.
Didn't notice that.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
What?
What did I do?
Cyber...
Dragoon, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's your victory bonus.
Doki Knight.
I did it.
Also, that was definitely optional.
That was fucking optional.
It was optional.
Oh my god, where do I go?
I'm so sad.
I can't believe that was option.
Okay, we go back to Firefields.
There is an area I've yet to go.
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
Everyone's ahead of me now.
Everyone is like 20 chapters away.
Wait, where's my...
Oh.
But do they have the beast crest?
True.
Where is...
What?
I have no compass with the beast crest.
What's the point?
What?
I don't...
If I don't have those, I can't even get...
I was like, where do I go?
You can't...
Okay.
Okay, we'll just...
I had to go down anyway.
Okay.
It's for bosses, Toki.
The beast does not need direction.
It's true.
It's so true.
The beast need not need to know where to go.
The beast's hungers.
Isn't that right?
The real gamers know where they are without the compass.
I was like wondering.
I was like, where the fuck do I go?
okay left down right okay oh yeah i get the oh what the fuck guys guys chill out
okay there is a lot the people are like oh why don't you go there there's a lot of areas that are locked up right now I'm not very behind at the moment.
Because we had our little intermission.
I think every other boss now is going to be easier.
After what I had to deal with.
A lot of bosses are going to be a lot easier than the fucking beast.
Than the goddamn...
Oh my god, that stupid lava.
I forgot to like, do this.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What's the...
I think that one was a wall jump, right?
Okay, wait.
Yeah, definitely an...
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew I couldn't go up there.
I had a feeling it was a wall jump.
Hey, get me out of this guy.
Get me out of here.
Wee.
All right, where does this go again?
Okay.
Oh, it's supposed to go up here.
Oh my god.
Ah!
I was...
I was supposed to be up here.
We lost players.
I did like the fucking wildest intermission possible.
I sound so sane, right?
now after everything i've been what the fuck are you guys playing baseball like what are you doing am i interrupting some baseball they're like we're trying to play baseball this is our baseball practice rude oh my sorry okay
to be fair it is my fault i did interrupt her baseball.
Get off the field.
I was like, no hobbies allowed.
If I can't have fun, nobody can have fun.
Rip do something.
She's on the field.
That's fucking right.
No one can have fun.
I'm still so sad.
I can't believe.
I still can't believe I missed it.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Now what you're gonna do with one pitcher?
You can't play catch with just by yourself.
That's fucking right.
Is that it?
Is this supposed to be lore?
what am i supposed to do maybe if i there you go no that's just a lore room apparently i still yeah it was literally like they're just here trying to play catch and i just went to kill him you monster the day baseball disappeared from the kingdom yeah oh you have held tight to fate having carried further the station Shall offer a brief rest to those devout.
Oh, nice.
Sing, then.
Don't despair, pilgrims.
Run.
Lift your sight and raise your voice.
Have no fear, pilgrim.
True.
Believing is a happy choice.
Oh, that should get rid of my...
My son's eyes.
Holy there.
Aren't those fields marvelous?
And above us are your bountiful moors.
Where every pilgrim can fill their belly.
These hot fields are a wonder indeed.
The hunter's proud, the long grass.
Praying your instruments will only alert them to your presence.
Well then, alert them I shall!
For when many gathered, great songs are sung.
These poor traveler finds her resolve moaning.
When I first greeted her, her voice was so scarcely, I harshly, scarcely heard it.
There's no cause for worry, though.
My song will lift her from her to a prayer.
Join your voice with mine.
Red Maiden, together we shall rouse our fellow pilgrims!
Alright, chair.
What are you?
I'm gonna rest your...
Mort!
worry body the climb is agonizing and even the devout must mind your limits i'm impressed to find any without firm claw my weapon that could ascend so far indeed we are very lucky to have made here luckier than many others or perhaps the difference between a lucky and unlucky is merely fate now while you rest shall we make a trade and if you have rosaries i'll gladly I'll take them gladly.
Or reinstruct yourself.
You'll be with me.
Oh, this is steady body.
Um.
I can add some pockets.
What do I do to use shards for?
I can add some pockets to the camera to us.
That'd be nice, wouldn't it?
Okay.
Oh, we could.
Wait, let me...
Okay.
Okay, let me...
Do I have, like, those Rosary Beasts?
No, I do not.
I want to buy memories, so I...
I'll get Poise.
I grab that.
And it'll be like, you don't have memory to put your poison on me, like, oh, fuck me, I guess.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, oh, they're gonna say that.
Don't earn it.
They're gonna...
Funny.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
I have a feeling.
Nice upgrade, don't you?
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, I thought that was a breakable wall.
There's something on the other side.
You guys heard that?
Oh, you see?
Okay, I have to jump.
Oh no Oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
Oh wait Oh wait I'm fine This won't hurt me Oh Oh It's like the shittiest ride oh that means okay that means i'm gonna learn a ground pound because like that thing over there or maybe that
okay i'll go this way oops yeah that's gonna break it okay there you go i was gonna say Okay, no secret here.
Wee.
Okay, gotta do this yet.
And I float.
God, I look so goofy.
I just look so goofy whenever I float.
I love it.
Wee.
Oh my.
Get out of here!
God, I cannot.
wait to get nail upgrades and you'd be like nothing to me it's cute but it's also goofy for her because i would see this more for that whoa oh is this a gray more wait gray more
wait what
isn't that like whoa oh you need a map
Oh, yeah.
Nice view.
Very greeting, Shakara.
Shakira.
You're welcome, Sayamist, to sod and gloom of these caverns.
Baby, don't.
Child-wielding needle.
Your aspect is still sharp.
My respect remains.
Heed a warning.
Many fierce bugs roost nearby.
On the lake beyond this cave nest, a ragged horde, atop an old watermelon.
Their mastery of flight makes them dangerous.
My shell will very carry the score of their pins.
If you're seeking a safer path, head back towards this land core.
Okay, I have no money.
I'm broke, Shakira.
The other man took my money.
Okay, but she's basically Shakira.
Isn't...
Wait, what's this?
Insert rosary?
God damn it, I'm broke every...
everywhere.
The hat?
What is that?
Oh, thank God.
Cultists.
Just what I need.
Oh.
Too bad there's no life, guys.
That's so unfortunate.
Oh, I can swim, too.
Yay!
Sucks to be dumb.
Sucks to be you.
That's over here.
Oh, it's locked.
Everything is locked.
No service.
Okay, I don't really want to go back over.
Whoa!
They fight back.
Okay, I actually need a...
Okay, we gotta reset this.
I'm gonna farm these people.
All right, we gotta go back.
Wait, is there a bench near?
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's no bench nearby, right?
I have to go all the way down for the bench.
Oh, my God.
Shakira, do you know where the benches are?
Oh, I can't go back.
Oh.
Oh, I messed up.
I messed up.
She told me not to go that way.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there's a bench next.
I forgot that's a bench.
I still messed up, though.
Shakira was like, don't go that way.
And I was like, okay.
Oh, I got it.
Yes.
It doesn't, it's because this doesn't look like a bench, so I forgot.
And how much money did I get?
64.
I didn't.
I need, like, 70?
Alright.
I can't farm him.
I also need, like, 100 so I can buy the...
I assume the fast travel.
I actually need you alive.
Alright.
83.
Oh, shit.
Whoa!
A paco.
We need the...
We got the map.
I feel like okay we have to farm so much in silk song compared to before in hollow night I felt like there was less farming there's so much farming in this game for currency compared to like silk compared to a hollow night that's how it feels so far.
Oh my, that was my bet.
I was just taking it.
Really?
I didn't have to farm that much in Hollow Knight.
There you go.
All right, here you go.
Is that enough?
I can't, I don't remember.
52.
How much for this?
Okay, we got to sit in the bench.
Alright.
There's a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of gear this time around.
Then we're gonna lock that.
Oh, almost.
Okay.
That was like, I don't want to drop.
Don't drop into the pit!
Doki!
Okay, I need 80.
and grab 80 from.
Okay, I need to get closer so I can farm you.
I don't want your bees to fall into the ocean.
You're much... Oh, hey, secret.
Okay, wait.
There's secret there.
Alright, after I farm in, unlock fast travel, I go to secret.
There you go.
Okay, now.
Now I go back and I buy fast travel.
Hello.
Take my money.
Oh.
All right, that was a waste of my time.
Okay.
All right.
I guess that's what it was.
I guess.
Wow.
Okay.
It was just a string.
Nothing?
What?
Why would this be a hidden cavern?
Such a weird area.
Alright.
That's cool.
Up.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's figure this out.
I do think this parkour is more difficult than Hollow Knight.
The parkour segment only becomes...
Because, like, some of the areas you have to, like, it's definitely, like, the dash.
This is a test of reaction.
I'd say it's, like, the dash stuff, too.
It's a side dash.
Oh, my God.
I don't know yet, but I want to...
Jesus Christ, these enemies are fucking horrible!
There we go.
I'm okay.
And there's, like, some parkour where you have to run, jump.
Which is different from, like, what people are used to, maybe.
Har, well met, traveler.
Looking for a drink or a rest or both?
Fair greetings, good...
Fair greetings, good, bud.
The warmth of your hearth is welcome upon those wet-paint lambs.
Aye, it's a damp climb through these parts.
Used to be just pilgrims trekking my way, but odd times these are, and you ain't even the strangest shell wandering about.
A rowdy old warrior stopped through not long back, cause quite a scene, and now a young's last taken up lodging in my top room.
The less my thought, the less mention she's on the lookout for sharp tights like yourself.
Maybe pay her a visit, if you haven't already.
care for a drink traveler my nectar's got a kick that'll warm your shell in these Sodom chimes sure I'll have a lot money anyway what's it do few stronger pilgrims I survived to reach my home now barlooms curse claims the rest poor sods left to wonder I do sometimes get to wondering is the Dregs of their own mind and they're keeping walking or something else entirely.
You didn't even have to look at my license.
Oh, I opened the door.
Oh, I got silk out of that.
Look at that.
He didn't ask for my license.
Oh, okay.
That's the thing to sell.
The bone scrub.
What the fuck is that?
So you're surprised for Nu?
You're an adult, yes?
Fully grown?
Ready to hunt?
Certainly, I am the child, young one.
Perfect, then.
Nu must ask a wish.
For her, Nu would seek Farlum's many fabulous bugs and cut them.
Cut them with your blade and cut them with your mature spear.
Cut them with your savage adult heart.
Would you help Nu?
Could you take a scroll and fill as pages of learnings Oh, she, okay.
She a little...
No, not right in the head.
Oh, my!
You make me so happy!
Hug down the creatures of this land and record them in the script!
Oh, she's...
Yeah, she's a little intense, guys.
Just a little intense.
Oh, this is not...
No, I'm the hunter journal.
Learning about lands and habits is a worthwhile undertaking.
And perhaps you're more grown than you realize, new?
My?
Such a list of space will make new trouble.
Go now, art, and pray, and begin our learning.
Yeah, she's very forward, guys.
Just a little.
Dude, he's just a little freaky.
Oh, what?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, wait, they're dead originally.
What the fuck?
Okay.
So they were originally dead.
And then the thread.
Oh, they're like getting puppeteered.
I...
What the fuck?
Okay, these guys are crazy.
This one's...
This one's weird.
I'm trying to figure out a pattern for him.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out this guy's pattern.
there we go he has his his attack pattern is like pretty wonky no i swear ever since the fucking beast like this these guys are fucking nothing like
the beast has messed me up these guys are nothing compared to that beast compared to what the verb of the fuck I had to deal with earlier.
Okay.
Friend.
Alright, this way.
My side quest power up.
How much does he need?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
They took 20 from me?
Okay.
$20 for the string of Apparently
The service charge yeah, they took 20 bees for the fucking service charge Get over here boy now who it's top it's treats time.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you you want to zoom with me?
You want to zoom with me little boy Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, zoomie zoomies.
All right zoomies done Oh out my head.
Oh.
Okay.
It's just... I was like, you know what?
Fuck you!
I didn't realize it was a secret.
I hit it because I was just like, how dare you bump my head?
And then it was a secret.
I was just...
I was low-key just punishing the wall.
Oh my god.
Is that a fucking rat bug?
what the fuck that's a rat that's a fucking rat
holy shit
okay a bug oh my god nice can i do it here oh my god i will not need to
okay um none of these really okay wait what about the the okay i want to know what the beast crest does the beast crest have any anything i need oh my god there is something oh oh oh oh we didn't okay we didn't it's not our fault he you saw him He ran in there himself.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't like the rat, guys.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
I didn't...
I didn't think he turned around so fast.
Holy shit.
I'm so fucking fat.
Remmy can turn.
I thought he was gonna like wait a little and then turn around.
Like, you know, common AI.
You know, you know, the common AI where they...
Where they like...
There's like an intermission before it happens.
You know, I thought it was...
Oh my god.
They're everywhere.
I do not like these big rats.
I'm leaving.
Where am I?
Ah!
You thought you were gonna leave?
Oh my god.
He can swim too.
Okay, where am I?
I don't like this area.
Okay.
I really don't like this area.
I'll make sure I got everything around here.
Okay, this has to be a shortcut, right?
Where is this area?
Oh, oh, down!
Oh, here!
Okay, yeah, that was a shortcut.
I just don't have wall dash.
Oh my god, I like unlock...
I like how the bug carcass...
A bug carcass like fucking drops down after.
Didn't get me...
Wait, what?
I didn't do that.
Did he just walk there himself before I got there?
Okay, there's a shortcut here, but I can't get there yet.
Just to be sure, there's no secret over there.
there oh this is a sad town very sad oh morning you better not you better not be optional you better not be optional okay
all right i swear to god if you are an optional boss i Where the guy?
Oh.
Two hits!
I'm done.
I'm so done.
A fucking court.
Oh, thank God.
There we go.
I got damage for, like, hitting him.
Oh, my God.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck down here.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
I need to be like super cautious right now because I'm one HP.
I'm trying to like not force an attack.
Oh, I know I'm like playing really slow, but like I'm scared.
Because I, oh my god.
Oh, what the fuck?
Are you serious?
Oh.
Okay.
Holy fuck!
This is so...
Oh.
Oh my god.
This is so annoying.
I actually...
that was unlucky that was so unlucky all right i know where he is i could have first tried him i i could have okay it's time we going beast mode
we going beast mode oh wait i could put compass nice okay i actually needed that okay we'll put steady body all right the beast is here the beast that was here
And I don't have compass.
Okay, let me figure out how to get there.
Let me, okay.
Wait.
Is it me or is that different, too?
We go straight and then down.
Okay, we're just gonna skip this part.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we have to go to the secret then.
What the fuck?
shit wait this is a whole there's like new moves and everything
here we go this way we'll go this way then
i'm trying to remember how to get there okay i can't do that shortcut because
oh my god so and it's like it's like sonic now the beast move
Yeah, it's like a whole new move too The beast
Oh my god Nice Oh, so that's how it works Okay Okay, I get it Oh, it's so fast
Oopsie Oopsie Sorry, I was thinking about the beast.
Yeah.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Alright.
Nope.
Okay, because the dash is a little different.
Oh, what?
Beast mode.
The beast hungers!
Oh my
god.
Wait, what?
He can cancel it?
Cancel my thing!
I didn't realize!
He cancels the beast!
Yeah!
He cancels it!
No!
How can I hunger if he cancels my hunger?
How else can I be hungry?
Oh, beasted the beast.
The downslash is a little it's not like exactly like a downslash it's a oh my gosh oh my god oh my I did not expect all these little guys I'm trying to remember how to get back all right we got the beast has to eat the beast has oh my god okay the beast is gonna die it's too dark the beast is scared now the beast is very scared I don't think I have that much money on me no I don't thank God I spent it all I remember now thank God I actually don't have a lot of money so if I die I don't have to worry too much
okay I actually I don't...
I don't have to worry too much.
Ah!
When she makes a...
So hungry!
You hear it?
That way she goes, Ah!
Bees hungry.
I think that vampirism is nice, though.
Where the fuck is my... Oh, there it is.
I was like, where is it?
Okay.
All right, locking in.
What?
Okay.
That's good.
All right.
The beast continues to hunger.
Yeah, it's like a Sonic Dash.
You guys recognize it?
Wait.
You guys notice that it's like a Sonic Dash?
How did I get hurt there?
Okay.
Oh, there's so much to juke!
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I got the...
I got the life still in time.
What?!
Okay.
I- it's hard to hit the saws consistently only because it's a it's a tilt.
It's a little tilty.
Oh.
Yeah, I did it.
I'm getting used to the- I'm getting used to the downward slash though.
Like this tilt thing is a little weird.
I gotta be patient, yeah.
No, the saws do two damage.
Every move does two damage.
That was close.
I actually forgot about that trap.
I did indeed forgot about that trap.
You can't.
It's...
It's nearly...
It tilts like that.
I don't think there... Unless there's another...
another quest does all the jumps are tilts what oh bitch I'll have to all right remember this trap here yeah oh it can do three as well oh my god that's so frustrating I swear to God if this guy is not sorry I I swear to God.
I'm literally doing all the...
I'm like accidentally doing optional bosses at this point.
Okay, I don't know how that happened.
Alright, nice.
I needed that life steal.
Nice.
He fucking... Oh my...
He got up just the moment I needed him not to.
Yeah.
I'm too scared right now to...
to use my needle attack.
Because he just, he does so much at once.
Like, oh my god.
He has too many moves that do like a lot of damage.
Like this.
Oh fuck.
I gotta make sure.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Super saws.
Damn.
The goddamn saws.
Yeah.
At least like, I can sort of get back here.
I like the beast though.
I like the life seal.
It's...
It's very helpful, I think.
I'm not gonna go too fast.
If I go too fast, the rats get me.
I can hit the saws.
We'll see.
Alright.
Oh my god, I have to...
I have to try and life steal something.
Are you...
Guys, this is bad.
The rats got me.
I have one.
I technically have one HP.
Because this guy does two damage.
Okay, I got some of my HP back.
Thank God.
Okay, I'm going to try and lock in more.
with this one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
That was such a risk to not use my...
Okay.
Are you... Oh my god!
Oh.
okay okay that's the team when he shoots the twice one i think you can parry it i just don't have it's so it goes so fast that i don't have time to like register
yeah it is like the the the sign when he does it um what's the the word like he what the fuck like his tell-tale his tell to like when to when he does that uh move is so it's such a the tell is really fast so that I really only have like one second to react to it and sometimes I don't have that second Where?
I don't want to run to that one because I knew I might get trapped.
Oh.
I have to use the bees.
I got my HP back.
Thank God.
Alright.
Okay, I parried it.
Thank God.
Yeah.
Oh.
Try my best to lock it.
Are you serious?
What?
Woo!
No!
I hate these saws.
I hate them so much.
Please.
Oh.
Jesus, guys, okay, give it to me straight.
He's an optional boss, isn't he?
Firestar, welcome to Tomato Fire, welcome.
He's optional, isn't he?
I fucking, I, oh, no.
We don't know.
Oh my god.
I need a note.
Okay.
Alright.
Do I have a shorter range too with this move?
I can't tell.
Because he's that beast.
Any knowers.
Any knowers in chat.
Is he optional?
This is very important.
Okay.
I think...
I think the range is shorter with the beast.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, I can do that.
But...
Alright, I'm pushing back.
I don't want him to corner me.
There you go.
Oh my god.
I need to...
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god, thank god.
I need HP, really bad.
I need to use my vampirism.
That's close.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I couldn't use my fucking vampirism!
It's a goddamn curve.
No!
Oh god.
Okay, I need to go to the other side.
Fuck!
Oh, fuck!
That hits me!
That really hits me.
Okay.
That hits me.
Of course it does.
Oh!
That attack hits me.
Yeah, I thought I was safe.
I just thought I was safe.
She was, in fact, not safe.
getting this.
I'm getting better at it.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I was about to jinx myself there.
I'm like a motorboat.
Oh, I wish there was a closer bench.
That's really it.
I wish there was a bench closer.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, I've got help from it.
It's too late.
I don't need no help.
Sometimes it's just too late.
I have to be so patient with him because he has so much anti-air.
Like...
There
you go.
Okay.
Is this move like the...
Oh, that's unlucky.
I'm not meaning to hit that.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, you flew up.
Fucking bitch.
Okay.
Oh my- God damn it, the curve.
Oh.
Okay.
Are you- Oh my god.
Okay, that's good, that's good, that's good for me.
What I've noticed, too, with these bosses is that they have more staggers.
I don't know if you guys noticed.
Yippee-y-y-y-y, yippee-y, yippee-y.
It's over.
They require more staggers.
than usual oh we did it i don't know where i am because i took off my compass i
i don't know where i live what's this the summon welcomes all who set the holy path may ease your shell within then your strength renew can carry you higher
what's that oh it's a puppeteer i told you it's a puppet i knew it
oh the haunted bell heart i killed a boss and all i got was lure what's over there what's everyone else looking at okay now i can swap my crest all right back to my map never mind
Don't worry, I'll help you.
Why are y'all just hanging there?
I assume that's the tram, right?
I don't even know if I'm supposed to be here.
I don't have money and I'm broke, too.
I'm just hanging out.
Hello?
Oh!
I don't think they're okay, guys.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, I knew it.
Never mind, it was nothing.
There was a platform here.
Oh, this door is gonna open.
I get it.
That's the door you have to open later.
Where are some cultists for me to...
Now where am I?
Shellwood, where the fuck am I?
Oh, it's these guys.
Oh, I hate these guys.
Ah!
Yeah, I hate these guys.
I'm gonna heal.
Alright, we are not going here.
We're not going to Shellwood.
I feel like I should explore more.
Yeah, they walk on water, and I can't hit water while in water.
Oh my god, it's the scuttlebug.
We're gonna do the scuttlebug.
Where am I supposed to...
Okay, now I guess we can go...
Alright, now we go to the other way.
Remember that other exit we went there?
Alright, now we go back.
We did our job.
Oh my god, I am...
Not okay.
At least she seemed like a...
At least I did a...
I think I did a story, boss.
And he's scurried away, Sarishka.
I don't know how to kill them.
Like I'm scared.
I'm so scared of this rat.
Oh my god, he does two damage.
Yeah, there's a reason why I was scared of you.
Jesus.
oh my god he blocks the only way out holy shit his death is oh my god i can't even get out i just realized i can't even get out
oh my uh i forgot about that And I'm, like, too broke to pay the tram.
I think that's the worst part.
I have no money.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this is how I get out.
Oh, my God.
I'm so...
Oh, shit.
All right.
That was close.
Oh, hey, money.
Take that.
Is there anything else here?
Oh my god, there has...
I hope there's a lamp.
I hope I find a lamp.
I'm just perpetually lost in this dark cavern.
This cavern of misery.
Oh my god.
This is like...
I swear if Silk Song has like...
The toxic lakes.
Then it truly is the dark souls.
of Metrovania.
They already got the rats.
They just need the poison lakes, and then we have it all.
My chair is here.
Yeah.
We go left side.
We just need the poison swamps.
Then it truly is in the dark souls of Metrovania.
They have everything.
They have almost... Oh.
My There you go It's like that.
I used it as a platform.
I used our rats There you go.
I had a feeling the rats were there.
Hello What the what?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, and then the rats show up It's all right.
It's fine.
He doesn't give me anything in there Anyway, I'll just slowly float down.
He's like, who's that?
I legitimately don't think he gives me anything useful anyway.
He's got scissors.
That's fine.
I needed heals for that.
Okay, nice thread.
But what do I do with thread?
That's it?
All right, I'll go this way then.
What have I not got over here?
Oh, they're all scissors, man.
How the fuck?
Oh, that's how I kill him.
It's like, snip, snip, snip, snip!
Wee.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I'm just...
floating in the air until he's done.
I just...
Okay.
Gotta float until he's done playing.
What does this do?
What the fuck is the point of this?
I just...
Look at my... Oh, I must be able to ground pound this area.
Okay.
Park boy got that stupid rat get out of here No, yo, yeah, I can't do anything else but go this way What the fuck what the fuck?
Okay, I did not expect him to fucking come up top
I'm just gonna run Pat Yeah, he's not a...
Yeah, no.
Look at these fuckers.
Now I'm gonna get you!
I don't like them.
Oh my god, I hate them.
Yeah, I'm not gonna deal with that.
I'm not gonna deal with that guy.
He is not worth it.
He is absolutely not worth it.
Oh!
I can't pogo!
Just do a shimmy because I can't pogo!
Okay.
I assumed this guy was supposed to help me.
If I, the chapel of the Reaper, since you guys said I could have got assistance with that boss.
Okay.
Well...
But I don't need no help.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, get it.
Oh my god!
You are such a freak!
Holy shit!
You are such a freak.
You are actually such a free holy shit
these guys have these guys are the most annoying these guys are the most annoying
okay there you go oh jesus
Trev?
What?
How?
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
He dodged?
Alright, nice.
These enemies.
Oh!
No!
Two of them!
Oh my god.
I need them to line up right now.
Oh, thank god.
I had to...
I need them to line up for the needle.
This was the only way.
It was the only way.
Literally the needle.
Healing them normally was just too much.
I don't even know who this guy is.
I just stabbed him for the fun of it.
I...
I don't know who this guy is.
I was like, dead corpse.
Stabby, stabby.
What crest is this?
Attack with heavy arching slashes and reap additional silk.
What the fuck?
What does this give me?
How much better is this anyway?
Is this the attack?
Oh my god, my compass is gone yet again.
Wait.
Oh, I have a...
Oh, this is different now.
Look at this.
This feels like a pogo.
Now I have a... now I have pogo.
Wait, I pogo now!
Yeah, and I have an uppercut.
I have an uppercut and I have a pogo.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean, this looks like a pogo.
Yeah, I have a pogo now.
No, this is 100...
Yep, I got Pogo.
Oh.
It is slower though.
That's the thing.
It is slower.
I will agree.
It is a little slower, but it is Pogo.
Uh, Pogo is when you can chop down.
So, so now it goes straight down versus like, before.
Okay, so I got this area.
Okay, there you go.
I got the shortcut now for this.
Where is this area?
What is this area?
Wait, what?
What?
Oh!
So I can heal and grab silk.
Hey, that's interesting.
Okay.
I can heal and grab silk at the same time.
I don't know where this area was.
What is this area?
I don't have my compass.
Oh, oh, I did this.
Okay, I remember.
Yeah.
That's an upgrade.
Wait, I like this crest.
This is a good crest.
I can pogo and I can like...
Uh...
And I can grab spells and get more.
found.
Yeah.
Spells it.
Okay, so that was pointless doing... I get to have a cooler crest.
And I have uppercut.
I have uppercut now.
Okay.
Uppercut!
Oh, I have enough money for fast track.
Fast travel.
Wait, I feel like I can finally buy Wait, how much money do I have?
I can buy...
Wait a minute, I can buy...
I think I can buy the...
Actually, I don't think so.
I don't have enough money.
I finally bought the last tool.
Because I was never able to afford it.
But if I buy it from Bone Mera...
No, I still need to spend $50.
Well, it's not a spell.
I get to spam my needle.
My needle is my spell.
Beckel.
Uh, I need to buy this.
And I still need more money.
Does anyone have any wishes?
Sure.
Here you go.
I have so many shards.
I grant you a wish.
Make a wish, child.
Look at that.
The gems that grow up provide pure harvest of treasures and be rewarded.
Where the fuck are flint beaters?
I got a wish promise.
Alright, let's...
Let's put some crests in there, I think.
Uh...
Is there a maximum amount of wishes I have to do?
I still haven't picked up their berries yet.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Okay, we need compass.
Uh...
I can put this and this.
And then that's it.
That's fine.
I'll get Compass for now.
And then we have to go.
Wake up.
Sleep time's over.
Bellheart.
I guess we have to.
I guess we have to cross the river.
I
I assume it's a river.
I don't know where else to go.
Like, I saw them do this little puppeteer.
I don't have a map for here, too.
Oh, I'm just gonna go to Sherwood.
Ah!
I hate this area.
Every new area I go to, I'm like, I hate it here.
I feel like...
Joey, is there any area you would like?
That's a good question.
It
is a slower Pogo, so I have to like...
Yeah.
Oh, get over it.
Here.
Okay.
There you go.
What the fuck?
Where's the... Oh, he killed him.
I was gonna say, what happened to the other Another bug.
Nice, I got the shards.
Every new area I find something new to hate.
It's actually very impressive.
What's that?
Ew.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's like a, it's like a jelly.
Or like a slime.
After I like kill it, it like reproduced and made more.
Okay, cheer up top.
I can't do dashes yet.
This looks like a boss fight.
I don't...
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay, it's just a normal trap shit.
You know what?
Oh, never mind.
There we go.
Oh, me.
Oh, my God.
I got stick bug.
Stick bug.
Please.
Dad, I'm getting stick bugged right now.
Stop.
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
He's barking at something outside.
Okay.
Oh, no, he's barking at me.
Oh, I forgot to give you a warning tree.
It's because I didn't give him his warning tree.
It was like, it says greenies.
I didn't give him his goddamn greenies.
Oh, my God, I'm so far.
I don't even know how to get there.
I got doubles.
sick stick bug.
He's poor this evening.
Robin, thank you.
Thank you.
Alright, fell hard.
I didn't give him his little his greenies.
And usually he gets it every morning and I didn't give it to him this morning because I was playing Silk Song.
It's been really fun.
I kept on streaming for six hours already or almost seven hours.
I've been having really fun so far.
And the moment I stopped playing, everybody's gonna beat this game in like two more days.
I wish I could...
Oh, shit.
I wish I could keep playing this week, but there's so many stuff to do this week.
Like, I want to finish a lot of my other obligations, too.
So sadly...
So sadly, we don't get another silk song until...
Until maybe, like, until next week, basically.
Ah!
Wait, there's something over there Oh shit, wait, that's fucked up
Oh my god Oh my I'm gonna lose my money But I got sick as charm
My money
didn't even get the charm
I'm sorry
I couldn't even get it It's not even a charm, it's like gear some shit that's fun but yeah by the time like we get to i get to play again everyone you guys can finally backseat me when i'm done when you guys can backseat me for next week's part two
that was embarrassing this guy the javelin bro is very annoying i will say oh
my god you are so and oh wait i don't even I forgot.
I don't have the magnet, so I have to hand grab all of these guys.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Thank you for the $30.
The $30.
Thank God.
What would I've done without that money?
It's like this way.
It wasn't even gear.
For $100 to $30, I am so lucky.
I am truly so lucky and so thankful.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my god!
god i hate these guys okay actually i can that's good nice that was the last guy okay
okay wow no i know wait that's god damn it god that's a bench
i don't have money
No money!
And none of these guys are religious zealots or whatever the fuck they're called.
Oh wait, there he is!
Oh my god!
Over here.
Wait, he's killing this guy.
Bro, what the fuck?
Whoa!
Oh!
I'll take those.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay, that's fine.
Give me!
Oh no!
Why was I so greedy?
Oh!
Ninochella, hack.
when you hear had a quarrel of vain of old bells the bugs there were snared silent on the web of silk it seems a pernicious trap of some unseen predator i left quickly making sure to avoid the glimmering threads i pass the town myself the thread sickness i've seen in like upon the roads but there does not discriminate the curse that strikes my town the town is driven focus A cold use of silk at a concerning scale.
If the path permits, I will investigate this source.
Okay, I...
Wait, I have $13?
Wait, I have...
Oh, wait, I'm free.
Wait.
I have enough.
Oh, my God.
I have just enough.
It's like 40, right?
It was $40, right?
Okay.
I don't know.
Ah!
Guys, it was $60.
Wasn't it $60?
Well, now we know.
maybe guys maybe we'll find
maybe we'll find oh
slow and steady maybe i'll find more religious religious bugs
okay that is good that is good
okay That is very good.
Friend.
Okay.
Oh, that guy is chasing me.
I needed him to come down.
Alright, good.
Okay, we're fine.
We still gotta figure out.
We gotta find out more religious bugs.
What is that?
Oh.
Oh, there's another platformer.
Oh, there's another chair here please where are the religious bugs i have to rob you oh my god that's not him
holy shit at least there's a dog bleeding oh my god get away from me did you guys see that he like fucking rat rushed at oh no okay it's fine oh it's fine because i have Pogo.
That's good.
I'm glad I have Pogo.
What the?
Okay.
Alright.
Come on, I've got you, buddy.
I've got you!
That's the child's first word.
My pogo buff.
Thank God.
Holy shit.
That is so much easier.
Okay, I jinxed myself.
I actually jinxed myself there.
But that is...
It's so much easier.
Oh my god.
Not nice.
Okay, I need you guys to get closer to me.
Oh, that's fine.
I can...
At least I have friends.
Oh, what?
Yeah.
There we go.
Yeah, I was not.
I did not hear about these guys.
There we go.
Easy.
I was like, no, fuck that.
No, this is a boss fight.
It's too empty.
I refuse to go there.
If it's too empty, I...
I know no no no no no no no no no no I need $60 I just need $60 I'll climb all of this up the moment I find a bench the
music stops okay oh my god holy shit Okay, this guy hates bugs.
This guy really fucking hates outside it.
Oh
my god.
Okay.
So this is where like, use the uppercut.
It's really hard to use the uppercut.
Because, um...
I have to use the...
I have to run sprint for it.
What the...
okay we're so close friend wait
there's another bench here it's more money it's more expensive oh my god okay let's go back we got the chair we got the chair That's all we needed.
The fact that the bench was more expensive, it makes me so sad.
We have the other bench now.
Now I don't have to worry about the potential boss fights.
Okay, this is a bench.
I recognize the bench.
It's gong gong Gong gong Yay Oh thank god Thank fucking god Alright now Now we can Now we're fine Yes we can't We don't have a map but that's okay Let me out Let me out, let me out Okay
Okay Oh shit Oh shit The projectile of this...
Like, it's so inconsistent.
Holy fuck.
The projectile for that javelin is so inconsistent.
Whoops.
Alright, now...
Now we can do this parkour again.
Okay.
Get out of here.
God, these guys are so annoying.
Holy shit, makes me so happy.
Oops.
It makes me so happy, I don't have to deal with the weird dash shit.
You know the weird dash thing?
Oh, it wasn't a boss fight.
You know what, I just didn't want to take my chances, okay?
It was an open area.
It could have been.
You don't understand.
The arrow was so open.
I wasn't risking it.
Wait, what?
What are these purple flowers?
Wait, what are these purple flowers?
What is that?
Holy fuck.
Ah!
I can't do this jump anymore.
The paw lip heart.
What the fuck is that?
Oh.
That damn stupid stick, but...
That's right.
I know you can't get over that ledge.
Is that a charm?
Oh.
What the?
I don't like that.
That's a face.
What the?
fuck that was a fucking face so what is this
oh my I'm so lost now I wish I have the map wait
boss fight what oh no oh no what
what oh Look at that!
Two damage!
Oh, what?
What are these guys?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm so scared!
I'm getting every fucking optional boss possible!
Okay.
I'm actually, I'm, I'm killed.
I'm, I'm just, oh.
He's, she's not?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
As long as she's not optional, I'm happy.
Wait, how did I, oh, I don't have a map.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, that's good.
I like how every boss I fight, I'm just like, optional.
If I can't first try her, you're an optional boss.
Okay, now I know that...
Okay.
That's bullshit.
What?
Oh, I can cut the...
I can cut the binds.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright, now I know.
Now I know I can cut the binds.
I don't know her hitbox is like big.
You guys notice that?
Because like at some points I was like there's no way that that can hit me.
But she has such a big hitbox.
It's like really hard to tell.
Okay.
Oh yeah I need to use vampir.
No.
I think I think magic build is fine.
Ah.
I didn't mean not greedy.
How?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, thank god.
I'm fine with that.
That's cool.
Kill your child, I guess.
Oh.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, this...
Okay, this build is actually crazy.
I like
this build.
Holy shit.
Are you serious?
Nice.
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, that's good
There we go All right
Yeah, that's what I'm saying her hitbox is fucking huge.
I have to be aware of the hitbox
Nice that's fucking right
This is I love this part
Oh, okay.
I just had to figure out his pattern.
Where does it lead?
I hate these guys, though.
These guys are fucking freaky.
Doki, you just hate all of them.
Exactly!
Oh, I fucked up the parkour part.
I gotta do it again.
Oopsie.
I gotta parkour this again.
I messed up.
They're creepy!
Exactly!
They're so creepy!
Look at them!
They're ugly as fuck.
It's just- I don't like that they're like plant faces.
Or like bug- they're like- they have the faces of- they have a face of a child and that's what It's like, ooh.
Okay, now that I...
Okay, honor swaps on parkour.
With this float, it makes parkour like baby mode.
This float plus the crest I have now, the...
Also, that crest is so broken.
Holy fuck.
That is a broken crest.
Yeah, no.
This is actually baby mode.
With it.
Okay, nice.
Oh, you're not real.
Like, I literally don't have to worry about parkour when I do this.
I think that's, like, the best part.
Because all I have to do is just float.
So I never have to worry about actually parkouring.
I want to...
I just want to get rid of him.
No, the beast has been very useful.
Um...
It's useful in, uh...
In that boss fight we had, but like after that, um...
Hmm...
Okay, that's pretty charged.
What?
Oh my god, I don't know what to do.
How the fuck?
Okay, I can't...
Okay, I need to farm him.
Okay, nice.
I got my HP back.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god!
Okay, that's not fine.
Oh my god.
I fucked it up.
But that's okay, I got my HP back again.
Like, baby mode.
Baby mode parkour.
Oh my god.
Another upgrade.
Daughter of a distant land.
We who remain here waited long.
Find our strength to yours.
Reclaim the future of our haunted kingdom.
Yeah, I think if you hate parkour section, get the Reaper crest.
It's so convenient.
It actually is.
It's so easy.
Yay!
I can walk live!
Hooking, finally!
Oh my god, now we're Jane silk sawing now.
Thank god.
We're finally Jane silk sawing.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, I see you.
Stupid bug.
Okay.
Where are these?
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I have to kill the nest.
Oh, my god.
They're coming for me.
Oh, oh,
my god.
they're coming for me there's so many children haha you left your nest you left your nest unprepared unguarded that's right you left your nest unguarded and unprotected for me to come in
i have alerted the horde the horde is dead
That's on them.
Like, it's stupid.
Wait, where am I?
Where is this area?
Oh, my God.
It's our babies.
Okay, I'm here.
Oh, I'm back here.
Is there anything else down here?
I wish I have a map.
It sure would be very useful by now.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out where the map is.
I'm trying to figure out, like, okay, I don't have money for a map.
I remember now.
I just don't have money for that.
Oh yeah!
We want it to go...
I remember now.
We want it to go this way.
Okay.
This way.
I know where Shakira is, but I have no money.
bro what the fuck is this a fast track oh it is it's a tram oh my god oh my god i have to spend there's so much stuff i have to spend on but like i just i'm broke i'm so broke
i'm mad there
he is i gotta mug this man
Wait, I know where to find more...
Okay.
Whoops.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
There you go.
I don't have a lot.
Maybe I can...
I kill him?
There you go.
Nice.
I need a fireman.
Can't kill me if I'm in the water!
No money?
I need just a bathroom.
Hang out with the stick bugs.
JK.
I'll be right back.
I used to bathroom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Gordon, Matt, and Miriam.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Alright.
We still have no map.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I know what to do.
Wait.
Yeah.
We got a backtrack.
Very, very back.
There you go.
Okay, how much was the tram?
Guys, how much was the...
Wait, actually?
Guys, how much was the tram?
80?
Okay, we don't necessarily have to backtrack.
We just need to get to the first bench, reset it, and farm this one guy.
It's the only way.
Alright.
We just farm.
This guy.
Oh my god, there is one.
And there's another 11.
We just gotta do that.
We gotta do that.
Three more times.
It's 80, right?
I need 80.
I don't remember.
How much was the trap?
He's gonna be our farm.
He is our one farm to rule them all.
This is a farming stream now.
80.
Okay.
I just need to do it with that.
There he is.
Get around here.
Your purpose.
Get over here.
Get over here!
There you go.
all right nice 69
but i know a really good farming spot after this area that we just we just need to go to the tram to take it there his glorious purpose is to be our little piggy bank it's beautiful his purpose will serve us very well yeah
it's the the area where it was literally all cultists.
Oh my!
Oh.
Okay, I really...
I need him to chill.
There we go.
I fucking slam dunked him into the ocean.
Oh, we did it!
All right.
And then we go this way.
Yeah, a little piggy bank.
I think that's...
Wait, where is it?
Was it here?
No, it was here.
The tram was above us, right?
Yeah, I just didn't want to deal with him.
I cannot be bothered.
There you go.
Oh my god!
What?
I got doubled.
I actually got double hit.
Yeah, get me my silk.
This better be the goddamn tram.
Nice.
I...
It was 60.
I didn't even need 80.
That's fine.
It's extra.
We just got a little extra.
Just in case, you know.
You always need a little bit extra to top it up.
Alright.
We go to Greymore.
We have to meet our new piggy banks.
I think it's like here.
Alright.
I think our new piggy bank was like here.
Oh god I hate these guys.
Alright.
All right, here we go.
Where's our piggy bank?
All right, there it is.
Right here.
Yippee.
And there's more.
Free money.
get over here nice pigs that can't fly there we go you know what I can actually just grab these guys there we go we just need to do this until we get 140 oh you're right I should just get the magnet on it doesn't matter I don't need a compass for now There you go.
Our little piggy banks.
Alright, nice.
Our glorious piggy bank.
You know what, let's get 300 just in case.
Thank God.
Because we need to buy several.
We need to buy...
Oh my god, they're fighting back for now.
That's cute.
They try to fight back.
How cute.
Alright, here we go.
How am I the crazy one?
They're the ones in a cut.
I'm just...
I'm just saving them.
Oh.
God, what a waste of money.
It's like they don't want to get robbed.
They're part of a cult.
I'm saving them.
I'm literally saving their lives.
There we go.
See, I'm a hero.
I'm liberating.
Yeah, I'm liberating their souls right now.
Then they'll go to my dad's heaven.
Okay?
They're believing in a false god.
There's only one God, and it's my mom and dad.
It could be a happy club.
They don't know that they're happy.
I'm here to teach them to be happy.
Don't worry.
I'm here to save their life by liberating their souls.
Nepo baby on a crusade.
Oh, I can, like...
Nice.
Okay, we need to get to...
Let's get to...
Okay, what do we need to buy?
We need to buy...
Oh my god, we gotta buy so many things.
Let's get to...
Fuck it, let's get to a thousand.
Their pain will never stop.
They're literally...
Oh, shit.
No, you ain't getting my money.
might as well
I'm making sure I'm making sure they get to go to my dad's heaven guys
what the fuck no oh thank god okay thank god he didn't drown okay maybe I'll do 300 I'll do 3 okay what do I wait I actually forgot what I'm trying to buy I forgot I forgot what I'm trying to buy trying to buy it yeah it's been so i've been farming them for so long i've actually forgotten what was my purpose okay i need to buy the last tool a map and a a bench right okay how much do i need for that two maps how far behind am i
Holy...
We're not getting the $500 key, guys.
We're not getting the $500 key.
That is a little bit too much farming.
Jesus.
Ah!
They fought back.
Oh, my...
It's okay.
I can get it back.
I can't believe it.
I got it back.
That's right.
You know, I was gonna stop.
Now I'm definitely not gonna stop.
Okay, is 400 enough for everything?
I think 400 should be enough, right?
That was supposed to be my last run.
But now...
Now...
Now we keep going.
Alright.
Oh, there we go.
It's always this one that dies last.
Alright, now that should be enough.
Okay, we can go back now.
Guys, we can go back.
Alright.
We go this way.
Go to the tram.
And then we go by...
Jesus Christ.
Chris, I need to try to remember everything I need to buy.
We buy the last trinket, the last tool.
And then we have to buy...
What do we have to buy?
We buy the last tool.
I want to make sure I...
But we have to buy our maps too.
Okay.
Does she have anything useful?
Okay, no.
Terrible tyrant.
Oh, it's not me.
Okay.
It's not... It's not me, so it's fine.
It wasn't me.
I was like, oh my god, how did they know?
Okay.
Belhar map.
The shellwood map that we needed.
Alright, and then we got to buy the last trinket.
Okay.
I was like, oh no, did they know?
No, they don't know, thank God.
Thank God they're too stupid to know.
They don't know that every time a crime was committed, I was last seen there.
Get the pins, the doors, the...
Guys, I don't have money for that.
I have more important things to spend right now.
Sit down here.
Okay, I need to put compasses.
I forgot where I am.
Oh nice, there you go.
Oh my god, we finally buy this.
It's been so long.
Tool acquired.
Okay, I don't even know what this tool is.
What the fuck?
Oh,
it's this!
Oh!
I said...
Wait, is there like...
I can't remember where this is.
Oh yeah, it's the fucking key.
I keep forgetting that's the key.
Okay, so it has charges.
How do I know...
Yeah, it's the... Okay, that's... that's pretty strong.
Wait.
That would have helped a lot.
I just realized.
Wait a minute.
That would have helped a lot during boss fights.
Oh, wow.
Man, I wish I knew that.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
That would have been nice to know a little earlier.
That's for sure.
I'm going to go back because I can now...
Yeah, that would have helped a lot in the beast fight.
Oops.
Okay, now that I can wall dash, I can do this.
Wait, no.
I thought there was something I need to do, like, what?
No, whatever.
Oh, it was back there.
It was in the motto.
I don't remember now.
Okay, I want to...
I want to do the wall jump one area.
It was here.
Because now I can do this now.
So I'm sure there's something here, right?
I knew it.
I knew it was money.
I need this.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I think I hate these guys the most out of all of them.
I definitely hate these guys the most.
Wait, that's it?
That's it?
Oh, I knew it.
Secret tunnel.
There we go.
Where does this go?
Oh.
Alright, time for a boss fight.
Oh, it's this quest.
It's the make-a-wish.
Okay, I got really lucky for that.
Ow.
All right.
Okay, I can jump for that.
That's good to know.
Oh.
Fuck.
I gotta be careful.
Ah, he's so fast.
The mines!
I forgot!
Okay, where am I?
We don't have to fight him yet.
We're so far anyway.
I'm not used to using him.
I'm not used to using the mines.
Okay, let's go to a tram.
Alright, let's pre- Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, now we know where he lives.
My money!
I almost forgot about my money.
okay wait okay we'll grab here
never mind we have to go back i hope he's not that hard i had i had so many detours today
we had so i'm i'm like fighting every boss i've encountered because i've been encountering him accidentally my money
Oh, oh, goodbye.
What?
Okay, that was bullshit.
That was bullshit.
Wait, you came back?
Okay, that's fine.
Was there anything this way?
Oh, yeah, I got the this.
Got it.
I hate these guys so...
I really...
I don't like these guys.
At all.
Like...
Ah.
These guys are so annoying.
They're annoying more so with the fact that...
Are you serious?
No!
I
lost the body!
No!
I killed those people and all I got was zero dollars.
I killed so many.
Back to the mines.
It's fine.
At least I bought everything I need.
I should have played safe.
I should have.
of.
I just, those bugs, ever since the friend shit, ever since the beast, I have a particular hatred for all of those bugs.
They annoy me so much.
You're broke.
No, you don't understand.
It's just, I don't have enough for the bench now.
Oh, we don't need it.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
I realized I forgot to...
Oh, I forgot to buy the bench.
I forgot to buy the bench.
I... I...
Spare a song for those who lay here silent.
By shrimp abandoned, they fell before the final ascent.
Who lives here?
Hello?
Oh, fuck!
I thought he was i thought he was an mpc i thought oh plus two plus two of course of course he does plus two they all do plus two oh they all do plus two they all do plus two
i'm going crazy i'm going crazy going crazy with the plus two damage if they all do plus two what's the point of having this much
hp all right oh it's this way it's fine i'll have magic for him as the light it's been gone
the light maybe he has guys maybe
Okay, maybe it has $80.
Yoink.
Okay.
Oh.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, he does so much damage.
Oh my god.
Oh, plus $31.
I'll take that.
He does so much damage.
Holy shit.
31.
I'm getting closer.
Maybe I can farm the stick bugs.
Okay, I need let.
I need HP.
So let.
Thank you.
I just need I need HP please please please Please spare me your your HP Please please I'm struggling here right now
Oh my god Spare me your soul
Your purpose is to let me slap you Isn't that beautiful Oh my god Friend Friend
Oh my god, get me out, get me out of here, get me out of here, nice, nice, I got my money.
Oh my god.
Okay, plus 12.
That's good.
Plus 12.
I'm getting my money.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god!
You're religious!
Thank god!
Oh, thank god!
My religious money!
Oh, thank god more!
I have enough!
I can buy a bench!
They died for a good cause.
Oh my god, which one's the chair?
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
What is this?
Which one?
This is the chair, right?
Is this the chair?
Oh, please tell me this is the chair.
What the fuck is...
Oh, that's the bead.
That's the bead thing.
Okay, that just shrugs your beads.
I remember now.
Where wealth is...
In a world where wealth is measured in rosary beads.
Okay.
Okay, now I can figure out what the fuck this place was.
He died for a good cause.
Oh.
I gotta...
I'm so hungry for...
for rosary beads.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay, I hope he comes.
She comes down.
Okay.
Nice.
Because these guys were... Oh, shit.
Get over here.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum.
Throw her $5.
It's worth it.
Oh, fuck.
Oops.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, it's because I...
I floated it.
Okay.
There we go.
I floated too soon.
What is here?
What's this side?
Oh, shortcut!
Gone, gone, gone, gone.
Gone.
Yay, chair!
Yippee!
Oh, this is a travel area.
Nice!
Unlocked it.
Okay.
Yeah!
It's just bottom map.
What is this?
I just...
But I just bought a map.
What is this place?
Oh, my...
Oh...
Where...
Where am I?
Where am I falling?
Oh!
My...
What the fuck?
Where did I...
Where did I go?
Oh no.
Okay, we're not.
We're...
We are...
How did I...
What?
How did I get here?
Alright, let's just...
Alright, let's go back.
I keep thinking to hit the bell Because of Hollow Knight But all I have to do is literally just call him I was so confused I fell so far I just kept falling
I was like Oh it's bone bottom It's another area Shit Okay Bone Wait I didn't go there What the fuck is over there Is that important?
No, can't be, right?
Yeah, that was a fucking big fall.
I was not expecting how far I was falling.
No.
Yeah, I fell for, like, 50 minutes or some shit.
This is, like, this is reverse parkour.
I feel like I'm doing reverse parkour right now.
No, the glide is most definitely very silly.
The worm ways!
Holy shit, this area is big.
I got a purse.
Oh, I hear it.
Ooh, shallow.
I've got him.
Lai, lai, lai.
Where is she?
I hear her.
I'm gonna grab Helos real quick.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh.
Oh, Shalom.
Oh, there she is!
Greetings, Shakira.
It was a welcome surprise to hear your calls.
Echo through these crumbling tunnels.
How goes the search for your master?
Poshanka, it is a difficult task to track anything in these caverns.
while the worms ceaselessly churned a rock.
Still, I can see that Master has traveled here.
Her path within this land swings, strangely.
I wonder at her intent.
It is no matter, though.
She can enlighten me when again we meet.
Until then, I'll continue in her shadows.
All right, $70.
I am poor.
Goodbye.
I will figure this out.
That wind will guide me, I guess.
Yes.
It might be a very...
Did this...
Was that two damage?
That was two damage, wasn't it?
I fucking knew it.
Fuck this.
I knew it.
I could feel the two damage in my blood.
The only ones that don't do two damage are these fucking damn colors.
this that's the only joy in life that I get oh
yeah oh
my god I wish I had my magnet oh yeah oh there you go whoa whoa whoa whoa slip slip okay oh my god I do this oh nice oh i don't i still don't have enough i still don't have enough oh my god wait was it 70 or 80 i've lost count that everybody wants money from me guys was 70 or 80.
we have enough
No.
Keep singing to me.
Oh my god.
I have just enough.
I'm like, actually like, like scrounging for pennies right now.
I'm like going to vending machines, checking the little slots of anybody like left cash in there.
I'm like going to longer maps, like being like, can you please spare some change?
I just, please, I just need like five dollars.
Like, please, maybe, like, you can, I, 25 cents, 125 cents is good enough for me.
Please, I spare some change.
Like, this is how I feel right now.
That sounds so damn sad.
That's all I'm feeling.
I know.
I know it sounds sad.
But this is my life now.
Please, sir, can I have some spare change?
wait are these children
you don't understand I have to kill these kids a kid for a kid
guys a kid for a kid oh my god what the fuck oh What the fuck?
Okay.
There are a lot of money.
Oh my god, okay, I almost fucked that up.
A kid for a kid.
It's only fair.
It's down there.
Man, if only I have a key.
Let's not go there.
That looked absolutely terrible.
That was very scary.
Yeah.
Okay, we just need one more mask for an HP.
All right, let's look at this again.
Okay, it's not as bad as I thought it was, but let's have HP first.
I wonder if the children respawn.
Yeah.
Okay, I actually need money.
I need to figure out something that...
What are the worms?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is way too risky.
This is...
Ah!
dolly dolly dolly that was way too risky um i don't think i should do that again
i don't know where to go
he just spit on me what what oh my shards that i don't know he literally just spit on me like i don't know what to do at that point just slowly uh Drift over there.
God, this area.
Oh my...
Okay.
Well, I guess I didn't need my money again.
I got stuck on the wall.
It's fine.
I had nothing.
I spent it all on the map.
Remember, guys?
It's okay.
I was actually broke.
So it's okay.
exactly what money exactly nothing to worry about i was already poor
all right i oh wait not here i don't know how to feel about this area
is he a boss fight oh oh
Okay.
Can I kill him?
Oh.
I'm gonna try and kill him.
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay.
This is like really hard.
Oh my god!
It's difficult because I'm like...
I have to like figure out...
time it correctly you know oh it's a plus of course i won't have it any other way listen thank you super chat thank you thank you yeah i jumped too high
oh okay i did not expect her to i didn't expect the worm to be there i what the
oh my god that's it i have to kill you guys now I need HP.
All right, there you go.
That's fine.
You guys had to die now.
All right.
Okay, I don't know if I can kill him.
Wait what?
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's so hard to control the jump.
Okay.
I'm not gonna try I'm just gonna run It's very hard to control the jump
Okay Yeah I gave up I gave up Oh my god It didn't matter
It didn't matter It was It was just a shortcut It was just a shortcut Oh my god, at least I get money that I'm gonna lose anyway.
I'm gonna fucking respawn that bug.
I need HP.
I'm gonna try and kill that guy then.
I want to know if he respawns or not.
I need to know.
Oh my god, I'm actually one HP.
I fucked up.
Okay, there you go.
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm gonna try and get full HP, and then...
He's so fast suddenly!
It's so weird!
He's like...
I hit him, but he doesn't like...
He's so fast.
Like...
I don't expect him to be that fast.
There you go.
Okay, now I'm full.
All right, let's try Let's see what we can I don't know if we can kill them But I want to try
Okay As possible
Oh my god The scary part is just the Okay I'm trying to like time this correctly
Oh my god Oh my god Oh Oh Oh my god, please.
MUD!
I hate these guys.
Excuse me?
That's bullshit.
I bet you, after I kill him, he's gonna respawn, isn't he?
He's gonna respawn.
This is the scariest game of peekaboo I've ever played.
this is actually such a scary game of peekaboo are you serious like
that's just rng
i can't do it here like how did it hit me i saw that i was underneath
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Scariest game of peekaboo in my life.
This is so dumb.
Oh my, I just hope he dies.
That's it.
This is a real endurance.
I know, right?
Oh shit!
Peekaboo!
5 viewers skip 12 minutes.
minutes skip 12 hours he will die right I wish I could use my needle it's too risky oh my god I did it the most intense fight of my life I got beast shard that's what the fuck is a beast shard oh my what the fuck is a beast shard I got it.
I told you.
The most intense peekaboo of my life.
Holy shit.
I've never peekabooed harder than I've had than I did before.
What a wild ride.
Where is this?
Moss home.
Never been here
I can't be bothered.
I'm just going to kill these guys.
Have you ever played peekaboo with your life on...
Oh my god, it's the first farm spot.
I remember this area now.
It's the very first Groundhog Day.
I remember you.
Okay, we don't have to go here, actually.
I want to go this back.
Because there is an area that we haven't gone to and it's near me falling down.
This brings back memories.
Yes.
The very first farm.
Oh, at least we can rob some people.
One more time.
And there's...
Oh, nice.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Jesus.
Maybe here?
There's something here.
Oh, my Oh my god!
Okay, that was some sick...
Oh!
Yay, money!
Okay, that was...
Now I can say that was some sick ass...
Sick ass reflexes right there.
Wait.
Oh, he's holding the fruit.
Remember that witch doctor lady that asked us to do that one mission thing and I didn't do it?
Oh!
Guess I can't do it again!
I guess I won't be able to do it again, guys.
Unlucky.
Okay.
Where can we?
Okay, we explored all of that.
What have we not got?
Oh, that area in Shelwood.
Rough.
I can't open anything.
Ada!
It's 300?
I'll think about it.
I want to explore that last area.
That I didn't go in shellwood.
No, it's not key time.
Not yet.
I want to go... Okay, it's down and up.
Okay, not this up.
This is where I saved the dog.
Okay.
yeah this way when will it ever be key time someday maybe one day but you said that 20 years ago maybe you just gotta be patient They'll never be Kidae if you're never patient, guys.
Just gotta wait.
Good things come to those who...
Oh my god.
Goddamn stick, bud.
I hope he drowns.
Okay, this is the area I haven't gone yet.
What's this?
Oh, someone is here.
Hello?
Oh?
Shh.
Shill, white mask, red cloak, bug, a living bug.
To me again.
A bug I am, at least in part, but you're something quite different.
I apologize if I roused you from some deep slumber.
Slumber, non-sleep.
But now is the waking.
Growth, time of birth.
The time of birth approaches.
Heed, bug.
Was he just born?
Only you are left.
No more tread here.
None.
For the right.
The pallet hearts there needed.
Bring them here.
For the right.
Oh, I have some.
Wish promised.
I have so many promises.
I'll eat you.
These pot...
They can be found.
about the wood but poly hearts found in the wood yes bug seek out the purple blooms inside the hearts the time of birth to purchase pull aparts are needed bring them bug and power will be shared i need how okay oh i finished i found all the children all right goodbye we'll never meet again
Yeah, no.
I guess we'll never meet again.
I mean, I know, like, these bugs.
Oh, my God.
I actually need...
I actually need to get out of here.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I actually need to get out of here.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Okay, nice.
Free magic.
I'm just gonna leave.
He wins.
He won.
Alright, I have...
I have Bell right here.
But like I said, I can't access this anywhere.
Ring ring!
Alright, let me figure out where to go.
Where's my map?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
What?
I guess?
Graymoor?
I didn't do half a graymoor.
I'll deliver the children.
And then...
Oh, here.
Hunter's March.
There is a place in Hunter's March, too.
Hmm.
Okay, I'll do...
I will do...
I'll deliver the children first, and then...
Okay, where's that children?
Tomorrow.
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, it's my little pet dog.
He's just a big-ass dog.
Is it bone bar?
Or is it deep docks?
Which is closer.
I don't remember.
I'll go tomorrow first.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, whoops.
Well, guess I'll never need that.
I guess I don't need the needle, guys.
Just in case.
I wonder if there's nail upgrades.
I haven't seen any nail upgrades yet.
So I don't know.
All right, here's the children.
Hello, I found all your kids.
Look, look!
So many fleas have joined the caravan.
What a miracle.
We can't thank you enough for honoring our humble wish.
Yay, wish granted.
There's so many fleas, fleas, for us to be united with, though, and we rested long enough.
The caravan must head higher.
Oh, but stranger, how remiss of me!
I introduced myself earlier while ever asking for your own name.
Forgive me, please, what shall we call you?
You may call me Hornet, Flea Master.
Know that I, like you, am glad to see your fellow fleas safe with your caravan.
travel alone.
I still have a long journey ahead of me.
If I come across more fleas, I will assist where I'm able.
Oh, Vavenda!
That is to say, incredible!
What a beautiful thing for me to hear.
Dear friend, Miss Hornet, our caravan must be away now.
Toward the wide, more high above.
Would you travel with us as an honored guest?
Sure.
Yes.
Excellent, excellent!
Let us make be off without delay.
Rouse yourself, please, for the caravan roams once more!
Alright.
Oh, shit.
I'm in the caravan!
I'm gonna blow my nose.
Wait, is this a new area?
Mushka!
The journey here was long, but we didn't lose a single flea.
I'm told it's good luck to bring guests along when traveling so we must have you to think
oh i want to play longer but my voice is starting to get straight we'll fight one more boss and then we'll call it i trust the trip was agreeable for you a pleasure perhaps nestled in with our dear little ones they certainly made for energetic travel companions i've not often had opportunities socialized with such a spirit of sorts.
Splendid!
And now you must go and see Yushkin, sitting there by the bubbling cauldron.
After long travel, we drink to revive our spirits.
Okay.
Let's go drink the cauldron.
The Hushka went for shelter from the thick gray hair is heavy and wet.
I'm worried for the little fleas' health in this land, and they make play in the filthy water.
I say them.
Stop!
But they just laugh and splash on me.
They are lack of respect.
Most bugs instinctively obey those with strength and will.
Speak with authority or your commands may go unheeded.
Really?
It's Flea Master's job to teach the flea such.
I will just rest here in the time to move on.
Uh, wait, where's the cauldron?
Where's the cauldron?
Oh, here.
Don't get it.
Don't snaw.
Miss Hornet.
Is it?
Welcome to our new camp.
The traveling is done, and so we drink.
He walked over?
Okay, I'm gonna give him a little snack.
Okay, I'll be right back.
He hungy.
Alright, I'm back.
He, like, walked over.
He got closer.
He's like, how dare you?
It's no better way to revive spirit than to drink the famous flea brew.
I'm just finished the batch.
You are a friend.
Founder of Lost Little Fleas.
Here, take bottle of Fleet Brew with you.
We'll keep you warm while travel.
I'm always brewing here, so I have no fear.
The drink plenty.
Return whenever you're waiting for more.
What is that?
Where am I?
I'm in Graymoor.
Wait, I'm in Graymoor.
Oh!
Wait.
Wait, that shit is OP.
Okay.
That's pretty fucking OP.
That's for sure.
There's like...
Okay, this area I could go to.
I guess I'll go up?
It says...
Yeah.
It says temporary increases the speed of movements and attacks.
It's a consumable...
Yeah, it is.
Okay, there's something up top that I haven't got yet.
I really hate the scissor people.
These guys are annoying.
Yeah, it gives an attack up.
Okay, um, I just want to see what's at the top.
God, fuck off!
Get out of here!
Yeah.
There's something up top.
Oh, no?
Oh, it's up here.
There we go.
I'll go this way first.
What?
Oh, my god.
A fucking horse.
These one are the more annoying one.
Actually...
Friend.
There
you go.
They're so annoying to fight!
Oh
my god.
There you go.
Friend!
These guys are so annoying to fight.
Holy fuck.
They just do so much.
They do way too much.
For like a small enemy.
Which I don't lay.
Me don't like that.
You should do less.
Okay, I did it.
I don't know how to get there.
How the fuck do I even get up top?
Okay.
Oh, I hear some noises.
And I don't like these noises I'm hearing.
Are you serious?
Damn it.
No!
Oh, yay.
Okay.
Yippee.
What's over here?
Oh.
Yay!
Pacor!
Oh, it's just shard bundles.
Oh, just nothing.
Just nothing.
It's fine.
I wonder if I...
I'll take this.
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Cheezing works.
I had to know.
I need to know if cheezing works in this game.
That's good to know.
Okay, there's nothing here.
just a little cheese okay this way oh what the fuck the random rat out of nowhere where did this random rat come where did he come from god stupid rat bugs a horse they come over here after I'm cheat after I was cheesing oh god oh Oh god.
Oh god, they're everywhere.
Get these fucking crows and rats out of here.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh god, there's more.
Oh!
Oh my god!
There's more of them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god All right, there you go
All the money fell down
It's not fair
Please leave me alone Jump up jump over there jump over there.
Yes land there.
Yes, yes land there There you go Yes, no no enemy no enemy little guy no no just land down let that it's so safe.
It's so safe.
Just keep... No, no.
Does he know I'm here?
He doesn't know.
You're so safe.
You're such a fucker.
There you go.
Oh my god.
This guy is actually so tanky.
Holy fuck.
There we go.
Oh my Oh my god, he is so tanky.
Okay, I just want to know where to go.
That was the most stressful fight I've ever had.
Oh my god, there's more.
How much more?
I'm like actually slam dunking them I'm slam dunking them right now
Okay What do I get out of this Oh Now I have more Wait what's that oh I have longer silk Nice
I think Silk song Has more annoying enemies
than than Hollow Knight.
I felt more annoyed than fighting any of the other characters in Hollow Knight.
Gone, gone, gone.
Gone, gone, gone, gone, gone, gone, gone, gone, gone, gone, gone.
Okay, nice.
I wrote on my map.
Like, the flying birds are not fun.
Like, right now.
Like, like, right now.
Nobody likes them.
And then there was the...
Oh my god.
I just...
And then there's, like, those metal ones, too.
The bone guys.
Those guys were not fun as well.
There's a lot of...
fun enemies and then the fucking rats then there are the rats oh my god there he is again I
wanted to go here for a bit oh my god I didn't even see this guy I'm gonna open the shortcut wait did I open Okay, nice.
All birds are evil except for me.
Oh.
I'm ready.
Oh, I'm not ready.
But, like, what else can I do?
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I thought...
Every time I see, like, an open corridor...
I just expect the worst, you know?
An open arena.
I just expect the worst thing possible.
I'm so paranoid.
I
am...
Yes, sir.
Okay, I need to remember that these guys have, like, money in there.
That's a lot of birds.
Oh, never mind.
Paranora is deserved.
Always be paranoid!
Wait, what am I?
What do I have?
Always be paranoid!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, fucking course you hit me.
Oh Wish I could grab that right up
Friend oh shit
There we go.
I had to do that There's more I Killed the priest
What do you what do you mean more?
I nearly killed the bird priest.
Oh my god.
I'm dead here.
No, I'm dead.
I'm actually dead.
There's no way.
I jumped into it.
I...
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Okay, it's not that far.
Thank god.
It's this way.
And then we just go straight.
Just keep swimming.
Alright.
There's so much money above me too.
Like the little beads area.
But I can't.
I can't get anything from that.
There you go.
Okay.
Fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
I hate these guys.
I hate them.
I realize like my magic lasts as long as As long as I don't get hit, so which is pretty difficult to do because they love to hit me.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god, Ice Tree Fighter that!
Holy shit!
That was insane.
Wow, some Chun-Li shit right there.
They are not cute.
They are absolutely not cute.
Let's go, Justin!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh
My god
Friend slow-mo That's safe, let's go Justin
I got the I had to save for the heal there was no thing else I could do That was so scary.
What did it do?
Did it raise?
Oh yeah, 100%.
If I knew these were the enemies I'm fucking facing, I would have.
It's just free money?
Oh my, get out.
This isn't for you.
Was this literally for money?
That was it?
I can't believe Toki's complaining about the free money.
There's no way.
There has to be more.
To be fair, this did not feel free.
I earned this money.
It was.
That was actually it.
There's nothing else here.
No, I opened these.
I've opened these to grab the jewels, the beads there.
Oh my god, that was it.
I hate the bird, the bird bugs.
I hate them so much.
I...
That was it.
Oh, maybe this.
Oh, wait, I opened this.
Where the amazing gameplay and the multiple pairs.
Psycho, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you guys have been enjoying it.
I've been...
I'm sad now.
I hate them.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
The worst part is that they are not easy to farm at all.
They are not easy.
Oh my god, I see the birds.
They're literally waiting for me.
Okay,
shortcut.
I'm so confused what happened.
I'm, like, living by the edge right now.
That's what happened.
I am not okay.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got played so careful.
What's over there?
I'm gonna die to this.
I...
I'll do this When I'm not one HP I
That is not something I'm willing to risk
What They ambushed me They actually ambushed me These fucking freaks The birds.
Oh, thank God.
I opened a shortcut here.
Oh, thank fucking God.
Where's the cocoon?
Oh, there it is.
I leave.
Okay, I leave.
Oh, my God.
I leave.
Oh, fucking court.
Oh my...
Speedrun!
Yeah!
Guys, I did that intentionally.
Speedrun!
I lived.
I wanted to do that.
Daughter of the Sunland, we who remind have waited long.
Find our strength to yours.
Reclean the future of our haunted kingdom.
Oh my god, I'm getting all the power-ups.
Wait, I think this is...
Is this the last one?
It's double- Oh wait, I still have the crystal dash to do.
Redstorm.
It's Adidas!
Oh!
It's literally Adidas!
Okay.
Watch this.
Adidas!
Okay, and I still get hit.
Okay.
Never mind.
I thought I looked so sick.
And it didn't matter anyway.
I'm sad.
Ow.
It didn't matter.
I did still look sick.
Okay, now where do I go?
I feel like I...
Who the fuck?
Oh, hey.
Three fold pins.
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
Oh my god!
I'm here!
Looking for me, bitch!
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, I am not dying to a rat right now.
Okay, I don't think they...
Oh, fuck it again!
I was like, I...
Oh my...
They're so tanky.
Let's go, Justin!
There you go.
We saved another fleet.
Sick.
Gaming.
World star!
Oh my god, I just want to fight a boss.
I mean, I explored a lot of parts of this map.
Nice move, Justin.
What have I not explored?
I guess I don't know if I have to go there.
That's the thing.
I haven't upgraded my...
Oh, wait.
She can just...
Where's my chair?
She can just do that?
Take away my chair?
My chair is gone.
I mean, I guess I have this chair.
I don't know if I like Threadstorn.
I literally used it and then like...
And it felt like nothing happened.
I need to buy another memory slot though.
I'll just slowly float over.
Where do I want to go?
Oh wait, nice.
Money first.
Because I feel like the...
Okay.
I need her to, like, not jump in.
Yeah, I don't...
I think...
I don't know, actually.
I can't tell.
Do you guys think the needle or the...
Or Adidas is better?
Oh my god, that guy almost killed me.
I guess better for a boss.
You're right.
Adidas is better for the boss.
I didn't go at the very top.
Let's see what's at the very top.
Much hunting has you done?
Assomi, sweet little creatures in our records.
Nula is drooling from such exos of learning.
Please keep working.
Okay.
Harder to miss.
That's true.
Okay.
Oh, I thought like I could get somewhere from while riding while jumping that okay there is one spot i haven't gone to
maybe i should go there oh wait that's where oh i have to go from all the way up there okay
i'll go all the way over there that's annoying Here, give me a...
Let me look at this.
I don't need this.
Is there anything here?
No.
Okay.
I have to go...
Go all the way up.
I'm trying to explore as much as I can on the map to figure out where to go.
What the fuck?
I hate them.
I hate these guys.
I hate him.
My hate will never end for these guys.
He's like, I'm gonna get you.
I'm gonna get you.
And then there's the rats.
Okay, I'm gonna go left side.
I haven't gotten the left yet.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
It's over here.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
He disappeared.
Knock, knock.
Who's bothering me now?
Leave the great Yonobie in peace.
Shushu!
Oh my god, this guy's are annoying.
That guy's fucking annoying.
No!
Should I say Unless you brought a worthy specimen with something truly nasty inside then Otherwise leave the great Yarnaby in peace I'll call him again Nano Oh okay I don't have anything cool I guess I Sorry the great Yarnaby I don't have anything cool What's up top Is this an arena that I have to worry about about later?
Wait, wait.
Wait.
Is there anything here?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
The freight?
I steal her fucking money.
That's right.
You deserve it, bitch.
You wouldn't open the door from me?
Goodbye to your goddamn rosary.
I haven't gone up.
okay it's this way and then this way she deserves it are you see okay he just does a double jump i'm not here for you yeah you ain't my money now just be a bitch oh i forgot i can't ah there was a reason why we couldn't get there oh but there's something up at the very top,
too.
Can I actually get there?
Alright, let's see.
Let's see if we can parkour that.
Carl!
Ow!
Rude!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I might have to actually use them as a platform.
Oh my god!
Okay, we're gonna finish this out.
Unless...
Oh wait, no.
Ha ha, JK.
I have wall jump.
It's like that boom dogs clip.
Uh-huh.
What am I...
No.
What am I doing?
Ha-ha.
I'm white.
What am I doing?
Ha-ha.
I have...
I have wall dash.
Sinner's road?
Oh.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
The floor is actually lava right now.
The floor is lava.
Do not, I repeat, do not go touch the door.
Oh, it's like a prison.
Oh, it's a prison now.
I hear you.
Jesus.
It's not here.
Or is it higher?
I don't know.
I have no map.
I have no direction to base this on.
just float down.
Leave me be, Traveler.
Better accept this kingdom's cruelty than rage, harm helpless against it.
To waste in a cell, forgotten.
This knows worse of fate than the haunting that binds Harlem's many fragile minds.
As you wish, prisoner.
It's like, alright.
Whatever.
Alright!
Oh my god, it's poison swamp.
There has to be a power up for that.
I refuse to believe there is no.
We're there.
We're in poison swamps.
Oh my god.
Get these maggots off me!
I think I might die.
I might die up.
Oh my god, they're still there.
They're still there sucking my fucking life blood.
Oh my god, they are actually...
It's never stopped.
I'm at poison swamps.
This is the dark souls of Metrovania.
I'm all...
Okay.
How do I...
How do I get there?
Okay.
I have to go to Sinner's Road, but to get to Sinner's Road I...
It's Bloodtown 2.0.
I can't believe it.
They brought me back to Blighttown.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
I messed up there.
Is it here?
No.
What?
Damn it.
Oh my god.
Almost let the rat get me.
I know.
I have $500.
Guys.
If there's anyone that knows, it's...
Oh my god!
My!
Slow and steady.
Slow and slow.
Guys, he's...
Guys, he's camping me.
Um...
Oh.
I do not feel so good.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Ring,
ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
I rest that bone barrel.
Objective, survive.
First off, I'm finding a bench so I can sit down.
Sit down, and then we go back to our cocoon.
Oh, that was so scary.
Graymoor.
I was like, where was this place?
Okay.
Oh, so scared.
Oh.
How?
Oh, my God.
This guy.
The long boy.
The long millipede.
I feel like every enemy is definitely very well designed and unique.
But, oh my gosh.
The common enemies are so much more frustrating than Hollow Knight.
um this thank you for the welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome yeah it's very rough and they do like combo damage too which is the rough part
they're very well designed but they do combo damage for like
oh this goes down okay oops oh i could have oh i could have taken the elevator I did not realize.
It's just, it's definitely a jump.
Like, like I said, like, Hollow Knight was like, welcome to kindergarten.
And then Silk Song was like, now you're in university.
And I'm like, huh?
Oh, God!
Oh,
don't let the dogs get you.
Don't let the dogs.
get you oh my god they got oh my god don't let them get you i don't even oh there it is
okay dog is above me dog is coming dog is coming i repeat dog dog is coming Oh my god, and then I find Rat
Okay I'll stay down here, goodbye Goodbye
What is impressive is that Every time I'm like There's no way This map could get anywhere And then every time, they impress me with a new map, with a new section that I hate.
Oh, oh.
Thank God.
I don't know where I am, and I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
Please!
Oh my please!
Okay.
Holy shit, friend.
It's like, what could possibly...
Yeah, it's like...
Surely it can't get worse.
And then...
It can.
It can and oh my god.
It's terrible.
It can absolutely get worse You're like little flies I
forgot I rested on this chair
Oh my god It's so far It's even further away It's even further away Oh my god I left it even further than...
Okay.
I'm gonna start spending my money.
I can't.
I'm hoarding my money for some reason.
Okay, where's the elevator?
Guys, does anyone remember how to get to the elevator?
Because I don't.
It's like here.
Okay, at least it saves time.
I don't know how to upgrade.
There's like no area to upgrade at all.
If I knew, like, um, I haven't met anybody yet.
That is like, there to upgrade stuff.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
The fucking guard dogs.
I keep thinking.
birds were really bad i hated the birds and now i'm like no no no no the the fucking oh my god where is oh there it is
i'm just getting higher i'm just i'm like i'm not intentionally try to go anywhere.
I swear to God.
Oh my this
is bad.
Oh shit.
There's a lever.
There's a bench.
Are you?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
I did it!
Oh my!
This area...
No!
This area... This area sucks the most.
This... The fear...
This area... I found the new worst area.
I...
It's this area.
Where's my fucking...
Give me my bench, please.
Oh my god, it's stuck.
It's actually stuck.
It's stuck.
Had thought not upon closer note, look, I found the fragments of trail winding through these ruins.
Perhaps you saw something here that I did not.
thinking where mine are clouded I can't believe it stopped I am not okay right now like there's no way it's asking me to swim please there's I am not using the markers there's no way
do you think I should swim underneath that do you think that is smart wait she said something I wasn't she did I did I was too tilted I was so tilted I was just I was so tilted I did it No!
I paid sixty dollars!
I don't know what to do!
I'm actually stuck here!
Guys, do I do it?
Do I do it?
Why is it stuck?
It's not.
Oh my god!
How do I fucking fix it?
Why is it stuck?
Why?
I don't understand.
But why is it stuck?
Okay.
I gotta figure out how to get home.
Give me a sec.
How do I get home?
Wait, where am I?
Can I just fall down?
Oh my god.
I could just fall.
It's dog time.
No!
I'm thinking.
I got...
I got chopped by a dog.
At least it's closer.
I just gotta get through it.
I gotta get through the dog.
The dogs don't fight.
The dog.
Holy fuck.
I think that air is definitely the next step in...
Okay.
My plan.
I wanted to fight a boss, but I don't think I want to be here anymore.
I don't want to play that area.
I don't like the poison swamp.
I do not like the poison swamp.
Do I have enough walkie?
I don't know.
I just need to...
I need to get past the dog first.
oh my god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god they're coming after me oh fuck it's over here all right how much money do i have at 250 oh yeah i don't have okay so we buy wait Okay, we can buy...
Alright.
Here's the plan.
We buy the mask shard.
So at least we have extra HP.
Now I don't know.
Okay, tram is this way.
Okay.
Holy shit.
I really don't want to go back to that area.
I don't...
I can't... I don't know.
Does the nail smith even exist?
Does it even exist?
We'll never know.
I wish we know.
Oh my god, I can actually buy this.
Thank god.
Sorry, the needle smith.
Alright.
I don't, I really, really, okay, we'll fight, we'll end today's stream with a boss fight, and I rather fight, I rather fight, I'll fight this boss, I'll fight the skull tyrant, because I really, I really don't want to deal, go back to the poison area,
I, I, I don't think I'm strong enough anymore, I, I.
It's here.
I know it's here.
I'm not strong enough.
Oh yeah, six lives.
I am still three shot.
Which way is it?
Is it this way?
For the shortcut?
Right?
Yeah.
Oh, fucking course that gets me.
Wait, he doesn't like...
I'm gonna say, why didn't he ricochet there?
Okay.
Oh my god, I didn't open the shortcut.
I did not open the shortcut.
Okay, that's fine.
That is fine.
I hate them, but that is okay.
Wee.
It's this way.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
I'll just really go back.
This is the boss I will fight.
Because I am done.
Are you okay?
That's okay.
This is evil.
This is actually evil.
This is so evil.
There we
go.
It's this way.
Alright.
I'm going to open the shortcut first.
Before anything.
We will open the shortcut.
Okay.
There we go.
I have to heal.
Oh, I should have saved it, though.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
What?
Okay.
That's okay.
I opened the shortcut.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
Yeah.
It was indeed not fine.
Oh, I sh- oh my god.
Where did you come from?
Wait a minute.
I was like, maybe, maybe, maybe he doesn't go past the edge, you know what I'm saying?
You know, like, oh, maybe, maybe he'll, like, stop at the edge, and I'm like, oh, Lord, you come in.
I have no, I wanted to, no, I absolutely wanted to cheat.
100%.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Adidas!
Adidas, please!
Friend!
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
I'm trying not to.
I'm trying not to, like, get stuck.
Right?
Okay.
That's good.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, that is definitely not so good.
Yeah.
I have to focus so hard.
Because I'm so scared
Holy shit I
have to focus so hard
Adios I need to go on the other side He put me to the edge How
much?
How much Bucky each beat Do you have oh my god his jaw missed it that's bad oh my god oh my god of course the rock hits me at the end i got crowd fragment okay i gotta crowd imagine if i died from that died from the fucking fucking rock hitting me in the end collected from defeating the skull tyrant okay
it would most it would be a fucking saddest tragedy alright let's go to the bench and collect our wish
I need to make sure he's dead friend friend It would be such a sad tragedy if that was how I was gonna go.
What's this?
What?
What the...
Okay, I got...
What am I looking at?
Track.
What am I tracking?
That's fine.
I gotta know.
I'm just trying to figure out what the fuck I'm tracking right now.
I'm being chased by 20 different things.
But that's not gonna stop me.
Okay, me.
Okay, it's gonna stop me.
It has stopped me.
Do I have to track it again?
Oh my god, I have to do this again I have to do this again It has It has stopped me, guys It has indeed
Alright Now that I know I can take my time I got confused I was like, what am I tracking
nothing has stopped her right guys yeah yeah all right we will stop them oh wait oh they're not chasing me anymore oh no they are just very slowly oh
my god okay give me a sec i am going through a got there you go okay I don't know if I have to like I'm a unit oh what the fuck okay I thought I was gonna kill it before it kills me but the thing is I don't know if there you go okay we're gonna deal with these guys first before anything all right now oh
what what okay do you think he's still there guys do you think he's still there he should still be there right
it should be fine right yeah Oh My god, oh
My god, what am I fighting?
I'm fighting hell right now.
I'm fighting my inner demons right now
I'm actually fighting my inner demons
We did it I... I did it.
I made a... I made a wish came true, guys.
I made another make a wish come true.
Oh my god.
Look at me, go.
I hope this child is happy.
I made his dreams come true.
to make a wish.
There's no doubt about it.
We'll never know.
Maybe by next week, someone can finally backseat me.
By next week, someone would have completed the game, and I can finally get backseated.
For those who don't know, so there's this thing over here, and every time you complete a thing you make a wish come true and the make a wish board so i've been helping the i've been helping them i did it wasn't this somebody's make a wish whose mission is this
oh my god there's two more
all right we're calling it here i have I had a good time.
I...
It was fun.
I wish I could play more, but my voice is getting really strained, so I want to rest it now for tomorrow.
Has my sponsor been announced yet?
Let me double check.
I don't know.
I go check right now if my sponsor has been announced yet for tomorrow.
Yeah?
It has?
Oh, shit, what is it?
If it has, then...
Oh, wait, it has.
Yeah, okay.
For those who don't know, I am in the next Tomorrow Season preview, and I am on Tim the Tapman's team.
So I'll be on...
And Ninja, by the way.
I...
I'll be on a team with Tim the Tapman and Ninja tomorrow.
and we're gonna be fighting against xqc um tomorrow so i yeah i'm on a team with ninja and tim it's gonna be pretty i don't know how i don't know i don't know how to how to like expect it but i think our team will definitely be the toxic raging content team um yeah um so i'm really excited i'm I'm,
um, I'm very, very excited to, um, um, play on that team and, like, uh, check out, yeah, check out the season, check out the next season with, uh, Angela, who is holy fucking abs, crazy ass.
Um, but it's gonna be very exciting.
Yeah, I don't worry.
I don't think I'm gonna be the one that needs to lock in, guys.
Out of all of us, I am pretty sure I am.
not the one that needs to lock in
if anything I'm pretty sure someone else has to pick up the slack and it's not gonna be me but I'm super excited I can't wait for tomorrow oh and J3 yeah I'm gonna be on a team with J3 Tim and Ninja so yeah yeah So it's wrist time.
I'm going to wrist my voice for tomorrow.
But anyway, I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed the reveal of Doki Knight in the cinematic Dokiverse.
I'm really happy with this new skin suit.
I just thought it would be, you know, something special because, you know, I thought it was really cute.
Like I said, I saw, I'll show you guys who the artist is.
okay so that is from meal pal i saw her post her uh hollow like i saw her post her night uh night skin suit and i saw last week and i was like oh my god that's so cute i want one too and i asked her if she can make me one i was like oh the idea if you can make it before silk song like for my silk song stream that would be most ideal and she literally like done so um so huge shout out to really really cute and i'm really happy with how it turned out and a huge shout out to all the fan artists that drew doki night i received so many fan art of doki night and i like i sent like various like various fan art for to new to inspiration um so um really a huge shout out to all my fan artists that uh helped out with like giving me like the concept art and conceptualizing everything um to create this so i'm very happy and Like,
and then my idea, the idea of dad being grub was my idea.
And I thought it was so cute.
And then I was like, I was like, I, at first she, Neil gave her, gave dad like a knife.
And I was like, no, I want a gun.
Bam, bam.
So that's why he has a gun, too.
Pop, pop.
thank you again i'm gonna rest now as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys